THE ORDER THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE. TO TO ORDER
WILL BE TAKING A COUPLE OF
THINGS OUT OF ORDER AND PROCEED
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
FOLLOWING LAST YEAR LAST WEEK'S
HEARING I WANTED TO CLARIFY HOW
I'M GOING TO BE.
CONDUCTING THE PUBLIC HEARINGS
GOING FORWARD.
IF IF THE ISSUE IS GOING TO BE
HELD OPEN THEN WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO DO IS GO THROUGH ALL THE
ISSUES ON THAT WITH THAT AGENCY
AND THEN HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING
ON ALL THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE
HELD OPEN.
IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A VOTE ON
THE ISSUE THEN I'LL HAVE THE
PUBLIC HEARING INTEGRATE THAT
HOPEFULLY AT THE TIME THAT WE
HERE AT PRIOR TO YEAH I HAVE THE
HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING PRIOR TO
THE VOTE THAT'S MY THEORY.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TAKE
OUT OF ORDER THIS WILL BE ISSUE
NUMBER. TWENTY ONE IT'S WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER ON THE
UTILITY COSTS ADJUSTMENT IF WE
CAN HAVE THE SCIENCE CENTER COME
FORWARD.
IT'S STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING --
THIS IS.
A FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND AND SIX THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
GIVEN THE L. A. D. W. P..
INCREASE UTILITY COSTS PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
JEFF RUDOLPH PRESIDENT IN
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER --
THIS IS A REQUEST TO INCREASE
UTILITY BUDGET DUE --
TO INCREASES AND UTILITY COSTS
FROM LA DEPARTMENT OF WATER
POWER THAT HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN --
NORMAL AND IT'S JUST THE RATE
INCREASES HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
EACH YEAR IT'S GOTTEN TO BE A
HUGE BURDEN ON THE BUDGET --
WE'VE TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO
REDUCE OUR ENERGY USAGE AND EVEN
THAT IS NOT. TO THE TUNE OF
ALMOST OF A THIRD OF OUR
UTILITIES HAVE BEEN REDUCED
THROUGH THE ENERGY SAVINGS
PROJECT BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
TO OFFSET THESE INCREASES IN
COSTS.
NO GOOD DEED GOES UNPUNISHED.
HI LA -- DO
YOU HAVE A POSITION.
THIS COMPUTER SAID THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I WE DID NOT HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY -- I'D
CENTER RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS ONE YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THE SOARING
COSTS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
OF OUR ENERGY WE DO A GREAT JOB
AT THE SCIENCE CENTER IN THE
HOPE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MOVE THROUGH THIS AS WELL.
OKAY STAFFER CONDITIONS TO HOLD
THIS MATTER UP AND WHAT'S OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING ANYBODY HERE
FROM THE PUBLIC. TO COMMENT ON
THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE OKAY CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING WE WILL HOLD THIS.
MATTER OPEN LOOK FORTY HEARING
FROM YOU LATER ON WHEN WE BRING
UP TO THANK YOU SCIENCE CENTER
COMES BACK [inaudible]
LET'S SEE.
LET'S.
IF WE CAN.
IF WE CAN I GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN N. NINETEEN THIS IS THE
TAHOE CALIFORNIA TAHOE
CONSERVANCY WE HAVE TWO ISSUES
THAT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD.
ALL THE MAUPIN.
HE SHOULD LIKE TO CALL UP.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN THIS IS
THE ALTAR MERA PUBLIC ACCESS
PROJECT THIS IS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR PROP. SIXTY EIGHT
FUNDS [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CALIFORNIA TAHOE CONSERVANCY.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO ARE ITEM EIGHTEEN IS A SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR REQUESTS
FROM PROP SUCCEED FUNDING FOR
THE STUDY PHASE OF THE ALTA MIRA
PUBLIC ACCESS PROJECT.
HI THIS IS A PARTICULAR PROJECT
TO CONNECTS RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS TO THE CITY OF
SOUTHLAKE TO THE LAKE FRONT IT'S
A SIGNATURE PROPERTY AND
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
CONNECT WITH A SERIES OF BIKE
AND RECREATION AND BEACH TRAILS.
AS WELL A SOME HABITAT
IMPROVEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION RIGHT ALONG LAKE
FRONT OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE.
OKAY YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OUR
DISCUSSION LAST WEEK WE DID PROP
SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING.
TO DIG DOWN INTO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SO WE UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THE ASK IS WERE
HOLDING THIS MATTER OVER.
HELLO DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
RIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
THIS ALTA MIRA PUBLIC ACCESS
PROJECT.
AT LAKE TAHOE.
TING NOBODY INTERESTED LET'S
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING WILL
HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN --
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR
OPPORTUNITY ACQUISITIONS ISSUE
NUMBER.
NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS A SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE LANDS.
AND DEVELOPED YET DILAPIDATED
PROJECTS ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF THE
CITY AND ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTY.
AGAIN TO PROTECT ENVIRONMENTAL
RESOURCES WATER QUALITY AND ALSO
IMPROVE OF LIKE PUBLIC ACCESS.
AND SECONDARILY TO SERVE.
CAST EMISSIONS REDUCTION AS WELL
AS OTHER CLIMATE GOALS INCLUDING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
IS THIS.
IS THE SEVEN MILLION THAT'S
REQUEST IS THAT THE ALL IN
NUMBER FOR THE FIFTEEN
PROPERTIES THAT ARE THERE IS AT
THE COMPLETE ACQUISITION
CLUSTERS THIS THE A PORTION OF
WHAT THE FINAL FIGURES COULD BE.
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE ACTUAL
PROPERTIES WOULD GET ACQUIRED
THE TERM OPPORTUNITY INDICATES
IT DEPENDS ON A WILLING SELLER
WHEN A PROPERTY COMES IN THE
MARKET.
THIS AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT WE THAT
APPROPRIATION NESS BUT IT'S HARD
TO KNOW EXACTLY THE PRECISE
COSTS OF A PROPERTY YOU.
OKAY SO THESE ARE ALL THESE ARE
COPIES YOU ACQUIRE THAT ARE
COMPETITIVE WITH IN THE FREE
MARKET THIS IS NOT --
EMINENT DOMAIN ACTION OR ANY
OTHER ACTION ON THAT BECAUSE OF
THE SENSITIVITY.
OKAY LA --
WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN ON
OPPORTUNITY ACQUISITIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S TAHOE CONSERVANCY.
CLOSE PUBLIC WE WILL HOLD THIS
MATTER OF OPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HEY.
FIND TIME OUR COLLEAGUE HERE
.
SO LET'S LET'S DO YOU ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS THIS IS.
VARIOUS CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
THIS STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS --
TO KEEP IT OPEN.
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON THE
COST OF WORKING DRAWINGS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
UNDER CHIRLA CASKEY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRUCE AYE TOWER
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
BECAUSE OF THIS.
ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN YOU WERE CALL THE LAST
YEAR'S --
DEMONSTRATION AND LEGISLATOR
PROVED --
ALL RESIDENTS ARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM --
AND THESE ARE FOR OF THESE FOR
PROJECTS ARE THE SECOND PHASE
AND CONTINUATION DEVELOPMENT OF
THOSE PRESIDENTIAL SITES THEY
ARE. EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOR THE WORKING DRIVES
FOR THE FOR TURNOUT RESIDENTIAL
CENTER --
THE CCC HAS TWENTY FOUR SITES IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA NINE OF THEM
A RESIDENTIAL SINCE OF OUR FOR
TO DECIDE IS ONE OF THOSE.
PRESIDENTIAL CENTERS.
POINT SEVEN FOUR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORKING DRIES.
FOR OUR GREENWOOD RESIDENTIAL
CENTER LOCATED --
GREENWOOD GEORGETOWN AREA.
IN -- ONE
POINT ONE NINE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS --
FOR TO WORKING DRIES FOR A LOS
PINOS CENTER --
LISTING USES --
LOCATED UP ABOVE --
USING THAT THIS IS IN OUR
SENATOR JONES DISTRICT --
UP ABOVE LAKE ELSINORE IN --
THE CLEAN NATIONAL FORCE AND
THREE POINT. FIVE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORKING DRIVES --
AND ARE YOU KAI ASIDE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY THAT SITE
CURRENTLY EXISTS A RESIDENT
ASIDE CURRENT EXIST IN YOUR
CLASS.
AND WE'VE --
RECENTLY PURCHASED PROPERTY IN
WILLITS WE WERE STARTING --
THAT'S AGAIN SECOND PHASE OF
THAT DEVELOPMENT ABOUT
RESIDENTIAL SIDE.
SO WHEN WE WHEN WE REPLACE THE
EXISTING BUILDINGS --
YOU MAKE AN ASSESSMENT ON ANY
VALUE OF OF THE EXISTING
BUILDING WHEN IT MOVES FROM.
AND I'M THINKING IT MOVES TO BE
SOME SORT OF STORAGE FACILITY
VERSUS VERSUS A RESIDENTIAL
CENTER I MEAN DOES IT THE OR DO
YOU JUST.
DESTROYED AND BUILD ANOTHER
RESIDENTIAL ON THE SITE THAT'S
FOR THE ASSESSMENT IT IS --
FOR FOR INSTANCE THE U. CLASS
SIZE AT A TO LISA RIFAT FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS WITH.
MINUTES INYO COUNTY OFICE OF
EDUCATION SO WE TRIED TO EXPAND
ON THAT SIDE AND EITHER BUILT
FROM THE GROUND UP AND OR
RENOVATE EXISTING SITES BUT IN
THIS CASE --
MEDICINE --
KIND OF COUNTY OF AWESOME OFFICE
OF EDUCATION DID NOT WANT --
TO PROVIDES MORE SPACE.
AND SO WITH THE SECOND OPTION
WAS AND TO LOOK FOR ANOTHER SITE
THAT CLOSE CITY AREAS SO WE
COULD CONTINUE TO SERVE THAT
MENDOCINO COUNTY AREA.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE FOUND THIS
YOU GUYS SITE AND THAT'S PART OF
THE PROCESS THAT.
WE'RE INVOLVED IN WITH
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES FROM
THE GECKO RESEARCH FOR SIDE WE
WAITED DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES
OR DIFFERENT OPTIONS WITH WHEN
THERE ARE POSSIBILITIES ARE
OPTIONS.
OF THAT AND FIGURE OUT WHICH
WHICH IS THE BEST OPTION TO
BUILD FROM THE GROUND UP OR
AGAIN RENOVATE.
NOW ON THE TWENTY FOUR
FACILITIES TO WE OWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OWN THOSE
FACILITIES IN LANDER WE'RE
RELEASING SOME OF THOSE.
FACILITIES AND LONG TERM LEASES
LAS VEGAS I IT'S FOR SERVICE
MOST ON RESIDENTIAL SITES THE
OTHERS IS THAT --
SIXTEEN YES SIXTEEN OTHER
NONRESIDENTIAL SITES ARE.
EITHER PRIVATELY LEISTER
PUBLICLY LEAST --
SO FOR A AS AS A GROUND EXAMPLE
ARE SAN DIEGO AND AND AND EMPIRE
SITES ARE LEASE FROM.
RIDLEY BUT OUR LOS ANGELES --
NON RESIDENTIAL SIDE IS LEASED
FROM THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE THE U. K. ASIDE.
FROM LAST YEAR THE U. K. SITE
AND THE POMONA SIDE OR I GUESS
THE THE NAPA.
IN POMONA SITE WE'RE ALL BEFORE
US YOU.
GOT THE WORKING DRAWINGS NOW ON
THAT -- YOU
KAI SITES YOU GOING FORWARD BUT
WE EVEN THE KID AT THAT --
THEY'RE NO LONGER BEING PURSUED
AS RESIDENTIAL CENTERS IS THAT
BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED TO
RESIDENTIAL CENTERS OR THEY WERE
ON LEASE PROPERTY AND THEY DON'T
WANT -- TO
DANCE WITH THE CCC'S ARM IT SAYS
WE'RE NOT PRESUME BUT I REALLY
IN MY MIND WE JUST PUT THEM ON
HOLD --
MOSTLY --
FOR IN MY MY WAS TRANCE WERE NOT
DESPERATE RECENTLY WAS
TRANSFERRED OVER TO CAL POLY
POMONA --
THE THE NAPA SITE WHERE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A NON RESIDENTIAL
SITE AT NAPA STATE HOSPITAL --
THEY HAD NO INTERESTS OF US --
DEVELOPING OR EXPANDING OF THEIR
PROPERTY BUT BEYOND FIELD VETS
HOMES IT DOES HAVE.
AN INTEREST SAYS AND US BUILDING
A RESIDENTIAL SITE AT THIS AT
VETS BY VETS HOME.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A LONG
PROCESS AS WELL LIKE TO CAL POLY
PROMOTED SIDE SO --
MY MY WE JUST PUT THOSE OFFER
NOW BECAUSE OF IN THE CASE OF
VETS HOMES IT IT'S A LONG
PROCESS FOR THE BILL IN THIS
NURSING HOME --
AND A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON
THERE SO --
I'D LIKE TO COME BACK TO THOSE
BUT NOT AT THIS TIME NOW DOES
YOUR DEPARTMENT.
I HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CAL FIRE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DIRECTOR PORTER UP HERE --
SOON AND ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT
THEY HAVE ARE SOME THERE THEY
WANT TO BUILD A TO THEIR FACE OF
WORKING DRAWINGS IMPLEMENTER
ACQUISITIONS IN HAVE FOR PHONE
THEN DAYS THOSE FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN COME --
UNWORKABLE OR UNDESIRABLE OR
JUST OLD FOR THE CALIFORNIE
YIDDISH YOUR SHOP HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THAT BEING A
CCC.
YOU KNOW RESIDENTIAL AREA OR
ANOTHER FACILITY THAT WOULDN'T
NEED THE THE SIZE OF THE
APPARATUS BUT YOU COULD.
TO WORK FROM THERE DO YOU HAVE
THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS WHEN THE
CAL FIRE BECAUSE THERE'S A LINK
IN THE BUDGET.
WITH THE THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS
SHOULD BE DOING ABSOLUTELY --
IN PART OF THAT D. G. S. PROCESS
FOR LOOKING AT SITES RE
OBVIOUSLY WE LOOK AT STATE
SURPLUS WE'VE TALKED TO YOU KNOW.
AS YOU'RE AWARE MANY THE
CONSERVATION CAMPS UNDER CAL
FIRE ARE --
DOWNSIZING OR ARE BEING FORCED
TO I'M DON'T HAVE THE CREWS THAT
THE STAFF SO WE'LL ABSOLUTE
LOOKED OUTSIDE CONTRACT ARE ARE
GREEN WHICH SIDE ONE OF THE
PROJECT SOLICITOR IS A FORMER
CAL FIRE PROPERTY THAT WAS
THIRTY MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS
AGO ARE PLASTER CENTER.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY --
ABOUT START CONSTRUCTION AFTER
THAT THREE OR FOUR YOU'RE.
A DESIGN PHASES.
WAS IT IS OR WAS A FORMER ROCK
HOW FAR SIDE AS WELL SORRY WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS YOU TRY TO MAXIMIZE.
YOUR EFFICIENCY AND AND USES
SITES -- AND
WHERE WE CAN WE WE MOVE INTO THE
SURPLUS PROPERTIES OR OR WORKERS
CAL FIRE.
TO MAKE THOSE KINDS OF SUCH
CHANGES OR COMEDY QUESTIONS OF
APARTMENT.
SENATE MCGUIRE YOUR QUESTION SIR
JUST A A QUICK COMMENT ON
DIRECTOR AT HAS HAD --
PUZZLE BOARD IN FRONT OF THEM OF
TRYING TO BE A TO MAKE IT WORK
WITH SOME PARTNERS WHO WANT TO
DANCE AND SOME THAT.
NOT NECESSARILY --
AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK
ESPECIALLY IN THE NORTH COAST OF
TRYING TO PUT THE PUZZLE PIECES
TOGETHER TO KEEP.
THE PROJECTS MOVING FOR BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES.
JUST SIMPLY SO APPRECIATE THAT
THANK CENTER.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN IS CAPITAL OUTLAYS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
SEEN NO PUBLIC INPUT CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS OVER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME [inaudible]
KENLEY.
CALL SENATOR JONES.
I'M LET'S MOVE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THIS IS THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN EXEMPTION
REVIEW.
WAR -- SB
NINE A ONE GOOD MORNING --
DIRECTOR BOTTOM.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
I WOULD LIKE TO QUICKLY COVER
OUR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
OF ISSUE SIXTEEN WHICH IS FOUND
ON AGENDA PAGE.
TWENTY SO THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSAL IS BOTH SPECIFIC.
N. FOR A DEFINED PURPOSE.
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL IS A
REQUEST OF FIFTEEN POSITIONS.
AND A TOTAL OF THREE MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND OF WHICH ONE MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND IS GENERAL FUND.
AND TWO MILLION IS --
REVENUE FROM THE TIMBER
REGULATION AND FOREST
RESTORATION FUND WHICH IS
MANAGED BY THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
OUR GOAL IN THIS PROPOSAL IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO MEET OUR
ROLE.
IN A NEW MUCH BIGGER TIMBER --
FOR CREATED BY SENATE BILL NINE
A ONE I WOULD ALSO JUST INFORM
YOU THAT FOR US AT THE
DEPARTMENT CATASTROPHIC FIRE HAS
AFFECTED US AS WELL.
IF YOU THINK IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS ALL THE MAJOR FIRES.
COLLECTIVELY THEY'VE THREATEN
DEPARTMENT ASSETS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE BUILDINGS AND VENTURA WE
HAVE BUILDINGS IN SANTA ROSA WE
HAVE BUILDINGS IN REDDING.
THEY'VE THREATENED OUR WILDLIFE
AREAS AN ECOLOGICAL RESERVES.
DAVE IMPACTED FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND THEY'VE IMPACTED OUR STAFF --
SOME OF THE MORE DIFFICULT PHONE
CALLS I'VE MADE WERE OVER LAST
HOLIDAY.
TO STAFF.
WHO LOST HOMES OR PROPERTY IN
THE PARADISE SITUATION?
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL IS
ALSO FOR A VERY DEFINED PURPOSE.
OUR DEPARTMENT WILL SEE AN
INCREASE IN OUR WORK LOAD
BECAUSE OF SENATE BILL NINE A
ONE THAT SENATE BILL REQUIRES
OUR DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST CAL
FIRE.
IN WAYS WE'RE NOT.
STAFFED TO ASSIST THEM.
WE WILL NEED TO DEAL WITH FAST
REVIEW OF THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL
NOTICES OF EXEMPTION.
INCLUDING TWO TYPES OF NEW
NOTICES FOR EXEMPTION AROUND%
TEMPORARY ROADS AND STREAM
CROSSINGS. TO ADVISE CAL FIRE ON
HOW TO MANAGE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO. TO REDUCE THIS RISK.
WITH ALSO AN UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
MEASURES THAT MIGHT HELP.
REDUCE IMPACTS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES.
WE ARE ASKED TO HELP CALL FAR IN
COMPLIANCE MONITORING AND
REPORTING AROUND POST
INSPECTIONS.
AND TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THAT.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION HAS ADOPTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE AND IN THOSE
REGULATIONS THEY RELY HEAVILY ON
OUR DEPARTMENT. TO GO OUT AND DO
POST PROJECT MONITORING.
AND PRE PROJECT CONSULTATION
AROUND THE USE OF THESE
EXEMPTIONS.
IS THE LAST THING I'LL SAY.
YESTERDAY I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
SPEAKING BROADLY ABOUT TIMBER
PRACTICES OUR DEPARTMENT IS
ENGAGE.
BUT IT'S I THINK.
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO TRY TO CLEAR
UP ANY CONFUSION.
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO OUR
DEPARTMENT IS GAUGED IN TIMBER
HARVEST REVIEWS.
IT'S TRADITIONAL WORK WE DO IT
WELL WE ARE CONSOLIDATING OUR
WORK WITH STATE AGENCIES.
AND THERE WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHETHER THE TREND LINES ON WORK
PRODUCT INEFFICIENCIES ARE GOING
UP OR DOWN.
THE TIMELINESS IS FASTER OR
SLOWER.
AND I WENT BACK AND READ THE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN REPORT
SUBMITTED BY OUR AGENCY TO THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK IN DECEMBER.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THOSE TREND
LINES ON THE ALREADY EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THEY'RE NOT ALL COMPREHENSIVELY
TRENDING DOWNWARD.
EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT PRE
HARVEST INSPECTIONS CONDUCTED
THAT METRIC FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
WAS ACTUALLY MUCH HIGHER.
AYE IN SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
THAN THE PRECEDING TWO YEARS.
SO ANOTHER METRICS YOU WOULD
FIND IN THAT RPORT IS.
WE STILL DO OUR OTHER PERMITTING
UNDER STREAMBED ALTERATION
AGREEMENTS.
AND IT'S ALL TAKE PERMITS IF YOU
LOOK AT WORKLOAD FOR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AGREEMENTS AND SIXTEEN
HUNDRED X. INSPECTIONS.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY INCREASED.
OVER THE MOST RECENT REPORTING
PERIOD NOT DECREASE.
OF COURSE IN THIS REPORT YOU CAN
FIND SOME OTHER METRICS WHICH
SELECT THEY MAY BE GOING THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
BUT FOR ME.
IT'S NOT A TOPIC ABOUT SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE SENATE BILL NINE
OH ONE COMES AFTER.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO SENATE BILL
NINE A ONE IS ABOUT DEALING WITH
CATASTROPHIC FIRE RISK IT
CREATES A NEW WORKLOAD.
BECAUSE OF THE USE OF IMPORTANT
EXEMPTIONS.
THE GET CAL FAR WITH SMALL
TIMBER OWNERS AND OTHERS OUT
REMOVING.
THINGS IN ORDER TO REDUCE THAT
RISK THAT'S A NEW WORKLOAD.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION AND OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS ABOUT THAT NEW
WORKLOAD.
ANOTHER DOCTOR OKAY SO
[inaudible]
WE JUST.
PART OF THE FUNDING MECHANISM
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE WORK IS THE
GREENHOUSE --
DATE GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS WE
JUST FINISH THE THIRD OPTION AND
WE'RE AT MAGICALLY TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BUDGET HAS IN
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR.
THERE APPEARS TO BE AN
AUGMENTATION COMING FOR FUNDS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO DO.
MITIGATION WORK IN THE AND THE
AND THE I CLIMATE EMISSIONS
ARENA.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE WOULD SUBMIT
THAT THE A ROBUST.
TIMBER REGULATION IN REDUCTION --
UP UP PROGRAM WILL BE ONE OF
THOSE VARIABLES THAT MAY HELP US
REDUCE GREENHOUSE.
GASES SO LET ME JUST PUT DOWN A
SAYS THAT THE SENATE.
SUB BUDGET SUB TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE MAY BE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE ON
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING.
SO WE COULD BE LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AND AND THAT THE LIST IS IS.
ABUNDANT THE LEASE IN RESILIENCY.
THIS SEEMS TO BE A BIG.
BIG --
POTENTIAL SO I GUESS MY FIRST
QUESTION IS IS THAT WHAT IS FISH
AND WILDLIFE'S.
ATTENTION FOR EXPANSION.
ON THIS PROGRAM.
I'M BEYOND THE FIFTEEN POSITIONS
IN THE THREE POINT FOR THAT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING.
I MEAN IF WE WERE.
TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE TIMBER
HARVESTS.
IN TREE REMOVAL WITH THE
AUGMENTATION.
IS THAT DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR WITH
YOU GUYS WERE ONCE YOU'RE OUT IN
THE FOREST.
WE DO IN A PRE POSITIONING
RESOLUTION THEN YOU'RE GOING
OVER HERE AND DOING A POST.
OUR WORK IS IT IS THERE SOME
COORDINATION THAT GOES ON GET
CHAIR YES.
THERE IS IN MY EXPERIENCE AN
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN CAL FIRE [inaudible]
OUR DEPARTMENT.
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARDS AND THE STATE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD.
THAT INTEGRATION AND
COLLABORATION MUST CONTINUE TO
EXIST TO BE SUCCESSFUL ANDERSON
A BILL NINE A ONE I THINK AN
IMPORTANT PART OF SENATE BILL
NINE A ONE AS AN EXAMPLE.
IS A PATHWAY FOR THE SMALLER NON
INDUSTRIAL TIMBER OWNER. TO HAVE
A MORE DIRECT ACCESS TO OUR
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS TO ADVISE
THEM.
SO THEY CAN TURN AROUND AND USE
THESE NEW EXEMPTIONS.
BUT FOR CLARITY'S SAKE OUR
DEPARTMENT.
WE THINK FIFTEEN POSITIONS IS A
REASONABLE REQUEST FOR THIS TIME
FRAME.
IT IS ONE OF THE SMALLER REQUEST
YOU'LL SEE FOR NINE OH ONE
IMPLEMENTATION.
I THINK SMALLER THAN EVERYONE
ELSE'S EXCEPT PERHAPS THE OFFICE
OF REPAIR ADVOCATES WITHIN THE
PC.
AND WE ONLY HAVE TO FUND SOURCE.
THE FIRST FUND SOURCES GENERAL
FUND.
THE SECOND SO FUND SOURCES THE
TIMBER REGULATION AND FAR AS
RESTORATION FUND WHICH I THINK.
THERE'S PROBABLY A POLICY
DISCUSSION ABOUT [inaudible]
THAT FUND.
PAYS FOR OUR ALREADY EXISTING
ACTIVITIES.
HE EXEMPTION ACTIVITY UNDER NINE
OH ONE RELATES TO TIMBER
OPERATIONS.
AND WE PROPOSE TO USE THAT PHONE
FOR THAT REASON I WILL SAY.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO PROHIBITS
OUR DEPARTMENT.
FROM CHARGING TIMBER. FOR OTHER
FEES.
AND REQUIRES US TO PAY FOR OUR
LOAD OF OPERATIONS FROM THIS
TIMBER FUND NO I'M IN A
CONUNDRUM.
IF I CAN'T GO CHARGE TIMBER FEES
TO DO NINE OH ONE WORK.
I HAVE A PORTION OF GENERAL FUND.
WE'RE SUGGESTING TO MILLION FROM
THIS TIMBER FUN.
VERY GOOD SENATE MCGUIRE GOV
QUESTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I NAY NIELSEN SEVER THEIR LET'S
TALK ABOUT FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
THEN AND LIKE TO BE TO TALK
ABOUT NINE A ONE I THINK WHERE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I THINK WE
NEED TO BE A TO GET UPDATED DATA.
ON WHERE WE'RE AT WITH ON
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO SPECIFIC. TO
TWO YEARS AGO I THINK WITH THE
LATEST DATA THAT WE HAD.
WHERE IT LOOKED AT STAFF
INCREASE AND [inaudible]
PERMITS [inaudible]
TIME DECREASE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE I THINK YOU I'M
PARAPHRASING HERE. 50% MORE
STAFF WITHIN THAT.
UMBRELLA.
PORTION OF CITY OF W. I THINK IT
WAS ABOUT A 15% INCREASE
[inaudible]
SO.
THROUGH THE CHAIR AND WOULD LIKE
TO BE A REQUEST DEPARTMENT --
PROVIDE THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE.
UPDATED NUMBERS JUST VERY SEE
WHERE ADAM NEXT I THINK TO BE TO
MAKE AN EDUCATED DECISION.
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT YES
[inaudible]
I AND THEN NINE NINE A ONE I
THINK WHERE THE CONCERN.
IS [inaudible]
IF.
THERE WAS AN EXPECTATION IF.
FOUR THREE TIMBER FOLKS WE'RE
GONNA BE TAXING THEMSELVES THERE
WOULD BE --
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN TURN
AROUND TIME. FOR TIMBER HARVEST
PLANTS.
AND IF WE'RE NOT SEEN THAT PLAY
OUT.
TAKING DOLLARS FROM. FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO TO BE ABLE TO COVER
OBLIGATIONS FOR NINE A ONE
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
BUT MEDIA TO SEE THOSE NUMBERS
TO BETTER DETERMINE THAT IN THE
FOR ONLY TALKING TWO MILLION
DOLLARS [inaudible]
THEN.
I AND I DON'T MEAN THAT USED TO
MILLION LIGHTLY.
ARMED BUT BIG PICTURE.
LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO FUND THAT NOT ADDED THAT
CHESBRO TIMBER TAX.
BUT THAT WOULD JUST BE MY BELIEF
AND WOULD LIKE TO BE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT WORKING WITH.
CHAIR IN IN WITH ACTIVITY HERE
ON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL.
THIS AGAIN IT IS FAIR TO SAY.
THE TIMBER TAX WAS MEANT TO BE
ABLE TO EXPEDITE PERMITTING.
IN A FOR NOT SEEN THAT WITH THE
NUMBER STAFF NO INJURIES AND
THEN TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THOSE
DOLLARS AWAY IF WE STILL HAVE
CHALLENGES INTERNALLY.
AS FAR AS EXPERT ON IN THAT SAME
WE DO BUT WE NEED TO SEE THE
NUMBERS.
THEN WE'RE ONLY DIGGING A DEEPER
HOLE.
THE OTHER PIECE MISTER DIRECTOR --
IN THESE ARE A LOT OF COMMENTS
ON THE SURVEY QUESTIONS BUT IF
YOU CAN.
RESPOND TO THIS IF UNDER NINE OH
ONE WE'RE LOOKING AT ENHANCE
EXEMPTIONS MORE EXEMPTIONS WE
SEEN IN A GENERATION.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME THAT SAY
THE WHY DO WE NEED ENHANCE
STAFFING. FOR LOOKING AT BROADER
EXEMPTIONS.
WHAT IS IT THAT THAT SEVEN WILL
DO AND YOU CAN JUST ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S AN ITEM
THAT?
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT ON THE
NORTH COAST IF YOU DON'T MIND
RESPONDS THAT AGAIN.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THE
SIR.
SO I YES ON CURRENT DATA.
IN YOUR ALSO CORRECT SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE RESOURCES AGENCY.
RAPPORT I BELIEVE DATED.
MARCH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IS
LOOKING AT FIFTEEN SIXTEEN DATA.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
SOON WE'LL SEE THE NEXT REPORT
AND IT'LL BE LOOKING AT WITH A.
B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN DATA.
THAT WOULD BE USEFUL.
I DO BELIEVE WHEN YOU GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THE CURRENT
PUBLISHED REPORT.
THE OVERALL AVERAGE T. H. PER.
THREE REVIEW TIME.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A HUNDRED NAY
DAYS IN FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND WENT UP TO HUNDRED
FORTY DAYS IN FISCAL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SO IT'S A
THIRTY DAY DIFFERENCE BUT I
WOULD ALSO TELL YOU THE REPORT
WILL SHOW METRICS THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT ARE SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENT.
SHRUNK OTHER PERMITTING.
TIMELINE STRAIGHT AND WAS MORE
EFFICIENT SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE DATA.
I WILL TELL YOU ALSO.
THAT UNDER SENATE BILL NINE A
ONE IN MY IMPRESSION THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON HERE THAT
RELATES TO THE DATA YOU ARE
LOOKING AT AROUND OUR
TRADITIONAL WORK --
I THINK A THING THAT'S HAPPENED
IS EXEMPTION NOTIFICATIONS HAD
BEEN TRENDING HIGHER OVER THE
LAST REPORTED FOUR YEAR PERIOD
ANYWAY.
EVEN BEFORE YOU GET S. B. NINE A
ONE NEW EXEMPTIONS AND PLAY. FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN AS
I UNDERSTAND THERE WERE ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY NOTIFICATIONS. FOR
EXEMPTIONS AND BY THE TIME YOU
GET.
TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE
WERE.
THREE THOUSAND TEN NOTICES OF
EXEMPTIONS YOU'RE ALMOST GETTING
A DOUBLING OF EXEMPTIONS UNDER
THE OLDER.
AVAILABILITY NOW WE'RE ADDING
POTENTIALLY NEW EXEMPTIONS WE
NEED TO EXPLOIT TO REDUCE
CATCHES FIRE RISK.
SO I PROJECT THE NUMBER OF
EXEMPTIONS JUST KEEPS
ACCELERATING.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROMPTLY UTILIZE THOSE
EXEMPTIONS TO GET PEOPLE OUT
REMOVING TIMBER.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WHETHER ONE OF THE METRICS IS A
COURAGEOUS.
ARE YOU APPROVING MORE ACRES
UNDER T. H. PEAS WELL I'LL JUST
SAY IS WE'VE SEEN THIS SHIFT.
ANY WAY.
TOWARDS EXEMPTIONS.
THAT NUMBER OF EXEMPTIONS I JUST
MENTIONED IS INVOLVING MORE
ACRES.
IT'S ALMOST THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION ACRES IN THE LAST
REPORTED PERIOD THAT WILL COMING
IN AROUND EXEMPTIONS.
AND I THINK THOSE TRENDS WILL
CONTINUE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SUGGESTING FIFTEEN PEOPLE.
JUST FOR OUR DEPARTMENT WITH THE
NINE A ONE TO DEAL WITH THAT
EXEMPTION WORKLOAD.
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR IT'S MY
LAST IS. TO BUT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT TAKING [inaudible]
DOLLARS.
FOR BUT THE TO PORTION OF IT THE
TWO MILLION FROM.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO THAT PART
CORRECT.
AND I UNDERSTAND HOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN REGARDS.
TO RELATION TO IT.
MY CONCERN WOULD BE IS S. IF I'M.
IF WE ARE NOT HITTING ME THE
METRICS THAT WE NEED TO HIT
UNDER FOURTEEN NINETY TWO UNDER.
WHAT WAS THOUGHT TO BE THE MAIN
MISSION?
I ARE WE CERTAIN THAT MAIN
MISSION AND SHOULD WE BE LOOKING
ELSEWHERE FOR THAT TWO MILLION
SO THAT.
SO I THINK THE DATA AND THEN YOU
KNOW WHERE THAT FUNDS GOING TO
COME WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
BEFORE WE MAKE A DECISION AND
THINK INSTRUCTION THE STREET WE
ARE HOLDING THIS OPEN SENATOR
MONEY YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THANK YU MISTER CHAIR IN THANK
YOU DIRECTOR --
I JUST WANNA.
JOIN WITH THE COMMENTS OF BOTH
THE CHAIR AND SENATOR MCGUIRE --
IT WASN'T CLEAR TO ME IN THE
NEXT AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
REPORT.
IS DO ARE LIKELY TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE.
I THINK MY UNDERSTANDING IS DAYS
TO WEEKS I DON'T THINK MONTHS
[inaudible]
SO PENDING.
I WOULD PROTECT CERTAINLY WELL
WITHIN THIS BUDGET CYCLE.
THANK YOU IN IN AGAIN IN JOINING --
CENTERS MCGUIRE AND WHAT CASKEY.
I THINK AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE COULD.
POTENTIALLY MORE CAP AND TRADE
SOME.
RESOURCES.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT
ANA INTENT. FOR THE TIMBER FEES
VERSUS THE NINE OH ONE WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR L. A. L.
YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
COMPUTERS AT THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THAT
OVERALL STAFFING REQUEST I FOR
DFW IT SEEMED A REASONABLE GIVEN
THE POTENTIAL WORKLOAD INCREASED --
BUT CLEARLY UNDERSTANDING THAT
I'M LOOKING AT AND AN
AUGMENTATION IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY LOOK AT THE BASELINE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
PROGRAM AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HELP
ON THE IF THAT IS THE MORE
RECENT DATA IS PROVIDED WE'RE
HAPPY TO HELP WITH TAKING A LOOK
AT THAT.
AND AND GET YOUR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED AND FINE TIMBER
REGULATION FORCE RESTORATION
FUND THAT.
SEEMS TO BE A COULD BE A BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE THEY COULD FIX
THAT.
THE TWO ON THE NINE A ONE WORK
BEING NINE A ONE WORK VERSUS.
TAKING FROM THE FORTY NINE
NINETY TWO THE WITH THE WOULD
YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT.
THIRD DRIVE OVER THE PART OF
FINANCE SO WE BELIEVE UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW FOR THE USE OF THE
FUND IT IS AN APPROPRIATE USE OF
THE MIND SO THERE'S NO NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILL TO
CHANGE.
THE USED BECAUSE IT DOES FALL IN
LINE WITH THE USE OF THE FUND
[inaudible]
DE.
OKAY.
THAT'S THAT'S AN OPINION LOOK AT
THAT SOME REQUIRE ONE LAST
QUESTION. ONE LAST QUESTION
FEDERAL IN FINANCE I I THINK
THAT -- JUST
BECAUSE IT DOES DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S WORKING SO IF WE HAVE A A
CHALLENGING LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS SO THIS IS VERY
COLLABORATIVE.
ON IS -- IF
WE HAVE CURRENT CHALLENGES IN A
MISSION THAT IS NOT BEING.
WE'VE CURRENT CHARGES MEETING A
MISSION.
TAKING TWO MILLION AWAY FROM IT.
IS GONNA MAKE IT EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING I WOULD JUST HOPE
THAT WE CAN GO BACK.
BY TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OTHER
BEGIN.
SMALL AMOUNT BIG PICTURE.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO BE ABLE.
TO THE MORE INNOVATIVE ON THE
APPROACH ON THIS.
COULD WE DO A LOT OF THAT IN
SEPT TWO LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER.
SIXTEEN WHILE I PREVENTION
RECOVERY LEGISLATION TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN EXEMPTION REVIEWS
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR Y. CASKEY
MEMBERS --
PAUL MASON PACIFIC FOREST TRUST.
AND I WANT TO START ON THIS
WHOLE FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
CONVERSATION WHICH I WASN'T
REALLY EXPECTING TO GO DOWN THAT
RABBIT HOLE.
BUT I FEEL LIKE.
THE GOALS OF FOURTEEN NINETY TO
HAVE --
GOTTEN CONFUSED IN THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION AND IT WAS A
COMPLEX PIECE OF LEGISLATION THE
BROUGHT A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
INTERESTS TO THE TABLE TO
RESOLVE THE WILDFIRE LIABILITY
ISSUES. TO SOME STREAMLINING OUR
EXTENDED TIMBER HARVEST PLANS
TRIED TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE GOING
TO HAVE THE WHOLE PROCESS BE
MORE EFFICIENT APPOINTED TIMBERS
ARE.
CREATED THIS LUMBER ASSESSMENT.
THAT'S THE LUMBER ASSESSMENT IN
THE FACT THAT IT WAS DEDICATED.
TO MAKING SURE WE HAD A ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS FOR
TIMBER HARVESTING ACTIVITIES.
IS THAT HOW YOU GOT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEE TO THE
TABLE ON THIS ENTIRE BILL WHICH
WAS OTHERWISE REALY VERY
FOCUSED ON YOU KNOW BENEFITS FOR
OF LANDOWNERS AND PROCESS.
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING AT A POINT
WE'RE COMING OUT OF THE
RECESSION DURING WHICH TIME.
THE DEPARTMENT'S GENERALLY AND
FISH AND WILDLIFE IN PARTICULAR
WERE ABSOLUTELY DECIMATED.
I MEAN THE CUTS THAT HAPPENED TO
THE TIMBER HARVEST REVIEW TEAMS
THERE AND THAT ERA WERE JUST.
WIDELY OUT OF PROPORTION WITH
THE REST OF WHAT HAPPENED AND
THE IN STATE BUDGET.
SO THAT WAS WHY WE WERE SUPPORT
OF OF AB FORTY NINETY TWO IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT STREAMLINING
PERMITS THERE WAS LANGUAGE THERE.
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE --
PROCESSING TOMORROW'S PLANS MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND TRACKING THAT
GETTING THE RECORDS IN THE
NUMBERS ARE THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
PART OF IT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHY WE HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT THESE AS ONE ON
LUMBER CONSUMERS IS TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW.
BUT AS ONE OF THEIR CORRECT THAT
CONTEXT A LITTLE BIT NOT HAPPY.
TO FOLLOW UP WITH A NEW
SEPARATELY IF YOU'D LIKE.
I MEAN THAT YEAH.
HAPPY TO HELP.
ALL OF THEM BUT THEY WANNA COME
BACK AROUND TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL --
SB NINE A ONE CONVERSATIONS SO
FOR STRESS AND OTHER THAN THE
NORMAL COMMUNITY WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE.
THAT THE REVIEW TEAM AGENCIES
WE'RE GOING TO BE AT THE TABLE --
WERE INVOLVED IN SOME.
MANNER AS BEST YOU CAN WITH A
MINISTERIAL PERMIT AROUND THESE
EXEMPTIONS AND SO WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THE ADMINISTRATION
IN A PROPOSED THE AUGMENTATION
FOR BOTH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND THE
F. W..
MORE SPEAKING MORE BROADLY THAN
JUST ABOUT THESE EXEMPTIONS AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DOING ALL
THIS FUEL REDUCTION WORK.
LET'S NOT LOSE TRACK THAT FUELS
REDUCTION IS HABITAT
MODIFICATION.
AND THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND THAT CAN BE GOOD
THERE'S MANY MANY PLACES IN THE
FORESTS WERE GETTING INTO TAKING
A BUNCH OF TREES OUT.
AND TRYING TO RESTORE SOME
STRUCTURE IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
WANT TO BE DOING YOU CAN ALSO BE
BAD THAT'S WHY WE HAVE --
AGENCIES TO HELP WITH THE SORT
OF A OVERSIGHT AND GUIDANCE SO I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS MORE BROADLY
THAN JUST WE ONE MIXER WERE
TRACKING ALL THE EXEMPTIONS.
AND AS WE'RE TRYING TO SCALE UP
TO HALF A MILLION ACRES A YEAR
OF YOUR FUEL REDUCTION FORCE
RESTORATION ACTIVITIES ANNUALLY.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
DIFFERENT.
RUSTY AGENCIES FULLY ENGAGED IN
SORT OF PLANNING THATRIGHT NOW
THERE ARE YOU KNOW OUT LOOKING
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AS THEY
SHOULD AND WORKING WITH THE
OTHER REVIEW TEAMS --
YOU KNOW WHAT THE DEPARTMENT BUT
I THINK WE REALLY WANT TO BE
MORE PROACTIVE ABOUT LOOKING AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING WHERE WE'RE
DOING AND THEY WERE GETTING THE
BEST BENEFITS BOTH FOR FIRE
REDUCTION AND HABITAT
RESTORATION.
ACROSS WATERSHED THANK.
NEXT AT THIS OF WILL THERE BE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT OTHER SB NINE
A ONE BCP'S AT SOME OTHER TIME
FOR EXAMPLE.
ABSOLUTELY [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION --
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO THIS
VCP LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
ABOUT A. B. --
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO PAUL MASONS
CORRECT THAT PART OF THE PURPOSE
OF FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD THE
ABILITY TO DO.
A PROFICIENT REVIEW OF TIMBER
HARVESTING ACTIVITIES --
IN ADDITION TO THAT THOUGH TWICE
IN THE BILL IT STATES ABOUT
CREATING THE EFFICIENCES AROUND
THAT WORK SO EFFICIENCIES WAS
ABSOLUTELY A PART OF AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AND THAT
SORT OF WHERE IT TIES INTO --
THE ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENT
THAT WAS MENTIONED BY SEVERAL OF
YOU UP HERE --
THE LAST REPORT WE SEEN WAS IN
TWENTY AS MISTER BONNER.
POINTED OUT --
WE HAVE WE'VE NEVER SEEN A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT AND THAT WAS DOING
JANUARY TENTH OF THIS YEAR --
AND THE TREND IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT WAS THAT P. WHY
WENT UP BY --
TWENTY SUBMITTED TEACH PEACE WAS
DOWN THE INCARCERATED WAS DOWN
AND REVIEW TIME WENT UP BY
TWENTY DAYS.
SO FOR US THOSE NUMBERS ARE
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN REPORT
BECAUSE WE'D LIKE TO SEE IS THAT
TREND CONTINUING HOW WE REVERSE
THAT TREND AND THAT'S PART OF
THE PURPOSE OF THOSE AND OF THAT
ANNUAL REPORT --
AND IT'S ALSO THE TIED TO SB
NINE A ONE THE REQUESTING THE
MONEY FROM FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE SUPPOSED.
TO SEE SOME OF THESE
EFFICIENCIES.
I THINK WE ALSO CONCERNED WITH
THE TWELVE POSITIONS FUNDED
UNDER --
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO BECAUSE OF
THE BC PIECE STATES THAT.
SB NINE A ONE REQUIRES FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO REVIEW NOTICES OF
EXEMPTIONS I'M ACTUALLY IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO REVIEW A
NOTICE OF EXEMPTION.
IT'S AN EXEMPTION FROM HAVING TO
DO A TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN.
IT'S A MINISTERIAL DOCUMENT THAT
NEITHER REQUIRES THE REVIEW
NORTHERN APPROVAL --
IT IS NOT A TIMBER HARVEST PLAN
WHICH THEY ARE PARTNERS WITH
VISION WHILE I AM SORRY WITH CAL
FIRE AT THE TABLE OF THE REVIEW
AGENCY --
CAL FIRE IS THE ONE THAT WE
SUBMIT THE TO CAL FIRE SOMEONE
TO DETERMINE IF THE NOTICE IS
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE.
AND THEN WE CAN SUBMIT WE CAN
START COMMENCING OUR WORK
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE IS INTERESTED
AND ADDING ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
TO DO MONITORING.
OF THE POST WORK TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THE FORCE PRACTICE RULES ARE --
APPLIED WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT WE
THINKTHAT THOSE POSITIONS
SHOULD BE FOCUSED WHERE THE MOST.
TIMBER HARVEST ACTIVITIES ARE
BEING ARE TAKING PLACE FISH AND
WILDLIFE DIVIDES THE STATE UP
INTO SIX DIFFERENT REGIONS. TWO
OF WHICH ARE THE INLAND DESERT
AND THE SOUTH COAST REGION FISH
AND WILDLIFE IS SEEKING TO
POSITIONS IN THOSE AREAS WE
LOOKED AT THE ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE DONE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
THOSE TWO REGIONS.
BETWEEN THOSE TWO REGIONS
TOGETHER WE HAD A TOTAL OF ONE
EXEMPTION. ONE LESSON THREE ACRE
CONVERSION AND ZERO TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS SO WE FAIL TO SEE
THE NEED TO HIRE TWO ADDITIONAL
STAFFERS FOR THAT ROBUST WORK
THAT'S GOING ON IN THERE --
THE A DOT THE IDEA BEHIND THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS AND THE
IDEA BEHIND THE EXEMPTIONS IS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
COMMERCIALIZING OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE.
THERE ARE NO SAWMILLS PER SE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO I'M NOT
SURE WHERE THE COMMERCIALIZATION
OF THOSE ANY OPERATIONS THAT
WOULD TAKE PLACE THERE WOULD
HAPPEN WHICH IS WHY THERE ARE NO
EXEMPTIONS NO EMERGENCY NOTICES.
AND NO TIMBER OPERATIONS IN
THOSE AREAS SO AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THIS IS
BEING HELD OPEN AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THE NEXT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL NO I'M
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY NOT ON CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN THANK OU FOR THE THE
CONVERSATION I HAD ACTUALLY
WRITTEN NOTES SOME ADDING ON THE
FLY HERE --
SUPPORT PLEASE BEAR WITH ME.
HE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE B.
C. P. FOR FOR DFW ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THEM TO ENGAGE IN A
SPIN ON A ONE ONE ECHO THE
SENTIMENT FOR MISTER MASON AT
PACIFIC FORCE TRUST THAT THE NPS
NOT UPON RUSSELL VERY MUCH
ENGAGED IN PART OF THAT-COALITION THE REFERENCE.
IN THE DEVELOPING OF THE
LANGUAGE --
FOR NINE OH ONE AS IT RELATES TO
THE THE THE NEW EXEMPTIONS THE
BROADENING OF EXEMPTIONS
ETCETERA FOR US IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT AT DFW AND THE WATER
BOARD.
BE -- BE AT
THE TABLE [inaudible]
WHAT WITH REGARD TO BE FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO SMP HAS ALSO --
WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE THE LANGUAGE
ONE O'CLOCK ECOLOGICAL FORMS
MEASURES --
WHICH AS AS ALSO REFERENCE BY
MISTER MASON GIVEN THE BUDGET
CUTS YOU KNOW THAT'S TAKE
SOMETIME FOR THOSE TO BE
DEVELOPED.
CURRENTLY NOW THERE THERE IN IN --
THERE IN IN THE PHASE OF BEING
FINALLY DEVELOPED AND AND
IMPLEMENTED --
THE DRAFT WHITE PAPER THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PUT OUT.
OR THAT --
MORE FOR ITS REPORT OUT --
ALONG WITH INPUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OTHERS ON THERE'S A
GLUT OF PERFORMANCE MEASURES
DOES RAISE THIS QUESTION OF OF
DATA DO WE HAVE THE INTHE RIGHT
DATA TO REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
OUT THERE AND WHAT AND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ALL KINDS OF
INTERVENTIONS.
OBVIOUSLY THE SPECIFIC THE
TIMBERLANDS --
BUT BROWN IN THE CONVERSATION --
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
YOU'RE TOUCHING ON THE THE
AVAILABILITY POTENTIALLY OF SEE
AN OPPORTUNITY SEEM PS IN
PARTICULAR IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR US TO FINALLY GET THAT DATA --
USING LIGHT ARE USING THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT WE KNOW CAN PROVIDE US
VALUABLE DATA THAT IS ACTUALLY
CROSS SECTORAL LIKE --
VERY BENEFICIAL DFW AND AND
THEIR EMPHASIS ON ON HABITAT AND
WILDLIFE --
OF FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PROTECTING THOSE PUBLIC TRUST
RESOURCES BUT ALSO USEFUL TO THE
WATER BOARD FOR FOR WATERSHED
IMPACTS AND AND WATER ANALYSES
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT.
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
THEIR AS WELL AS LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW A OR B. AND NATURAL
RESOURCES OF A LOOK AT OUR
LANDSCAPES FROM A FROM A CARD AN
ACCOUNTING PERSPECTIVE --
IN RELATION TO EVERYTHING THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN FOR A SIMILAR
CLIMATE GOALS --
AND AND BETTER ACCOUNT FOR WHAT
IS HAPPENING AS AS THESE FIRES
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN --
THERE WAS ONE REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLE I WANT TO POINT OUT I'M
GIVEN THE SENATOR --
FROM CINEMA COUNTY IS THAT SOME
OF THE COUNTY ACTUALLY WENT
THROUGH A A REALLY GOOD PROCESS
OF OF DEVELOPING ALL THIS DATA
USING LIGHT ARE --
I KNOW THAT ANOTHER ARE GONNA
I'M DOING ANALYSIS IN THE SPOT
CHECKS THE NEEDED TO GO ALONG
WITH WITH THE BROADER --
DATA COLLECTION I'M SO FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO TAKE TO CONTINUING GAUGE ON
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WERE THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
COULD BE BEST SPENT --
BUT AT THE SAME TIME VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE CITY BEFORE US
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
SEARCH YOUR MEMBERS CRISPY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBLED
REDWOOD COMMITTEE AND MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANY --
THREE QUICK ITEMS IF I COULD AND
SPEAKING.
BROADLY TED NINE A ONE IN --
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO I CERTAINLY
DON'T HOLD THE DIRECTOR
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT LAPSED
REPORT --
PER THE STATUTE IN P. R. C.
SECTION FOR SIX TO NINE POINT.
NINE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
ANNUAL REPORT THAT WAS DUE
JANUARY TENTH SO TWENTY NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO MONTHS PAST DUE.
OF FALLS ON THE AGENCY NOT ANY
OF THE DEPARTMENTS UNDER THAT
AGENCY --
BUT NONE THE LESS I URGE YOU TO
KEEP THIS OPEN IN THE BROADER
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO FUNDING
REQUEST UNTIL YOU HAVE THAT
DOCUMENTATION BOTH THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS USE THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS BEFORE YOU CAN
PROPERLY --
PINE ON ANY OF THESE BUDGET
REQUEST MY CLIENTS WERE HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK WE ACTIVELY --
NOT ONLY ADVOCATED FOR IT BUT
HELP NEGOTIATE THE LANGUAGE WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN THE FORMER PRO
TEM AND SPEAKER AND MANY OTHERS.
THE ISSUE THAT I WANT TO RAISE
IN PARTICULAR WITH THE SUB
COMMITTEE IS THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE SPECIFIC STATUTORY
PROVISIONS.
THAT CALL OUT THE NEED FOR
ACHIEVING EFFICIENCIES AND IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME ON TWO QUICK
SENTENCES MISTER CHAIR.
IN PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE SECTION
FOR SIX TO NINE POINT TWO
SUBDIVISION F..
SAYS TO PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AND
REGULATORY COSTS AND PROGRAMS TO
THE CREATION OF PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE STATE'S FOREST PRACTICE
REGULATORY PROGRAM.
AND TO SIMPLIFY THE COLLECTION
AND USE OF CRITICAL DATA TO
ENSURE CONSISTENCY WITH OTHER
PREVENT LAWS AND REGULATIONS AND
THEN SUBDIVISION DE.
CALLS UPON THE IDENTIFICATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
EFFICIENCIES IN THE REGULATION
OF TIMBER HARVESTING PLANS
BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES.
WHEN THE BUDGETS FOR ALL THE?
DEPARTMENTS UNDER THE RESOURCES
AGENCY THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
OVERSEE THE TIMBER HARVESTING
PLAN SUBMITTED.
THEY WERE DECIMATED IS MISTER
MASON INDICATED AND THAT'S WHY
THE INDUSTRY ADVOCATED FOR A
STABLE FUNDING SOURCE.
WE ASK THOSE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AND THEY PUT FORTH.
STAFFING LEVELS THAT THEY
BELIEVE THAT THEY NEEDED TO BE
AT AN IDEAL BUDGET LEVEL.
AND I DON'T HAVE THE IMMEDIATE
BREAKDOWN OF THEM I CAN GET IT
FOR YOU BUT THE TOTAL EMPLOYMENT.
WAS TWO HUNDRED AND TWO P. WEISS
BASICALLY A DOUBLING WHICH
REPRESENTED THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE ESSENTIALLY DECIMATED IN
HALF.
WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
THE GROUP OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS
AND THE FUNDING ATTRIBUTABLE TO
AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO IS IT TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO P. WEISS.
AND FOR SIX YEARS.
THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN WAITING
FOR THE EFFICIENCIES TO BE
OUTLINED AND UTILIZED BY THOSE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
STILL WAITING AND HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM.
AND NONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED.
BUT WE ALSO LIKE THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO THAT AND
THOSE STATUTORY PROVISIONS AND
ACHIEVE THOSE EFFICIENCIES THAT
WERE CALLED FOR THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC.
PUBLIC HEARING CENTER JONES.
SEVEN QUESTION ON THE SORRY
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES FOR
MY TARDINESS AND MISTER DIRECTOR
I'M.
MISTER OPENING --
AND YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED MY
QUESTION SO JUST A QUICK
QUESTION IF I MAY PLEASE ON THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL --
AND I UNDERSTAND WE'RE GONNA
LASTLY HOLD THIS OPEN OKAY GOOD
YOUR PROPOSALS ASKING FOR A TWO
OR THREE NEW POSITIONS --
FOR THE TIMBER HIRES HARVESTING
PLANS --
DOWN IN MY AREA IN THE SOUTH
COAST IN THE INLAND DESERT.
AND YOU KNOW I RECOGNIZE THAT TO
TEACH THESE ARE IMPORTANT AND WE
NEED --
PROCESSES AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
I CAN YOU KIND OF ADDRESS.
THE LOGGING IN IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ERIC IS IS.
I'M NOT TOO FAMILIAR WITH A
BUNCH A COMMERCIAL LOGGING IN MY
DISTRICT.
I'LL BE GLAD TO CENTER AND
WELCOME.
THANK YOU THE SENATE AND BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THE FIRST THING I'D SAY IS.
I THINK I PERSONALLY I HOPE.
IN OUR DEPARTMENT HAS AN
IMPROVED RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
I AM VERY PLEASED THAT THEY HAVE
NEW LEADERSHIP IN THE HONORABLE
MISTER GORDON.
IN ALL PRIOR BUDGET YEARS I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED.
OUR DEPARTMENT IN THE
ASSOCIATION OF FOUND COMMON
GROUND AS WE GO THROUGH.
AND I THINK THAT WILL BE
POSSIBLE HERE.
BUT WHAT I CAN CHALLENGE WITH
THIS CATEGORICAL CONCLUSIONS.
YOU HEARD TESTIMONY JUST NOW.
I WILL REMIND PEOPLE.
THAT IF YOU COMPARE THE LATEST
FISCAL YEAR. SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TO THE FISCAL YEAR.
ELEVEN TWELVE WHICH IS THE YEAR
PRIOR TO FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND IF YOU LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS THE AVERAGE
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN REVIEW TIME
HAS DECREASED [inaudible]
DE CREASED.
BY SEVEN POINT 3%.
SO I ENCOURAGE US TO GET THE
MOST RECENT DATA.
AND THOUGHT FULLY COLLECTIVELY
GO THROUGH IT.
BECAUSE ANYONE CAN FIND TRIM
LINES OFTEN.
AS THEIR PERSPECTIVE IS SHIPPED
TO YOUR QUESTION.
I THINK IT'S ACCURATE.
AND IT SAYS IT ON PAGE FOUR OF
OUR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
WE'RE ASKING FOR FIFTEEN
POSITIONS.
WHICH IS THE SMALLEST ASK.
OF THE TOTALITY OF THE NINE A
ONE PROPOSALS EXCEPT FOR THE PC
OFFICE OF REPAIR ADVOCATES. ONE
POSITION IS FOR THE SOUTH COAST
REGION WHICH FOR US IS KIND OF
YEAH VENTURA L. IT WILL ALONG
THE COAST FROM KIND OF VENTURE
DOWN AND ANOTHER IS. ONE FOR THE
IN THE DESERT REGION WHICH IS
KIND OF RIVERSIDE YOU KNOW UP
AGAINST THE MOUNTAINS.
AND I'LL QUOTE.
THESE WE SEEK THOSE [inaudible]
TO PEOPLE. TO ASSIST WITH
PROVIDING FREE CONSULTATION FOR
LANDOWNERS USING AN EXEMPTION.
UNDER THE FARCE PRACTICE ACT.
X. BUT IN PERMITS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY. TO IMPLEMENT FIRE
REDUCTION PROJECTS AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE MONITORING OF
THOSE EXEMPTIONS.
WE'RE TRYING TO OFFER OURSELVES.
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR ANYONE WHO
MAY WANT TO DO THAT WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER ED DRUG
DIRECTOR NIGHT I DO WANT TO
AGREE WITH YOU ON ON TWO POINTS
YOU MADE.
NUMBER ONE THE NEW LEADERSHIP IT
CALIFORNIA'S.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GORDON I GOT
ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN AND
AS A RESULT OF SERVING TOGETHER
IN THE ASSEMBLY GENERATED A
GREAT --
RELATIONSHIP WORKING
RELATIONSHIP SO I I AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT AND THE AND THE
SECOND THING.
I DO ALSO AGREE AND THANK YOU --
FOR THE INCREASED --
THE DECREASE REVIEW THOSE YOU
ARE DOING A MUCH BETTER JOB AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
IT'S A QUESTION THREE JUST A
QUICK QUESTION TED JUST DRILL
DOWN ON THAT THE VENTURA COUNTY
STRETCH WHAT WHAT WHAT WE THINKS.
OCCURRING THERE BECAUSE I'M
ACTUALLY I'M NOT.
AS SEEING INCREDULOUS MYSELF
AMANDO --
THE NATURE OF THE LANDSCAPE
THERE THERE ARE NEEDS IN.
WANT TO HAVE SOME CAPACITY IN
THE REGION THERE'S CERTAINLY A
LOT OF ACTIVITY GOING TO BE
GOING ON AROUND.
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT HABITAT
RESTORATION AROUND RESILIENCY SO
BUT I JUST CAN USE KIDS A LITTLE
MORE COLOR.
THAT.
I HAVE FOUND READING SENATE BILL
NINE OH ONE THAT IT TAKES A
WHILE ELISE FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND
ALL OF THE PATHWAYS IN KIND OF
NEW APPROACHES ARE INTENT IS
ALWAYS JUST CRYSTAL CLEAR SO
THAT'S A DEAL WITH THE
CATASTROPHIC RISK FACTOR --
I WOULD AGREE WITH COMMENTARY
AND PUBLIC TESTIMONY WHICH I
THINK IS TRYING TO SUGGEST
THERE'S NOT INDUSTRIAL TIMBER.
IN.
THAT PART OF THE STATUS RIGHT.
RIGHT OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LARGER TIMBER COMPANIES.
IS NO CENTRAL SIERRA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I SEE A LOT OF POTENTIAL
FUTURE ACTIVITY AROUND SMALL
LANDOWNERS --
I THINK THAT WHILE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS CONTROL OVER THE
FEDERAL DOMAIN.
YOU OBVIOUSLY STRUGGLE WITH
PRIVATE LAND ABIDING FEDERAL
LAND AND HOW THAT DYNAMIC WILL
PLAY OUT OVER TIME.
YOU MAY EVEN HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S THINKING
THROUGH WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO
MANAGE THIS RISK GOING FORWARD.
AND FOR US IN OUR DEFENSE ALL I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO OFFER IS
FOR EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE.
SOME PER.
NOT.
OVERLY.
LARGE COMMITMENT BY OUR
DEPARTMENT HAVE STAFF AVAILABLE.
TO MANAGE WHAT MAY BE COMING AND
ASSIST CAL FAR.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THAT
MAY PLAY OUT THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION HAS ADOPTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS. TO IMPLEMENT NINE A
ONE HE READ TO THOSE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THEY RELY HEAVILY ON
OUR DEPARTMENT. TO DO POST
PROJECT MONITORING AND PRE
PROJECT CONSULTATION.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE THAT ASSET.
WHERE I DON'T WANT TO BE?
IS IN TWO OR THREE YEARS FROM
NOW FOUR YEARS FROM NOW.
EVEN IF IT'S IN A PLACE WHERE
THERE'S LESS INDUSTRIAL TIMBER.
OPTIONS HAVE ARISEN.
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD CAPACITY AND
WERE BLAMED FOR BEING THE BOTTOM.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I DON'T
WANT YOU TO BE PLAYING CATCH UP
BY THERE AND I THE LARGE TIMBER
ISSUE AND THE WILD LAND AND
WHILE THEN URBAN INTERFACE ISSUE
IN THE PRIMARILY THAT NORTHERN
REGION IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
BUT VEGETATION AND FUEL
MANAGEMENT AND THE RISKS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE ALSO.
ENORMOUS ISSUE AND I I MORE NEW
ONES CHALLENGE DIFFERENT TYPE OF
LAND OWNERSHIP.
TRICKIER MARKETS MAYBE TO
PENETRATE AND TOUGHER TO GET A
COMMERCIAL OPERATION GOING BUT I
I DON'T THINK.
WE SHOULD BE FOR CLOSING THE
POSSIBILITY OF NEW INDUSTRIES
EMERGING AND AND CREATIVE NEW
ENTERPRISE IN WRITING EVEN IN
CHAPARRAL MANAGEMENT WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW IT'S TRICKY TO TO GRIND
AND GET TO A PLACE WHERE --
YOU KNOW YOU CAN BE AS VALUABLE
OF PRODUCT TO SAY YOU KNOW
REDWOOD BUT I STILL THINK.
WE CAN'T JUST.
HEY.
WE GOT A LEAVE THAT ALONE AND
JUST JUST STAY NORTH WE'VE GOT A
INNOVATE HERE SO ANY OUT I KNOW
WE'RE HOLDING OPEN I JUST WANTED
TO GET THAT IN THE RECORD TO SAY.
YOU KNOW GIVING US BASE IN%
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO GET TO TO
HAVE ROOM FOR INDUSTRY TO COME
FORWARD AND TRY TO INNOVATE AND
WE WANT TO SEE FROM ALL PARTNERS.
I THINK IS CRITICAL AND SO.
GET YOURSELF PREPARED FOR THAT
ACT -- I DO
APPRECIATE THE INTERESTS OF I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS WE WILL HOLD
THIS MATTER OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SINCE WE HAVE --
ALL OUR MEMBERS HERE LET'S CALL
THE ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
I CAN'T HEAR JONES [inaudible]
HERE JONES.
JONES ON ROLLING.
ALL I'M HERE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONEY HERE STERN.
I THE CHAIR WILL CONSIDER HIM --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR ISSUES
NUMBER ONE THROUGH.
SIX THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MINING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS MOTION ONE ON ISSUES ONE
THROUGH.
SIX I CASKEY HI.
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MORNING HI STERN.
THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF. FIVE
ZERO WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
NUMBER TWO ADDITION NUMBER.
SEVEN SENATE MCGUIRE SO MOVES
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HI JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
OKAY VERY GOOD --
CONTINUING WITH TAKING THINGS
OUT OF ORDER WE HAVE ONE SMALL
MATTER WITH EXHIBITION PARK IS
MISS.
GENERAL MANAGER LASSO HERE.
I WILL KEEP CAL FIRE WAITING BUT
THAT'S WE FINALLY GOT A QUORUM
SO I'M I'M READY TO GO THIS IS.
ITEM THE LAST ITEM.
I'M NUMBER. TWENTY SKEWS ME
SECOND LAST ITEM.
THIS IS TWO MILLION. SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FOR ONGOING INTER
AGENCY.
PURITY YES GOOD.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR --
THANK YOU ALL AT A LOSS SAID
GENERAL MANAGER EXPOSITION PARK
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR AN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND --
ALLOCATION TO FUND OUR
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
EXPOSITION PARK HAS GARNERED A
LOT OF NOTE NOTORIETY --
RECENTLY WE HAVE.
QUITE A BIT OF CONSTRUCTION
HAPPENING AT THE PARK --
IT IS IN THE DOWNTOWN AREA --
SOUTH EL áREA OF LOS ANGELES --
WITH THE GROWING NEED TO THE
PARK AND OVER FOUR MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY NEEDS HAVE GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY BUT THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL HAS
BEEN.
PROVIDING A COMMAND STAFF FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
HAS OFFERED OF QUITE A BIT OF
STAKEHOLDER AND TENANTS SUPPORT
IN --
PROVIDING --
SOME TRAINING FOR ALL OF US AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER ON SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGE CONTROL MANAGING ALL OF
OUR LARGE EVENTS --
WE HAVE THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PLANE --
COLLEGE FOOTBALL THERE WE'VE
BEEN HOST TO THE RAMS FOR THE
LAST THREE SEASONS AND WILL BE
HOSTING THEM FOR ANOTHER SEASON.
AND WE HAVE A NEW SOCCER TEAM
CALLED THE LOS ANGELES FOOTBALL
CLUB A BRAND NEW SOCCER STADIUM
AND OF COURSE THE NEW LUCAS
MUSEUM OF NARRATIVE ART --
TO SAY THE LEAST WERE VERY BUSY --
AND SO WE'D LIKE TO REALLY
SUPPORT OUR TO STATE MUSEUMS THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM IN THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER.
AND SUPPORT THEM WITH OUR
EXISTING MUSEUM SECURITY
OFFICERS AND PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL -- TO
DO ONGOING PUBLIX --
HELPUS WITH THOSE VERY LARGE
SKILLED EVENTS.
NIKKI CENTER MONEY OF A QUESTION
ON THE SECURITY CONTRACT
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION I
AM SUPPORTIVE OF MY QUESTION AND
DO THESE PROFESSIONAL TEAMS.
CONTRIBUTE ANYTHING TO THE
SECURITY COSTS ABSOLUTELY SO ALL
OF THE SPECIAL EVENTS THOSE ARE
REIMBURSABLE COST --
THE REASON WE REALLY FEEL STRONG
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL BEING THERE IS WE HAVE
CITY COUNTY --
WE ALSO HAVE SCHOOL POLICE WE
HAVE THE METRO RAIL SO THERE'S A
LOT OF ALLIED AGENCY --
SUPPORT THE NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND
BEING THAT OUR CURRENT.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY IS
ONLY A SIGN TO THE PARK --
THEIR POLICE SCENE --
REALLY IS DELEGATED TO
EXPOSITION PARKS IF ANYTHING
HAPPENS AND OF COURSE ALL OF
THESE EVENTS EMANATE OUT OF THE
PARKING EMANATE FROM THE
COMEDIAN WE REALLY WANT TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE.
TO WORK WITH ALLIE FIRE ALLEY
POLICE DEPARTMENT --
LAUSD SCHOOL --
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL LOS ANGELES
SHARE SEE YOU KNOW HOW TO
SUPPORT TEAM [inaudible]
COUNTRY THAT ALLOCATED.
WITH THE COLISEUM --
USC HAS A DIRECT CONTRACT WITH
ELLIE POLICE DEPARTMENT. FOR ALL
OF THE EVENTS THAT OUR OFFICE
MANAGER SO WE ALSO DO SPECIAL
EVENTS IN THE PARK AND LEASE OUT
SOME OF THE COMMON AREAS WE
CHARGE THE EVENT PROMOTER ALL OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COSTA WE
OFFSET THAT AS REIMBURSABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
FINANCE HAVE ANYTHING LET'S OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARINGS STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OR HERE ON THIS
AUGMENTATION.
BUT THE SECURITY CONTRACT AT THE
EXPOSITION PARK.
CLOSING THE PUBLIC HEARING WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
OKAY NUMBER APPROVED THE BUDGET.
AUGMENTATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL I CASKEY I JONES
[inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
THE MEDICINE YOU FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YEAH RIGHT
DIRECTOR --
BORDER WORKED UP TO CAL FIRE
STARTED KEEP EVERYBODY WAITING
BUT WE HAVE --
EIGHTY ISSUES THAT ARE.
BEFORE US WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
JUST TO RECAP.
IF WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE
MATTER OPEN I'LL JUST PASSAGE IN
THEN THE PUBLIC HEARING WILL
OCCUR AT THE END IF WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ACTION.
ON THE MATTER THEN WILL --
DO IT AT THAT AT THE TIME WE
CALL THE ISSUE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU. FOR
FOR BEING HERE AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN A WHITE
HOUSE SKI AND THE SENATORS --
NO PROBLEM WE'RE HERE AT YOUR
DISPOSAL.
AND THIS IS THE ISSUE EIGHTY
ENHANCE FIRE PROTECTION
RESOURCES.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND
WHAT I'M GONNA SAY --
UP FRONT FOR ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
THE STAFF'S OUTLINE AND ANALYSIS
THAT'S THAT'S IN THE AGENDA IS
IS HIGH QUALITY VERY GOOD AND
AND SO I I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
UP FRONT I WON'T SAY IT EVERY
TIME BUT BUT FOR EVERY ISSUE
THAT IS THE CASE.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
[inaudible]
SO.
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT HOW AND AND I AND I AM
SORRY BUT I DID BRING --
MIKE RICH WINE ACTING --
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL WITH ME --
FOR ONE OF THE ITEMS BUT HE'S
ALSO -- HERE.
WITH FOR ANY QUESTIONS AS AS
THEY MAY COME UP.
SO ISSUE IT AND NUMBER --
EIGHT IT WHICH IS ENHANCED FIRE
PROTECTION RESOURCES CAL FIRE
AND THE CCC.
TOGETHER REQUESTING IT NINETY
FIVE HAVE GENERAL FUND.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIONS --
IN THE COMING FISCAL YEAR.
OF FOR A COME IT'S A REAL
COMPREHENSIVE SUITE OF RESOURCES.
ALL OF THESE RESOURCES ARE
IMPORTANT FOR SITE FIRE
SUPPRESSION AND THEY THEY ARE --
HELPFUL TOWARD MEETING OUR OUR
GOAL OF OF INCREASING OUR
CAPABILITIES --
IN THE NEAR TERM AS WERE --
DOING ANALYSIS TO LOOK AT THE
MID AND LONG TERM AND WHAT WILL
COME BACK WITH THOSE --
ITEMS AT A LATER DATE SO IN THIS.
ITEM.
OR ADDITIONAL FIRE ENGINES --
THAT OUR STAFF TEN YEAR ROUND.
INCREASED AT A HEAVY FIRE
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS.
DEDICATED CCC CREWS AND
DEDICATED MEANS THEY ARE TRULY
FIRE CREWS --
THE WILL BE DEDICATED TO THAT.
AIR TANKERS THAT IS --
SEE. ONE THIRTY FIVE AIR TANKERS
THAT WILL EXTEND THE LIFE OF OUR
EXISTING S. --
TO FLEET OF AIRCRAFT AT THAT ARE --
FIXED WING AIR TANKERS FOR UP TO
THIRTY YEARS MAYBE EVEN LONGER.
THE EMPLOYEE WELLNESS HI THAT IS
BOTH ON THE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
WELLNESS OF OUR EMPLOYEES THE
MOST IMPORTANT A PART OF CAL
FIRES RESOURCES.
A FIRE DETECTION CAMERAS.
AND MAKING A A PERMANENT --
ALLOCATION FOR OUR FLEET --
REPLACEMENT.
SO.
I AS I SAID RATHER THAN GOING
THROUGH EACH ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALLY IN GREAT DEPTH AYE
AYE I WANT TO TURN BACK TO THE
THE THE ANALYSIS IN THE AGENDA
AS AS THE AUTHORITY FOR THAT --
BUT I DO WANT --
TO COVER JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE THE COMPREHENSIVENESS
AND THE MULTIPLE TOOLS THAT THIS
GIVES US.
ALL OF THESE TOGETHER --
INCOME WE ARE ARE --
ABILITY TO RESPOND --
TO WILDFIRES AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND BY HAVING ALL OF THEM
TOGETHER --
WE BELIEVE THIS IS THIS IS A
GOOD --
EFFORT TOWARD.
MEETING THE NEAR TERM GOALS
WHILE WE'RE WELL WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE MORE LONG TERM AND MID
TERM -- ASKS
THAT WILL COME FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE.
SO I WANTED TO SWITCH TO CIRCLE
BACK THOUGH TO TWO THINGS --
THE ONE BEING WHAT I BELIEVE IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF OF
ALL OF THIS AND THAT IS THE THE
FIREFIGHTERS FOUND THE RESPOND --
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH.
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO LOOK FOR
LOOK AT THAT AS AS THE OUR TOP
PRIORITY.
WITHOUT THOSE RESPOND OR IS NONE
OF THE REST OF HIS EQUIPMENT.
MAKES IT TO THE FIRE AND AND NO
DECISIONS ARE MADE.
OR THE OTHER OR ANY OTHER TYPE
OF AMER THAT IS ABSOLUTELY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO ME --
AND IN THIS PROPOSAL TO ME --
I KNOW IT'S NOT THE THE MOST
SEXY PART OF IT BUT IT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT --
THAT OUR PEOPLE NEED TO TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR FEET MAYBE BE
HELPFUL IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN. TO
TO US WHAT'S NOT COVERED ON
UNDER THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE
PROGRAM WHEN WE KNOW WE HAVE
SEEN EMPLOYEES THEY HAVE AN
EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
SO YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SCREEN FOR HEART
DISEASE AND CERTAIN TYPES OF
CANCER.
WHY WOULD THAT NOT BE UNDER THE
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM THAT YOU
HAVE THAT IT CURRENTLY IS
AFFORDED THEM AND?
AND AND THOSE TYPE OF NO P. T.
S. D. WHY WOULD THAT NOT BE.
COVERED UNDER THE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM THAT THE EMPLOYEES HAVE
HONOR OR A INDIVIDUALIZE
EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT.
IS.
AFFORDED I LEASES I UNDERSTAND
MY EMPLOYEES.
ED AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND AND AND WITH WHAT
I'M GOING TO REFER TO IS SOME OF
THAT STUFF CAN BE AND AND
EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY USE UTILIZE.
ALL OF THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT WE NEED TO
ALSO I DID I I DO ESCOBAR STAFF
THAT ARE WORKING IN THE THE MORE --
OFFICE OR SINGLE LOCATION TYPE
OF OF SETTING.
THEY ARE SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
THE STATE --
ANY TIME OF YEAR IT MAY BE --
IN THE WINTER WHEN WE'RE HAVING
ORVILLE OVERFLOWING AND AND AND
AND EMERGENCY OCCURRING THERE --
COULD BE A HEALTH RELATED
EMERGENCY OR OR EARTHQUAKE --
AND THEY'RE GONE FROM FROM THERE --
THEIR HOMES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS THOSE SERVICES FOR WEEKS
AND MONTHS AT A TIME --
AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING TO
THE TWO HELP THOSE PEOPLE WHEN
THEY ARE DEPLOYED --
THIS IS THIS IS PART OF OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE SUITE THAT'S UNDER
THIS PART --
THAT ALLOWS FOR ACCESS TO SOME
OF THAT PRE SCREENING.
CAPABILITIES THAT IS MORE --
DIRECTED TO THEIR NEEDS.
AS AS BEING EXPOSED --
TO CARCINOGENIC A CARCINOGENIC
SMOKE AND DIFFERENT THINGS AND
SO THE SO THERE'S PRE SCREENING
THAT'S INVOLVED.
THERE'S THE HEART --
SCREENING THAT YOU MENTIONED --
BUT THERE'S ALSO ACCESS --
TO PROFESSIONALS AND PEERS THAT
ARE AT THE INCIDENTS AND ALLOW.
FOR US TO WORK WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES BECAUSE MAYBE THEY
HAVE ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON AT
HOME AND THEY CANNOT GET
RELEASED --
THERE THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO
DO TO DO THAT KIND OF COUNSELING
AT THE INCIDENT.
AND AND WORK THROUGH ISSUES FIRE
ENGINE AND OR STRIKE TEAM OF
FIRE ENGINES BACK ON THE LINE --
WITHOUT HAVING.
A NEGATIVE EFFECT DOWN THE LINE
FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES.
PILOT PROGRAM.
WORK OUR THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY'RE UP IN
THE FIELD THAT ARE ASSISTING THE
OTHER FIREFIGHTERS --
TO TO TREAT THIS THIS INDIVIDUAL
OR IS THIS JUST PURE.
ASSISTANCE THAT'S GOING ON
THAT'S PART OF THE THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S A PILOT THAT YOU
WANT EXPAND STATEWIDE --
AND THEN SO THAT'S THE FIRST
PART OF QUESTION THE SECOND PART
IS OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS I
ASSUME THAT THESE STRESSORS ARE
GOING ON SIMULTANEOUSLY IS THE
ARE THE FAMILY MEMBERS.
NOT TO GO TO KAISER AND TO USE
THIS.
PROGRAM OR IS THIS AN
AUGMENTATION OR REPLACEMENT I
GUESS IS THE QUESTION.
THIS IS THIS IS MEANT FOR THE
EMPLOYEE BUT THERE ARE ASPECTS
THAT THAT THE FAMILY MEMBERS
MIGHT BE ABLE.
TO BE DRAWN INTO IF THERE'S IF
THERE'S AND THAT IS THAT'S FOR
MORE OF THE PROFESSIONAL
PROGRAMS --
THAT ARE IN THAT IT WOULD BE
UNDER CONTRACT WE AREN'T WE
AREN'T HIRING --
THE CLINICIANS THOSE WOULD BE
THE THE PIER AND AND A SUPPORT
FROM A DEPARTMENT LEVEL EMPLOYEE --
THAT IS HIS MORE PEER TO PEER
SUPPORT WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND SPECIALTY IN IN
IDENTIFYING AND WHAT KIND OF
SERVICES AN INDIVIDUAL MIGHT
NEED.
AND IT REALLY READ DOES REQUIRE
US TO HAVE A A A GOOD NUMBER OF
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AS THAT
HAVE THE BACKGROUND OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
RESPONDING SO THEY CAN REALLY
RELATE TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE THOSE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS THAT
OCCUR.
CENTER MONNING QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
IN YOUR SERVICE --
RELATED TO THIS THE EMPLOYEE
WELLNESS.
YOU DIDN'T MENTION IT BUT
PERHAPS IT'S SOME.
UNDERSTOOD BUT IS PART OF THIS
NEED THE INCREASING DEMANDS PUT
ON FIREFIGHTERS WITH OUR NEW
ABNORMAL IS FORMER GOVERNOR
BROWN CALLED IT --
MORE YEAR ROUND.
FIRE FIGHTING DUTIES IN MORE
TIME AWAY FROM HOME.
SENATOR MINING THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS IS --
AT THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS AO
WE NEEDED YOUR SUPPORT AND NOW
WE NEED A DEDICATED GROUP THAT'S
INCLUDED INCLUDING YOUR SUPPORT
TO TO DEAL WITH THE DEMAND --
IN YOUR DISTRICT WE HAD THE
SOPRANOS FIRE AND THERE WERE.
THERE WERE PEOPLE ON THAT FIRE
PLUS DAYS.
AND THEY WERE THERE AWAY FROM
THEIR HOMES.
AND WE DID HAVE OUR EMPLOYEES
SUPPORT SERVICES THE THE THE
FLEDGLING GROUP THAT WE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BUILD --
FROM BAD TO WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO GO HERE AND AND THEY WERE
VERY EFFECTIVE IN HELPING PEOPLE
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
JUST CONCEPTUALIZING THE BASE
CAMPS THAT YOU BUILD FIRE SITES.
WITH THE SERVICES BE AVAILABLE
ON AT THOSE.
BASE CAMP SITES THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE WOULD DO WE WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN --
BRINGING IN A TRAILER --
AND HAVING THOSE SERVICES
AVAILABLE AND WHAT WE FOUND IS
THE DEMAND. FOR THAT SERVICE IS
OUTSTRIPPING OUR ABILITY TO
SERVE THAT AND AND INTERESTINGLY
IT'S NOT JUST CAL FIRE EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE COMING IN IT'S FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES IT'S IT'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES --
WHO ARE COMING IN AND GETTING
THOSE SERVICES THAT LEADS TO MY
NEXT QUESTION ARE THE?
CCC DEDICATED CREWS ALSO WOULD
THEY BE ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
SERVICES.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS FIRE CREWS.
GREAT QUESTION AND WHILE WE'RE
BUILDING THIS IS A CAL FIRE --
RESOURCE --
WHEN OUT ON WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
GOING TO HELP EVERYBODY --
AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
EXPAND THESE TYPES OF SERVICES
TO TO ALL RESPOND HERS AND I
KNOW THAT --
CPF AND OTHERS ARE INTERESTED IN
WORKING TOWARD SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES ON MORE OF THE BROAD
SPECTRUM --
AND I CAN WORK WITH --
DIRECTOR SITE --
ON ON HOW THAT LOOKS FOR CCC.
THANK YOU ON I THINK YOU LIEU TO
THIS BUT THE PARALLELS WITH PTSD
OF VETERANS RETURNING FROM
COMBAT ZONES THERE'S A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES.
BUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THE
STIGMATIZING.
WHAT IT MEANS TO ACCESS THESE
SERVICES?
WOULD PART OF YOUR PROGRAM.
HAD YOU POPULARIZE THIS IN.
ASSURE PEOPLE THAT IT'S NOT
GONNA COUNT AGAINST THEM.
WITH RESPECT TO PROMOTION INNER
FUTURE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT IS A WONDERFUL QUESTION AND
AND THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT
BECAUSE IT IS AND IT HAS BEEN
AND TEN YEARS AGO --
PEOPLE WOULD NOT TALK ABOUT ANY
OF THIS IT WAS KIND OF THE
SHADOWS WITH HAVE TRAINING WE WE
DO HAVE --
YOU KNOW HOW TO RECOGNIZE THINGS
BUT THEN IT WOULD JUST DISAPPEAR --
AND PEOPLE WERE GETTING --
BUT IT WOULD BE IN A QUIET.
WAY PLACE.
THAT IS CHANGING IT'S CHANGING
DRAMATICALLY --
I AM SEEING.
A AND THERE'S TWO TWO THINGS I
WANT TO MENTION.
I'M SEEING A PARTICULARLY AFTER
THE WHAT'S HAPPENED LAST YEAR
WITH THE CAMP THE THE WALLS THE
THE THE CAR AND THE MENDOCINO
COMPLEX.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT
ALL SUMMER LONG AND SOME OF
THOSE SAME PEOPLE --
WATCHED THEIR COMMUNITY.
BURN TO THE GROUND AROUND THEM.
AND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO TO TALK WITH
SOME SOME OF THOSE FOLKS WHO WHO.
FLAT OUT SAID TO ME THAT AS THE
DIRECTOR.
WE ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
SS AND WE WOULD NOT WE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO WORK TODAY IF THAT
WAS NOT.
THERE FOR US AND SO WE PUT A LOT
OF OUR EFFORTS THERE --
AFTER THE CAMPFIRE IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE OF OF THE THE IMPACT IT
HAD TO OUR POLICE I THINK IT
IGHT BE USEFUL I DON'T KNOW HOW
THE PILOT WILL BE CONSTRUCTED
THAT.
IF THERE CAN BE SOME EXPLICIT --
MESSAGING.
THE TEAM MEMBERS.
THE TECH CAN'T BE A GROUNDS FOR
RETALIATION OR LOSING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PROMOTION --
IN WE HAVE A LOT OF NEW.
LAWS AND RULES HERE IN THE
CAPITAL ABOUT --
PROTECTING EMPLOYEES WHO ASSERT
THEIR RIGHTS NOT BEING SUBJECT
TO RETALIATION OR DISCRIMINATION
IN FUTURE EMPLOYMENT IN.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT IS
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
TO MAYBE FURTHER REDUCE THE
STIGMA OR THE FEAR --
IN MY FINAL QUESTION OF GOES TO
THE CCC CREWS.
WHAT IS THE?
WHAT'S THE TRANSITION RATE OF
CCC CREWS WHO END UP FINDING A
CAREER WITH CAL FIRE AND OR ANY.
INTENTIONAL EFFORT.
NOT JUST TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
CREWS ON THE WORK THEY DO.
BUT TO OFFER THEM.
CAREER ADVANCEMENT WITH CAL FIRE.
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION I'M NOT
PREPARED TO GIVE YOU A A NUMBER
OF STATISTIC ON THAT --
I WILL WORK WITH A DIRECTOR SIDE --
TO TO FIND A TO FIGURE THAT OUT --
ANECDOTALLY I DO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY --
CCC -- CORPS
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BECOME
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WITH
US THE FOREST SERVICE AND OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AND I KNOW
THAT THAT --
WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS OF OF
SEE SEE SEE THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN -- IN
GETTING JOB RULES CREWS THAT ARE
ALSO A PART OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THE SIX THAT ARE THAT
WE'VE HIRED.
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE IN THE
FUTURE ANY DATA IN ANY.
ANY INFORMATION IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE CC CRUZ CCC
CREWS ABOUT FUTURE.
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT.
WHEN THEY'RE WORKING WITHIN CCC?
THERE COULD BE SOME TARGETS THAT --
INSPIRE ACHIEVEMENT IN GOOD
EMPLOYMENT RECORDS KNOWING THAT
THAT CAN BE REWARDED WITH FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
REPORTER WE DID START THIS
BARRAGE OF QUESTIONS I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU COMPLETED YOUR
REMARKS ON THE ON THE ENTIRE --
I REQUEST AND ISSUE A SO IF YOU
WANTED TO BEFORE WE GET TO THE
REST OF THE QUESTIONS IF YOU
WANT [inaudible]
TO OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU I DID I DID HAVE ONE
LAST THE IT WAS IT WAS ONE LAST
PIECE -- AND
THAT IS --
UNDER THE SEA --
ONE THIRTY THE STAFFING
COMPONENT AND WHAT I'M CALLING
THE START UP COSTS --
FOR THE C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAM --
WE ARE IN WHEN WE'RE OUT WE WE
ARE AWARE THAT --
LA -- HAS
SOME CONTINUED QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT STARTUP COSTS THAT I I
REFERENCED AND WE ARE WORKING WE
HAVE ONE OUTSIDE OUTSTANDING
ITEM THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING --
TO SUPPLY THAT INFORMATION TO LA --
ON AND WILL THE REPORT BACK ONCE
WE HAVE --
FINALIZE THAT AND SO LISTER FOR
THE QUESTIONS THAT'S THE LA --
HERE.
IF YOU DON'T FACT A ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AND SO LOOKING AT THE AND ALL OF
THE PROPOSALS TOGETHER AS A
PACKAGE AND WE WE DO THINK THAT
IT IT MAKES SENSE FOR THE STATE
TO CONSIDER INCREASING ITS FIRE
RESPONSE CAPACITY RESOURCES.
AND GIVEN THAT THE SEVERITY OF
RECENT FIRE CONDITIONS IN THE
LIKELY HAD THAT THAT CONTINUES
WITH -- THE
ONGOING EFFECTS OF THE DROUGHT
BURKE BEETLE INFESTATION IN AND
OTHER CONDITIONS CLIMATE CHANGE
AS WELL.
I AM AND SO WE THINK INCREASING
RESOURCES OVERALL IS REASONABLE --
WE WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU
REQUIRE CAL FIRE TO WORK WITH IT
WE ASKED TO DO AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT THEIR EXISTING FIRE
RESPONSE CAPACITY.
IS AND WHAT THE GAPS ARE AND TO
PRIORITIZE WEIGHTS AND WE'RE
RESOURCES COULD BE ADDED.
ON AND WAIT AND IMPROVEMENT IN
GOALS AND OUTCOMES THAT WOULD
ACHIEVE AND WE THINK THAT THAT
WOULD HELP YOU TO AND EVALUATE.
FUTURE REQUEST THAT --
CAM GONNA COME IN THIS IT'S IT'S
LIKELY THAT THIS IS NOT THE
FINAL REQUEST FOR INCREASING AND
FIRE RESPONSE CAPACITY YOU'VE
PROVIDED A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
IN THIS BUDGET ON AND COMING
YEARS AND SO WE THINK THIS
ASSESSMENT WOULD REALLY HELP
INFORM.
ON THE FUTURE DECISIONS THAT YOU
ARE LIKELY GOING TO NEED TO MAKE
TO ENSURE THAT INCREASE
RESOURCES ARE PAID AND THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY AREAS AND THE
INCREASES ARE DONE IN THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
THAT'S THE SORT OF OVERALL AND
WITH REGARD TO THE THE C. --
ONE THIRTY TANKERS THAT THE
PROPOSAL OVERALL WAS WAS
SOMEWHAT LACKING IN DETAIL AND
THAT WE WE TYPICALLY EXPECT TO
SEE WITH SO MANY DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS REALLY ESSENTIALLY
INDIVIDUAL PROPOSALS PACKED.
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC FOR
THIS HE WENT --
THIRTY TANKERS ON THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL AND RESPONSIVE TO ASK IN
THE MANY QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD ACROSS THE VARIOUS I AM A
DIFFERENT.
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO A YOU KNOW SHARE
THAT INFORMATION WITH STAFF WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THOSE THAT BACK
AND FORTH ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'S
PUBLIC AND SO.
FOR THE PUBLIC TRYING TO FOLLOW
LONGER FOLKS TRYING TO TO LOOK
BACK -- AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS YEAR
ONCE ONCE THIS IS DONE.
AND IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO
HAVE SOME OF THAT DETAIL IN
INFORMATION AND THAT'S ALWAYS
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK TO GET
THE QUESTIONS ANSWERED ON THE C. --
ONE THIRTY TANKERS --
WHAT WERE TALKING ADAM
INCREASING TO TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN OUT YOUR COSTS
WHILE THESE PLANES WOULD BE
PROVIDED --
FOR FREE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THERE IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ON MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONAL COSTS --
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT THOSE
COSTS ALL IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RECEIVED AND THAT
THERE COULD BE A POTENTIAL
ADDITIONAL COSTS BEYOND THAT AND
SO WILL CONTINUE WORKING
HOPEFULLY THE NEXT TIME THIS
COMES UP ON THIS WILL HAVE MORE
TO REPORT BACK --
BUT WANT TO ENSURE THAT YOU ALL
HAVE COMPLETE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY IS INCLUDED IN THAT
PROPOSAL.
FINANCE HOUSING HERE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND JUST WANT TO
REITERATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ELIO STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED AND THE PUBLIC HAS THE
INFORMATION AND HAVE THE SAME
INFORMATION AND SO WE ARE.
COMMITTED TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT FUTURE PROPOSALS HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF DETAIL I'M
WE DIDN'T KNOW I DO WANT TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT AND THEN PASS IT
BACK AND TO THE DIRECTOR WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO THIS
BETTER BUT NOTED FROM THE AGENDA --
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE AN
ASSESSMENT BY APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY AND OUT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT IS V<c.cyan> IS THIS</c>
ASSESSMENT IS VITAL.
IN TERMS OF MAKING DECISIONS --
RELATED TO CAL FIRE IS
OPERATIONAL NEEDS THAT IS A
FAIRLY SHORT TIME LINE
SPECIFICALLY AS WE KNOW FIRE
THEIR FIRE ACTIVITY IS GOING TO
BE RAMPING UP AND WILL CARRY
THROUGH DECEMBER INTO THAT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM.
LIKE A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TIME
TO THE TYPE OF A DEEPER DIVE
DATA ANALYSIS AND THAT REALLY
WOULD INFORM I'M SORT OF THE
STATE'S LONGER TERM PROJECTIONS
IN TERMS OF CAL FIRES NEEDS.
REALLY DOES THE CHAIR PASSED ON
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
S. R. A SO IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS
A IS A A NICE.
TIME -- TO
SINCE WERE ASKING FOR FORTY
MILLION IN AND FIRE TRUCKS AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
AN INCREASE STAFFING THAT IN THE
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION THAT WE'RE
BACK FILLING.
ON THE THE LEGISLATION THAT WE
PASSED ON EXTENDING THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM WOULD SEEM LIKE
MONEY THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE IF
WE JUST DID BUSINESS AS USUAL
AND WENT BACK TO THE THE WAITED
WE HAD TRADITIONALLY.
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED
WOULD PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES FOR
THE THE AT LEAST THIS ITEM OF
NINE POINT. NINETY SIX POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
IT IS JUST TO CLARIFY IT IN
TERMS OF THIS YOU RESPONSIBILITY
AREA FIRE PREVENTION FIND IN
TERMS OF THE FEES THAT WERE
DEPOSITED INTO THAT FIND.
THAT AMOUNT IS IS BEEN FULLY
BAK FILLED BY THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE TO CAL FIRE CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE SEAT
RESPONSIBILITY AREA FIRE
PREVENTION FUND WOULD HAVE
SUPPORTED.
I'M CONSISTENT WITH WITH PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE AND EIGHTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT WHICH EXTENDED THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM RIGHT IN
IF THAT PROVISION OF BACK
FILLING THE S. R. A FEE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT LEGISLATION
THAT WE IMPROVE.
THEM WE WOULD HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
WE WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CAP
AND TRADE FUND WHICH IS.
WHICH WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
MANY THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
WERE LOOKING AT AND IN THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL I JUST YOU KNOW
REYES RESET WITH FINANCE WHICH
HAVE REYES BEFORE BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AS WE GO
THROUGH OTHER.
THIS BUDGET SEASON TO TO AUGMENT
OUR RESOURCES WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT THE CATASTROPHIC.
CONSEQUENCES SO WE WE WE DID
SOMETHING WAS SUPERB.
A DEAL AND I AND I GET THAT BUT
WE NEVER I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE
FULLY APPRECIATE WHAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE DID THAT
EXTENSION AND THE AND THE FIRE
SEASON SO I JUST.
RAISE IT WON'T BE THE LAST TIME
I REYES SAID --
WE HAVE OF CENTER STERN HAS
QUESTION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO I JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
SAY THINK IT AT CHIEF FOR
ADVANCEMENTS ENGINE PART IN A
FINANCE --
WHO HAVE BEEN SO GOOD ON ALL
ISSUES THE FIRES OF THE PAST
WITH YEAH AND --
BOTH ON RECOVERY IN RESPONSE TO
JUST ONE TAKE MOMENT --
IN OFTEN DISPOSITIVE IN MAYES
AND WORK WITH AND JUST WANT TO
COME TO THE THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES AND OF COURSE THE
CAL FIRE FOR EVERYTHING THEY'VE
BEEN DOING.
ON THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
BEEN FACING --
IN IS AN INCREDIBLY RESPONSIVE.
LIKE TO BE A CENTER STERN I BEEN
WORKING.
ON THE ISSUE OF ADDITIONAL.
FIRE ENGINES WITH CAL FIRE --
IN ONE OF THE FIRST OF ALL SAY
THANK YOU I TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
ADVANCING THE THIRTEEN ON AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I WANNA BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE THAT WE DISCUSSED AT THE
LARGER BUDGET HEARING.
ON IN GOING TO THAT JUST A BIT
[inaudible]
SO.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
SOME NUANCES WITH CONTRACT
COUNTIES OF WHERE.
ORIGINALLY ENGINES WERE LEFT FOR
EXAMPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY --
WHEN NAY TRANSITION?
AND REMAIN IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT
THERE'S SOME NUANCES IN REGARDS
TO WHERE WE'VE BEEN WITH.
NUMBER OF ENGINES PERSONNEL ON
THE ROAD AND WHERE WE'RE AT NOW.
IF WE LOOK BACK HISTORICALLY TO
SAY I'M.
WE HAVE. TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE P. FIRE ENGINES
RIGHT NOW.
I SEASONAL AS WELL AS FULL TIME.
ON THE ROAD.
EACH FIRE SEASON.
IF WE LOOK AT PLUS THIRTEEN AS
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT TAKES IS THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX ANDERSON THOSE.
THIRTEEN OR ALL PROPOSED TO BE
FULL TIME.
AND THAT STILL KEEPS US BELOW
WHERE WE'RE AT IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IF WE FAST
FORWARD AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
TYPE OF FIRES THAT THIS IS BEEN
SEEN OF THE LAST DECADE.
I WILL GO THROUGH ALL THE
STATISTICS BUT IT'S NOT ONLY.
THE LARGEST BUT THE MOST
STRUCTURE.
WE DISCUSSED LE LET ME HEARING A
THAT I CENTER STERN HOSTED.
WITH US YESTERDAY --
INTO WAS A THINKING FIRE
MARSHALL FOR BEING SO ELOQUENT.
IN HIS PRESENTATION.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME --
BAN WITH ISSUES OF BEING ABLE TO
GET FOLKS TRAINED. TO BE A STAFF
THE ENGINES ANYWHERE TO GET THE
ENGINES FULLY OUTFITTING DEVELOP.
GOING THROUGH THE VENDOR YES IT.
THIRTEEN AND THE SAME TIME
THOUGH.
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO GO THE
NUMBER OF ACRES THAT ARE BURNING?
LOSING JUST IN PARADISE ALONE
LAST YEAR NINETEEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES LARGEST WHILE LINE
FIRING HER I NATION'S HISTORY
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE --
IN THIS TREND CONTINUES TO GET
WORSE WE ARE STILL AT NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE A IS.
UP BEYOND.
AND IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT AN
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
ADVANCEMENT.
OF FROM THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO
GET US THOSE --
ENGINES PURCHASED IT WOULD BE
ABOUT A SIXTY TO SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING COST.
THERE'S SOME FLUCTUATE
FLUCTUATING THERE BECAUSE
DEPENDING ON IF IT'S THREE OR
THREE POINT TWO FIVE RANGING
THAT'S ALL NEED TO GET WORKED
OUT.
I'M.
BUT THAT'S WHERE I THINK.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO IN --
STERN I KNOW WILL SPEAK TO THIS
AS WELL BUT CHIEF.
I I THINK OUR I'VE HEARD FOLKS
IN CAL FIRE SAY WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET.
TO FOUR HUNDRED CAN YOU CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT --
AND HOW WE CAN ADVANCE.
I ADDITIONAL ENGINES THIS YEAR.
ON THE THIRTEENTH BE ON THE
THIRTEENTH.
GREAT GREAT THE QUESTION AMEND
TAKE THAT --
IN IN TWO WAYS UHHUH START TO
START WITH WHY WERE AT THIRTEEN
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THIRTEEN IS THE IS THE MAGIC
NUMBER.
WE WE DON'T --
WE KNOW THAT WITH THIRTEEN WITH
THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT A HEAVY FIRE
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS --
THE AIR TANKER --
START UP COSTS THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT OUR ADDITIONAL
HELICOPTERS ARE COMING OUT WHICH
ARE NOT PART OF THIS THERE
ALREADY THOSE ARE COMING FROM
LAST YEAR THOSE IN A INCREASED
CAPABILITIES BUT THESE.
THE CCC CREWS ARE BACK FILLING
SOME OF OUR OUR CREWS THAT ARE
STARTING TO DUE TO LACK OF
INMATES --
AND THEN --
THE THE OTHER ELEMENTS THAT ARE
IN HERE --
THOSE ARE AS A SWEET --
THEY'RE GETTING US TO WEAR OR WE
CAN REALLY MOVE FORWARD THIS
YEAR WITH A WITH A BETTER
RESOURCE TO DO SO --
AS FAR AS IF WE COULD DO MORE A
MINUTE TAKE YOUR YOUR SECOND
WILL.
COULD WE GET TO MORE THIS THIS --
THIS YEAR --
IF WE COULD DO MORE I WOULD SAY --
THERE IS PROBABLY.
MORE THAT WE COULD DO --
IT WOULD BE A TALL ORDER TO DO
MORE THAN THE THIRTEEN I BECAUSE
OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU RATE
RAISED RELATED --
TO PURCHASING THE EQUIPMENT AS
WELL AS AS A TRAINING THE LOUISE.
TO OPERATE THAT EQUIPMENT.
AND PERMANENT AND HAVE THEM AS
PERMANENT EMPLOYEES --
BUT THE THE SUITE THAT WE HAVE --
IN FRONT OF US AND AND WE'RE
PRESENTING --
THROUGH THIS BUDGET IS IS --
KIND OF WHERE WE FEEL IS IS IS A
NO REGRETS ASK AND THIS IS WHERE
WE WE ARE CURRENTLY --
RELATED --
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVENTY FIVE
I I II -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND THE AND I
CAN'T DISAGREE THAT IN IN OUR
MATH WE HAVE --
TWENTY THREE LESS ENGINES THAN
WE DID AT THAT POINT TIME --
WE ACTUALLY HAVE LESS --
EMPLOYEES ON ENGINES BUT THAT
WAS A VERY SEASONAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT --
WE HAVE MOVED TO A VERY YEAR
ROUND FIRE DEPARTMENT NEED AND
SO SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK OUT
WHAT THE BALANCE IS BETWEEN
PERMANENT YEAR ROUND FIRE
ENGINES AND STAFFING.
AS OPPOSED TO OUR SEASONAL PEAK
NEEDS THESE THIRTEEN WILL ADD TO
OUR PEAK NEEDS --
WHERE BACK IN IN THE IN THE
SEVENTIES WE WERE WHOLLY A --
A SEASONAL FIRED ANYBODY ON
WINTERS LIKE THIS --
MY I THINK HERE'S YOU ARE THE
THE EXPERT I'M A LAY PERSON IN --
TEEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN.
IN OUR OUR NEXT THE WOODS.
THERE IS NO GREATER CHAMPION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FOR FIREFIGHTERS
IN YOU CHIEF.
BUT THERE IS NO BETTER TOOL TO
BE ABLE TO SOLVE WHAT I WILL
CALL CRISIS WITHIN THE RANKS OF
CAO FIGHTER AND OR MUNICIPAL
FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN GETTING
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL ON BOARD.
OUT WE ARE.
TAX SEEN OUR FIREFIGHTERS LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
YOU HAVE MORE STRESS LEAVING
YOU'VE HAD EVER BEFORE.
I'M THERE ARE MORE CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE RANKS OF PHYSICAL
INJURY INJURY OR HEAR FROM.
THE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
[inaudible]
AND BOTTOM LINE IS WE CAN.
ADVANCE WHICH WE SHOULD IN IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
MENTAL HEALTH FOR FIREFIGHTERS
WE NEED MORE FIREFIGHTERS.
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE STARTED
THE ANALYSIS ALREADY WITH THE
YES. THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
HUNDRED PARTS OF THREE AN ENGINE
FOR REQUESTED IN THE FIRST
TWELVE HOURS NORTH A FIRESTORM
HUNDRED THIRTY RIGHT
[inaudible]
TURN.
THIRTY OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IS
NOT KEEPING UP WITH A SEVERITY
FIRES THAT WE HAVE CAL FIRES
UNABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
SEVERITY FIRES THAT WE HAVE.
IN THE BEST TOOL THAT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO COMBAT THE CRISIS
WHEN IT COMES TO MIDDLE HEALTH.
WITH FIREFIGHTERS BEING GONE TWO
THREE FOUR MONTHS AT A TIME IT'S
GETTING MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
AND WE CAN'T COMPARE THE
CONDITIONS HE'S THE CONDITIONS
THAT WE HAVE HERE.
I KNOW I'M PREACHING THE CHOIR
ALL I'M SAYING IS.
IT IS TIME TO BE ABLE TO BITE
THE BULLET AND MAKE THE
INVESTMENT --
AND LONG TERM IF WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE INSURED LOSSES THAT WE'VE
HAD OVER TWELVE BILLION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE A I
GREW TO CHAIR WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT FIRE.
PREVENTION.
AND WE HAVE TO BE A LOOK AT FIRE
RESPONSE AND I THINK THAT WERE
NOT THERE WITH IN THIS BUDGET
WHICH IS WHY.
WANT TO BE A CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE ON THEN I'LL JUST JUMP
TO ONE OTHER ITEM.
IS -- IN
ADDITION TO THE SIX POINT SIX
MILLION --
WE'RE LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THE IMPACT OF WILDLAND FIRE
SMOKE.
I WITHIN THE WILL.
AND AGAIN.
WHEN YOU BRING UP SOME OF THE
MOST TOXIC AIR I'M PARAPHRASING
HERE -- IT'S
IMPACTING BOTH CAL FIRE AS WELL
AS A MUNICIPAL FIREFIGHTERS
ACROSS THE STATE --
AND THAT'S THE OTHER PIECE THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS IN ON IN
ADDITION TO THE SIX POINT SIX
MILLION. FIVE MILLION TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK.
AT UP FOR THE IN FOR THE IMPACT
OF OF SMOKE COMING FROM THE WILL
BE AND WHAT WE NEED TO BE A TO
DO PRETTY AT BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THOSE MEN WOMEN OR THE FRONT
LINES EACH AND EVERY DAY.
HAVING TO BE ABLE TO BREATHE
THAT -- IN
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE I'M I
HAVE ONE QUICK QUESTION AS HE
WENT THIRTIES AND JUST ANY TO
TIONAL REACTION CHIEF AND AGAIN.
PLEASE DON'T TAKE THIS IS ME
THROWING STONES BECAUSE I AM SO
GRATEFUL ON EMOTIONAL THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT --
EVERYTHING A COW FIRES DONE BY.
I ALSO BELIEVE WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON GETTING ADDITIONAL FOLKS ON
THE GROUND.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE --
ANNA AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE RECOGNITION OF OF OF THE THE
EMPLOYEE BECAUSE THAT REALLY IS
IT IS THE ANSWER TO ALL OF THIS.
EVEN TO THE POINT OF WE NEED
MORE EMPLOYEES FOR THE ENGINES
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE BECAUSE
WERE STAFFED AT A DIFFERENT
LEVEL THAT WE WERE --
AND WE ARE DOING AN ANALYSIS I A
I KNOW.
YOU'RE ALL AWARE OF OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN --
THE FIRST GOAL IN THE STRATEGIC
PLAN IS DOING THE ANALYSIS
NEEDED TO IDENTIFY WHERE WE ARE
SHORT --
RESOURCES AND WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE THROUGH THAT INCLUDES AIR
TANKERS THAT INCLUDES A NEW AIR
TANKERS THE NEW HELICOPTERS.
FIRE ENGINES CREWS --
AND ALL OF THE LIKE --
WE BELIEVE THAT --
THAT WE NEED TO DO THIS AS A
STANDALONE IT WAS IT WAS PUT
INTO THE STRATEGIC PLAN THIS
YEAR -- FOR
CAL FIRE TO DO OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS I I APPRECIATE --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES --
CONCERNS THAT THAT --
THAT IF WE DID SOMETHING UNDER
THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION OF OF
APRIL --
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
THAT'S AND THAT'S NOT LONG
ENOUGH FOR US TO DO WHAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO DO FOR ALL OF
THIS WE CAN DO FIRE ENGINES UP
FRONT BUT IT'S A WHOLE SYSTEM AS
AS STATED BEFORE.
AND WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
MISSION OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT
IS THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
AND WHILE I A I I EXPECT THAT --
YES SHOULD BE IN THIS IS COOL
GOVERNMENT ALI DIFFERENT MISH
[inaudible]
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE COMING
ARE VERY MUCH A PART OF THE
SYSTEM BUT THEY ARE NOT THE CAL
FIRE S. ARE A SYSTEM THAT THAT --
WE NEED TO ASSESS UNDER MY
STRATEGIC PLAN ELEMENT.
SEE ONE THIRTIES.
WHEN YOU DO THE ANALYSIS CAN YOU?
HELP ME OUT MAYBE EVERYBODY ON
THE THE WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU
GET IF THAT MONEY WERE SIMPLY
PUT INTO PREVENTION I DON'T
WANNA I I SEE THEN THE ITEM IS
BEFORE US BUT IF WE TOOK FORTY
MILLION WHICH IS.
BEFORE US AND WE HAD THAT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE THIS NEW
STAFF AND WE DIDN'T BY THE THE
EQUIPMENT.
AND WE KEPT AT THESE LOW LEVELS
BUT WE PUT IN MORE STAFF TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY AND
THEY WERE TASKED WITH THE
PREVENTION.
IS PREVENTION ON THE FORESTRY
SIDE OF THE FORESTRY AND FIRE.
PROTECTION WHAT TYPE OF OUTCOMES
WITH THAT HAVE --
FOR THE REDUCTION OF THE FUEL
AND THE PRESCRIBED DOSE
PRESCRIBED BURNS IN THE INTO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WITH THIS IS THAT
THIS IS AT THE SEVERAL DECADES
OUR MONSTER THAT WE'VE CREATED
HERE WITH THAT WITH DOING OUR
SUPPRESSION WORK SO SO I'M NOT
EXPECTING AN ANSWER NOW BUT WHEN
YOU DO THE ANALYSIS.
BECAUSE WE NEED YOU KNOW WE WE
HAVE TO MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES
HERE AND WE HAVE YOUR PROPOSAL
WE HAVE.
OTHERS PROPOSAL WE HAVE
ALTERNATIVES ON AB PRESCRIBER IN
SOME PREVENTION PURPLE WHEN YOU
DO THE ANALYSIS OF WE KNOW WHAT
WEEK.
WE GET IT'S IT'S HELPFUL. FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE LAKE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND AND
THAT WILL BE A PART OF IT AND I
WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU IS.
THE BEAUTY OF OF INVESTING IN
CAL FIRE IS WHEN YOU PUT A FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESOURCE INTO CAL
FIRES --
TOOL BOX IT'S ALSO A FIRE
PREVENTION TOOL --
IT DOES INSPECTIONS IT DOES --
PRESCRIBED BURNING AND FUELS
REDUCTION PROJECT WORK IT DOES
EDUCATION IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT IS OUR MISSION AND THAT'S
WHY.
THESE FIRE SUPPRESSION RESOURCES
ARE HARD --
THEY HAVE DUAL PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HOW.
BOB DOLE THE PIGGY BACK I GUESS
THOUGH ON ON YOUR TO YOUR
QUESTION --
I GUESS MY MY MY CONCERN IS THAT
IT SHOULDN'T BE EITHER OR RIGHT
NOW.
AND THAT WERE UNDER SIZING THIS
ENTIRE --
PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET AND I
KNOW THERE ARE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OF OF DOING LESS.
THEY HAVE REAL HUMAN IMPACT --
COMES TO THE THE WELL BEING OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN WITHIN YOUR
RANKS WHICH I THINK WE ALL
STRUGGLE WITH.
THIS JARRING STATISTICS ABOUT.
IN A SUICIDE RATES OUTPACING
MINA DUTY DEATH RIGHT NOW ON THE
FRONT LINES --
SOBERING --
SO MY I ACTUALLY APPRECIATED.
THE LA OWES.
COMMENDATION WHICH WE TALKED
ABOUT A BROADER BUDGET HEARING
ABOUT.
CONDUCTING AN ASSESSMENT TO IT --
INFORM FUTURE BUDGET DECISION.
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THAT'S A
CRITICISM I THINK THAT'S A
THAT'S A CALL FOR MORE
CREATIVITY IN A LITTLE BIT
BIGGER THINKING HERE ABOUT.
WHERE DO WE END UP?
YOU KNOW WE GO YEAR TO YEAR ON
WITHIN G. G. R. F. AND HAVE TO
SORT OF FIGHT WITHIN THIS POT
THAT.
I DON'T THINK SHOULD BE THIS
THIS SMALL AND I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE ARBITRARY I THINK WE
SHOULD ASSESS.
THE ACTUAL SCOPE OF THE NEED IT
MAY INCLUDE A C. ONE THIRTY AND
IT MAY INCLUDE BEEFED UP MENTAL
HEALTH AND IT MAY INCLUDE MORE
ENGINES IT IS.
I ACTUALLY THINK MORE IS JUST
GOING TO BE THE ANSWER SO --
BUT WE HAVE TO KNOW NEED SO I I
WOULD I I APPRECIATE THAT POINT
I HOPE I HOPE WE DO GET THERE
WERE.
WHILE YOU'RE RUNNING AROUND.
REALLY TRY TO EXPEDITE FUEL
MANAGEMENT DOING YOUR JOB
THINKING AHEAD AND TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR THIS TRUCK OF THE BUDGET I
SEE NO REASON WHY IT SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME STANDING AS ARE OTHER
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED ITEMS
WITHIN THE G. G. R. F..
OR WE'RE LOOKING AT TRANSIT
INVESTMENTS --
THIS IS ALSO A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT AND PEOPLE ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO AND THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO KEEP A SAY SO
THAT'S THE FIRST POINT I MAKE --
AT A HIGH LEVEL.
CERTAINLY SECOND THE COMMENTS IN
MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH
COAST IN.
AND I THINK YOU'RE HEARING AT
THE HUNGER.
FOR YET JUST NOT NOT UNDER
SIZING WHAT THIS IS --
I I DID WANT TO DRILL DOWN TO
SPECIFIC ITEMS THOUGH --
IN ADDITION SHE WHICH I HOPE
OKAY I DON'T YOU HAVE A SHOT AT
GETTING BACK TO US WITH
SOMETHING THIS CYCLE I MEAN.
THOUGHTS ON THAT SORT OF LONG
TERM FOR MOVE ON I KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'VE GOT YOUR YOU KNOW YOU YOU
DON'T FORTY FIVE AIRPORTS STRIKE
TEAMS CETERA BUT DO YOU HAVE
TIME TO GO THINK AHEAD A LITTLE
BIT BEFORE WE GET THROUGH THIS
BUDGET CYCLE.
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR THE A
RECOGNITION OF OF MANY THINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN ASKED
TO DO --
DURING A CYCLE THAT THAT HAVE
HAVE -- KIND
OF TAKEN A LOT OF OUR ATTENTION --
WE WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THIS BUT BUT WHAT I WANT TO COME
BACK TO IS --
MY STRATEGIC PLAN WAS DEVELOPED
OVER A YEAR OF WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE ARE --
OUR CONTRACT COUNTIES AND AND
AND THEN MY FIRE CHIEFS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED A COURSE
THAT WE WANT TO TAKE AND WE WERE
VERY METHODICAL COURSE --
TOWARD DOING AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT IT TAKES FOR CAL FIRE IN
THE CONTRACT COUNTIES. TO TO
RESPOND AS OUR MISSION REQUIRES
US.
TO IN THE S. R. A AND I REALLY
REALLY DON'T WANT TO CUT THAT
SHORT AND I DON'T WANT TO COME
BACK TO YOU AND SAY YEAH I COULD
USE THIRTY MORE ENGINES WHEN.
IT MIGHT BE A NUMBER MUCH MUCH
YOUR STAND THAT WE NEED TO KIND
OF LOOK AT THIS INCREMENTALLY
AND WHAT WE CAN BITE OFF AND AND
AND ALL THOSE THINGS.
I THINK THE THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHY I'VE KIND OF BROUGHT TO YOU
MY PRIORITIES OF THE HUMAN
FACTOR FIRST AND I THINK BY
ADDING THESE INDIVIDUALS --
WE'RE WE'RE WORKING IN THAT
DIRECTION AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CONTINUE WORKING IN THAT
DIRECTION --
BUT ALL OF THE EVERY PIECE THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS A
COMPREHENSIVE --
PIECE OF THE ANSWER AND I KNOW I
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER PRESENTED
IN FRONT OF YOU HERE TODAY.
TIMING ON THAT STRATEGIC PLAN I
KNOW YOU DID YOUR INITIAL DRAFT
IN JANUARY YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
ANOTHER ROUND TO THAT.
SO THE THE THE THE STRATEGIC
PLANS OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
CAL FIRE --
IS NEW THIS JANUARY --
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT'S IT
HOUSE US ON TRACK THROUGH
200-020-0020 THREE TO TAKE ON
THE FOR GOALS OF THAT ONE IS THE
COR COTTON CORE CAPABILITIES
ANALYSIS THAT I JUST TALKED
ABOUT THAT'S THAT'S OUR
OPERATIONAL KATE CAPABILITIES.
WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE KIND
OF BACK YOU KNOW BACKROOM KIND
OF ASSESSMENT --
NUMBER THREE WHICH I'VE TOLD YOU
IS MY MOST IN WELLNESS PEACE
[inaudible]
A FORCED DEVELOPMENT AND
MAINTAINING A A A WORK FORCE --
INTO THE FUTURE THOSE THOSE ARE
THE FOUR THAT THAT'S ALL THAT'S
ALL I'M I'M FOCUSED ON AS FAR AS
THAT STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND THE NUMBER ONE IS THIS
ANALYSIS AND I I DON'T WANT TO
CUT IT SHORT.
I REALLY WANT TO DO IT RIGHT I
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE RIGHT
ANSWERS I DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE THE OFF THE CUFF ANSWERS AND
I KNOW THAT THAT --
WE ARE GOING TO A PLACE THAT IS
IS MUCH MORE DEVASTATING AT
POTENTIALLY AND AND SCARY THAN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EVER WOULD HAVE
IMAGINED.
AND SO I I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
RIGHT ANSWER.
SO TIMING WISE THOUGH --
IS THERE --
FROM THE MAIN OUTLINE OF THE
BUDGET CYCLE BUT IT JUST
PROCEDURALLY YOU'RE GONNA GET
YOUR SECOND DRAFT I JUST WANNA
GET CLEAR YOU'RE GONNA GO.
YOU'RE GOING.
TO THERE'S THE STRATEGIC PLAN
PUBLISHED YOU GONNA DO AN UP
THIS IS A BRAND NEW CITIES YOU
PLAN IT IS IT ON THE STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT WE DEVELOP INTO THE
LAST YEAR AND RIGHT GOES TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE THAT IS
OUR PLAN GONNA TRY TO STICK
WITHIN THAT.
FRAMEWORK ANSWER TO BUILD OFF
THAT OKAY UNDERSTOOD STARTED BE
LABOR THAT POINT JUST TRYING TO
GET PROCEDURALLY TIGHT HERE SO --
OTHER OTHER --
NOT SMALL ITEMS THERE THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY BIG BUT I WOULD LOVE
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT.
HOW YOUR THE WELLNESS PILOT?
AND THE WORKERS COMP --
INTERRELATE --
THEY REQUIRE SAYS.
BEST THING WE DO IS ACTUALLY I
CAPACITY COULDN'T AGREE MORE
RIGHT LESS STRESS OVERSTRETCHED.
OF FIREFIGHTERS ONLINE IT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO HEALTHIER
HAPPIER FOLKS BUT IF I SEND IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SORT OF A THE
PUSH AND PULL OF SORT OF THAT
OVERALL WELLNESS PROGRAM AND
THEN WHEN THINGS REALLY DO GET
BAD HAD ACTUALLY UTILIZE IF YOU
HAVE AN INJURY.
AND INJURIES ARE JUST TO THE
BODY RIGHT THERE.
THAT.
YOU KNOW PSI'S IS ISRAEL --
IN A CROSS THAT THRESHOLD SO HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU SORT OF SIZE
THAT UP I SAW AN INCREASE
DEALING WITH A FEW WORKERS COMP
RELATED --
DISABILITY INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY
LEAVE -- HOW
DO YOU DO YOU DO YOU SEE UP TICK
COMING IN THE FUTURE IN TERMS OF?
CLAIMS BEING FILED ON THAT FRONT
I KNOW YOU TRY TO MITIGATE THAT
WITH THAT SORT OF BROADER
WELLNESS BUT CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT.
HI.
I DO SEE AN UPTICK IN WHAT I
DON'T HAVE STATISTICS SHOW THAT --
BUT ANECDOTALLY I'M SEEING THAT
AND IS AS WELL AS I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO
REDUCE THAT.
IN THE FUTURE IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY --
BUT I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE -- TO
SAVE PEOPLE.
KEEP THEM OUT OF THAT WORKERS
COMP.
A SITUATION KEEP THEM --
AS PRODUCTIVE --
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS WHICH WE
ALL NEED --
AND SO OF BAD THAT'S KIND OF
THAT THAT'S WHERE I AM AYE AYE
AYE IT THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY
DIRECTLY RELATED TO A IT'S
ACTUALLY IT'S NOT DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE OTHER ITEM IN
HERE ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
INDUSTRIAL --
YEAH FORGET THAT THE NAME OF THE
FUN BUT THAT THERE THERE'S A
COMEDY ODD.
THE THE IDEA OF THE ENHANCE
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY LEAVE US
AND IT'S OKAY SO WE'LL GET THEIR
FINAL QUESTION ON THIS AND AND
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU
THERE BECAUSE WE AGREE WITH
GETTING RID OF THAT STIGMA.
WE THINK THE WHERE WE'RE GONNA
BE ADVANCE ON A POLICY LEVEL
THIS YEAR A LOOK AT SORT OF THE
PRESUMPTIONS UNDERLYING PTS I
RELATED INJURIES AND WHETHER YOU
SHOULD JUST.
IF SOMEONE'S GONNA.
THAT TO TO SORT OF AT THE PERSON
REPORTING IS SUPPOSED TO SECOND
GUESSING --
THE FRONTLINE PERSON WHO SAYS I
GOT A PROBLEM IF THEY'RE GONNA
COME REPORT WE WANT TO SAY WE
BELIEVE YOU --
AS A MATTER OF COURSE OUT.
BUT LAST PIECE HERE ARE FIRE
DETECTION CAMPERS --
HERE THERE'S A SHORTAGE.
THIS IS I I DON'T KNOW ROOM OR
OR OR NOT BUT THERE'S THE THE
NIGHT AT THROUGH THE MEANWHILE
THAT WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
THE UTILITIES FILE WITH YOU SEE.
BY BEING REQUESTED IN THIS CYCLE.
JUST ANECDOTALLY I'VE HEARD
THEY'RE SORT OF A SUPPLY --
IMPEDIMENT RIGHT NOW.
IT IS IN WANTS TO GET UP 290%
COVERAGE BUT I CAN'T.
THIS YEAR THEY'RE ONLY PUT IN
SIXTY THREE CAMERAS IN PLACE HOW
MUCH COVERAGE DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE IN YOUR AREA
AND HOW DOES THAT RELATE TO THE
RATE PAYER --
FUNDED WILDFIRE AT FIRE CAMERAS
THAT ARE GOING ON WITHIN UTILITY
JURISDICTION ARE YOU TRYING TO
COVER GROUND THAT THEY'RENOT ON
ARE YOU ON THE SAME POLES AND
WIRES AT THEIR OWN JUST CAN YOU.
GOOD POINT GOOD POINT --
AND WE ARE WE'RE NOT GONNA PUT
HIM TO CLOSE TOGETHER --
WILL IDENTIFY THE AREAS WHERE WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE CAMERAS
THAT WE NEED CAMERAS --
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
CAMERAS LE PLUS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY --
UTILIZING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
MOST OF THOSE ARE IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE AND
THEN IN THE TAHOE BASIN.
SO THIS WOULD EXPAND THE
CAPABILITY WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR
THOSE HOLES --
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO PUT THEM
ON OUR OUR CURRENT LOOKOUT
LOCATIONS WHERE --
WE HAVE SOMETIMES VOLUNTEER
STAFF SOMETIMES NO STAFF BUT IF
WE HAVE A A CAMERA ON A LOOK OUT
THAT'S BEEN THERE.
FOR YOU KNOW EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED
YEARS -- WE
FEEL THAT THAT'S STILL A GOOD
PLACE A GOOD HIGH POINT TO BE
ABLE TO TO LOOK OUT ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE AND AND MAKE --
SOME ASSESSMENT OF THE SMOKE
REALLY THESE CAMERAS WHILE
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT DETECTION
TOOLS A AS AS OF KIND OF WE'VE.
LEARNED THROUGH READ THROUGH USE
OF THEM THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD SO
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL BE USING
THE MOUSE.
AND TO NOTHING YOU'RE HEARING
ABOUT SHORTAGE I IKEEP HEARING
THAT THERE'S NON ON IF ACTION ON
THE FIREFLY YES BY SIDE.
I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT BUT I'LL
LOOK INTO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE AN ISSUE FOR THANK YOU.
ANOTHER QUESTION BY SEN REQUIRE
CAN I ASK YOU BEFORE WE GET TO
THE TANK AIR TANKER ON THE
CAMERA --
DETECTION WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A LOTS OF SENSORS THAT ARE OUT
THERE WE HAVE SENSORS FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE WE HAVE SENSORS
FOR AIR QUALITY WE HAVE WE HAVE
WEATHER STATIONS WE HAVE ALL
THESE.
SENSE IS THAT ARE OUT THERE AND
CAMERAS THAT --
PRE EXISTING AND IT MAY BE A
SOFTWARE.
A CHALLENGE OR OPPORTUNITY THERE
AT THAT ALL THESE DIFFERENT
DEVICES THAT ARE OUT THERE
THINKING COMMUNICATE BECAUSE GET
TO SPLIT SENATOR STERN WAS
ALLUDING TO IS THAT IF WE
MAXIMIZE WHAT'S ALREADY THERE IT
MAY NOT BE THE BEST.
LOCATION FOR THE VIEW THE FIRE.
CAN ALLEN WHATEVER WHATEVER BUT
IT'S A GOOD ONE THAT MADE NEED
TO BE AUGMENTED AS WE GO WHEN
THEY'RE IN AS WE LOOK AT OUR
PRECIOUS RESOURCES AS WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE MATTER SOWHEN WE
COME BACK.
IT WOULD BE I KNOW THAT WE'VE
TALK WITH OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE IN THE AIR
QUALITY AND THE WEATHER PEOPLE
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY CAN USE THE
SAME.
AREAS JUST A SOFTWARE
AUGMENTATION THAT COULD GIVE YOU
A SMOKE DETECTION FOR INSTANCE
SENATOR --
MCGUIRE YOU HAVE AN AIR TANKER
QUESTION.
SENATOR MAKE SURE I'M ON THE
SAME PAGE.
WITH.
YOU CHIEF AND OBVIOUSLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR YOUR FIRST
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
MILLION [inaudible]
THIS.
THANKS. FOR IT FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY ODD TO BE ABLE TO THE
MOVE ON THE C. ONE THIRTY
PROGRAM IT'S IT'S THIRTEEN
MILLION.
IS WHAT'S BEING OUT YES AND
THAT'S A COMBINATION OF SORT OF
RAMPING UP STAFF AND THEN SOME
I'M SORT OF BEGINNING SOME
CAPITAL YET CAPACITY BUILDING
EXACTLY GETTING FACILITIES
ONLINE TO BE ABLE.
TO I MOVED TO SEE WHEN THIRTIES
AS SOON AS THEY BECOME UP AS
SOON AS THEY'RE DELIVERED --
TO INSTALLATIONS ARE DIFFERENCE
ARE INSTALLED AND AND SO WE WANT
TO HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
[inaudible]
THEN JUST.
LOOKING AT ON GOING TO ONGOING
WILL BE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
MILLION.
THAT'S CORRECT IN IS THAT.
OPERATION MAINTENANCE IS THAT
TAKING ACCOUNT ADDITIONAL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND NEEDING
TO BE A BILL THAT NEEDS TO CAN
YOU JUST WALK US THROUGH THAT --
SO BROADLY SPEAKING THERE'S A
COUPLE OF COMPONENTS WITH IT NOT
FIFTY MILLION SO THERE'S AND
THAT SORT OF THE COSTS OF OF
OPERATING THE ACTUAL PLANES
THEMSELVES AND THAT COMES DOWN
TO COSTS FOR PILOTS.
I'M AND AGAIN I DON'T WANT IT AS
THREE PILOTS --
AND AND THERE'S ALSO SORT OF
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AND NOT COMES
DOWN TO BOTH PARTS FOR THE
AIRCRAFT WHICH WILL BE GREATLY
INCREASED BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
ULTIMATELY A LARGER AND LARGER
PLATFORM I'M DOWN IN THE CURRENT
S. TWO T. AIR TANKERS THAT WE
HAVE THAT THEY HAVE AND THAT
THEY'RE SORT OF OPERATING --
AND THEN THEY'RE SORT OF THE
GROUND CREW STAFFING THAT'S
RELATED TO THAT WHICH I'M SORT
OF IS THE FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND LOADING THE RETIRED AND
AND SO THAT THAT SORT OF I THINK
BROADLY COVERS AND AND AND THIS
IS A NEW PROGRAM SO WE NEED TO
BUILD.
CAPACITY WITHIN THE PROGRAM IN
NONE OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IT --
DOLLARS IN THE CREWS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED AND THIS IS IN
THE WORLD DEAL WITH IN A BIT BUT
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO.
WITH ANY --
PREPARING HIS HE WENT THIRTIES
THAT THIRTEEN MILLION IS
STRICTLY FOR THOSE NEW AIRPLANES.
YES IT IS YEAH I'VE I'M JUST CAN
I JUST WANNA CLEAR FISERV WHAT
WHAT THE WAY I FORGET WHICH
WHICH I DO MAYES --
PROPOSING THIS FACILITIES ARE
PARA MAINTENANCE --
I WOULD SAY THAT THE PROBABLY
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS
AT AT TELL FARES --
TECH PIECES MORE BROADLY ARE
SORT OF IN TERMS OF THEIR
FACILITIES EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF
WHERE THOSE DOLLARS TO BE
DEDICATED.
RELATED TO THAT THIS THIS IS
SPECIFIC TO THE C. ONE THIRTIES
THIS REQUEST --
WE WERE NOT RAPPING AND OTHER --
SPECIAL REPAIRS THAT WE MIGHT
NEED -- AND
BUT THERE ARE --
MODIFICATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE.
RELATED --
TO PILOTS QUARTERS NEEDED FOR
HAVING THREE INDIVIDUALS A CREW
OF THREE IT'S ONE PILOT AND AND
THEN AND THEN ALSO --
SOME OF THE RAMP SPACE AND
THINGS NEED TO BE EXPANDED
BECAUSE IT'S A MUCH BIGGER
AIRCRAFT AND AND JUST
MANEUVERING IT AROUND --
REQUIRES MORE SPACE AND SO
THERE'S THOSE KIND OF COSTS FOR
UTILIZING THIS TYPE OF AIR
TANKER.
IN THE FUTURE OF THIS INDEED
HERE IN THIRTY SECONDS AND QUICK
CLOSING COMMENT ON NAY IN
GENERAL IS THAT LOOK.
I THINK MY BOTTOM LINE IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S UP TO
LEGISLATURE NOW TO BE A C. FOR
GOING TO BE ABLE.
TO ADD TO WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED
BY --
DEPARTMENT FINANCING THE
GOVERNOR.
AND I DO NOT THINK WE NEED A
STEP.
YOU BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT WE
ARE SHORTER PERSONNEL IN SHORT
ON ENGINES.
I THINK WITH THAT SAID YOU SHOW
US IS.
HOW SHORT WE ARE?
SO -- AND I
CANNOT IMAGINE THAT A STUDIES
GONNA COME BACK SAYING THAT WE
ARE -- JUST
TWENTY THREE SHORT.
I'M AS WE HAVE BEEN ESSENTIALLY
STATUS QUO STAFFING FOR THE
GREATER PART OF FORTY YEARS AND
NOW WE'VE JUST STARTED RAMPING
UP.
THAT'S WHY  THINK THAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GO FURTHER ON TOP
OF AGAIN THIS IS NOT A CRITICISM
VERY GRATEFUL ON TOP OF THOSE.
THIRTEEN THAT ARE BEING ADVANCE
AND GAME SECURE THANK YOU FOR
THE CONVERSATION TODAY CHIEF
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M FINE
SPRING GREEN FOR YOUR WORK AS
WELL WE WILL HOLD THAT MATTER
OPEN.
WE WILL ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS LATER ON IN OUR HEARING
TODAY A MOVE NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE WHAT THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES THAT IN INFORMATION
SYSTEMS AS REQUIRED BY AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE YOU IDENTIFIED THE THE
ITEM -- CAL
FIRE IS REQUESTING THREE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND --
AND SEVEN POINT EIGHT POSITIONS --
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF EL --
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRES EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
PROVIDERS --
TO BE TO TRANSMIT PATIENT CARE
DATA -- TO A
THIRTY THREE LOCAL.
EMERGENCY SERVICES AGENCIES.
AND THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AT THE ALREADY --
IF THESE HAVE TO BE DONE THROUGH
AN ELECTRONIC --
PROGRAM THAT IS A NATIONAL
PROGRAM.
AND THE COLLECTION OF THIS DATA.
THROUGH THAT --
IN A WILL HELP CALIFORNIA NEW
ISSUE OF CALL --
QUALITY S. SINCE.
AND ALSO TO VALIDATE THE THE
CARE THAT WE'RE GIVING AS HIGH
QUALITY CARE [inaudible]
ELIANE [inaudible]
THE COMMON.
THE TEEN DANCE FINANCE.
MEMBERS.
RECOMMENDATIONS HOLD THIS MATTER
OPEN.
SENATOR MONEY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR JUST A QUICK QUESTION.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY NINE WAS PASSED
IN -- TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHY IS IT TAKEN SO LONG
TO GET. TO THIS POINT OF SEEKING
THE BUDGET SUPPORT.
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION AND THE
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF OF THE
ELEVEN AT NIGHT. ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE FOR US WE'VE WE'RE JUST
CATCHING UP ON SO --
SOME OF US SOME OF OUR AREAS FF
STARTED TO DO SOME OF THIS ON
THEIR OWN THROUGH THEIR THEIR
COUNTIES --
AND SO WE'RE MEETING THAT IN
THOSE AREAS CURRENTLY THIS IS
THIS IS A STATE WIDE.
CAL FIRE ALL PRO ALL OF OUR TIME --
EMERGENCY PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE.
TO ACCESS THE SYSTEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
GOOD MOLD FOR THAT MATTER --
OPEN WILL COME BACK FOR COMMENTS
LATER LET'S MOVE THE ISSUE
NUMBER TEN THIS IS THE WORKERS
COMP IN --
DISABILITY --
FOR MEMBERS ITEM --
TO DODGE BILLS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
OF SO.
THIS IS RELATED --
TO SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR
AND SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR AS REFERENCED --
CALPERS REQUESTING A FOUR FOUR
MILLION TWO HUNDRED OR FORTY
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND --
IN A YEAR.
OF FOR THE ESTIMATED INCREASE OF
WORKERS COMP AND OVERTIME COSTS
FOR BACK FILL.
OF INJURED WORKER FOR BEHIND
INJURED WORKERS --
FOR ENHANCED INDUSTRIAL
DISABILITY LEAVE --
THIS IS THE SAME AMOUNT THAT WE
REQUESTED --
IN IN --
LAST OR THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
AND THAT WAS RELATED TO THE THE
FIRST OF THE TWO BILLS MENTIONED --
THREE THIRTY FOUR WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASE BEYOND THAT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR BUT THERE WOULD BE A
MECHANISM --
IT IN ARE THERE IS A MECHANISM
BUILT INTO A REQUEST ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IF THAT AMOUNT IS NOT
ENOUGH -- WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH --
COLLECTION OF DATA FOR BASS LINE
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE --
IF THIS OR ANOTHER IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER --
TWO FUND THIS LONG TERM IT WILL
COME BACK WITH THAT.
AT A FUTURE DATE [inaudible]
ANYTHING.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS.
TO PROVE HIS BUDGET.
ANDERSON.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A QUESTION
TWO QUICK QUESTION TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE LAST THREAD SEAT YOU'RE
SAYING THIS IS --
THE SAME IS THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR SO IT'S SORT OF A THE GOOD.
AND MIRRORS THE LAST YEAR'S
FUNDING REQUEST.
HE YES EIGHT SO THE BILLS HAVE
ONLY BEEN INACTIVE FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME SO WE WE YOUR BUT
USING HEALTH FIRES ESTIMATE THAT
THEY PROVIDED --
AND NOT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
HOWEVER YOU KNOW OPPORTUNITY
WOULD BE TO COME NEXT YEAR AND
THEN ONCE WE HAVE THREE YEARS OF
DATA -- COME
FORWARD WITH A PROPOSAL
POTENTIALLY FOR ON GOING
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE DEMAND
FOR THE INCREASE AND SO THE
CONTINGENCY.
THE CHIEF IS TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S BILL BUT THAT WOULD BE
BUILT INTO THE THIS CURRENT
BUDGET CYCLE.
THERE'S THE FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND WHICH WERE
BUILDING INTO THE BUDGET AND
THEN THERE WOULD BE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WITHIN THE THE ITEMS
THAT ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS. FOR AN
AUGMENTATION OF UP TO THREE
POINT FIVE PER A THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION WHICH AGAIN WAS
BASED ON THE ESTIMATE PURSUANT
TO THE LEGISLATION THAT WAS JUST
ENACTED JANUARY ONE WHICH WAS.
SB.
ONE ONE FOUR FOUR THE DATA
UNDERTAKEN NOW DESERVE ASSESS.
POTENTIAL FUTURE NEED THAT'S
THAT'S ON GOING WITH AND CAL
FIRE RINGS THAT'S ARE INTERESTED
IN.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION WOULD LIKE TO OPEN
UP PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS JUST
ON THE ENHANCE INDUSTRIAL
DISABILITY LEAVE.
UP PORTION ON ISSUE NUMBER TEN
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THAT.
SEEN AND WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LIKE HOW SCHEME BY.
CHANCE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
STERN.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR ZERO
LET'S MOVE TO OUR FACILITIES
REPAIR AND MAINTENANCE AS SET
FORTH IN ISSUE NUMBER.
ELEVEN OKAY THANK YOU.
A CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING A NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND A TWENTY TWO
POINT THREE POSITIONS IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR --
FOR TO BUILD THE CAPACITY NEEDED
TO UNDERTAKE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS.
AND EFFECTIVELY.
AND EFFICIENTLY.
MAINTAIN OVER TWO THOUSAND
STRUCTURES ON A FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- WE
ARE.
THIS IS IT THIS IS KEY TO
REDUCING OUR BACKLOG OF OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T HAVE --
FACILITIES THAT THAT FALL IN
SUCH DISREPAIR THAT THAT THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO BE --
MAINTAINED AT SOME POINT.
THE THE STAFFING AND FUNDING.
REALLY WILL --
HELP US TO AVOID GREATER
ACCUMULATION OF THE DEFERRED
MAISCH MAINTENANCE AS I
MENTIONED --
AND HELP US --
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT I'LL GET TO ON THE
ON FUTURE [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
THAT'S IT.
HAVE A QUESTION OF WHEN IT
APPEAR INSENSITIVE HERE BUT BUT
ON SOME OF THE STRUCTURES THAT
YOU HAVE THIS IS FIRE FIGHTING.
APPARATUS EQUIPMENT.
WIRE THE STRUCTURES REQUIRED TO
BE EIGHTY A COMPLIANT OR ARE
THEY IN A WERE UP IN.
AN AREA WE HAVE A HELIPAD THAT.
WHAT WOULD BE THE ACCESS THAT
THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE TO THAT
FACILITY?
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION AND
THESE ARE PUBLIC FACILITIES AND
A A I CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERYBODY
BUT IN MY UPBRINGING I I
REMEMBER.
A TIME WHEN --
MY DAD WOULD TAKE ME TO THE FIRE
STATION AND ALLOW ME TO SEE AND
TALK TO THE FIREFIGHTERS AND GET
AROUND.
AND IT WAS A PUBLIC OPENS OPEN
SPACE.
AND SO SO WE DO HAVE TO PROVIDE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS --
FREELY THOSE SPACES AND WE DO
HAVE.
A SPECIAL NEEDS OF SOME OF OUR
EMPLOYEES WHO WHO --
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE AT THOSE
LOCATIONS FOR THEIR WORK --
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PERSPECTIVE AND OTHER THINGS AND
AND WE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE --
THEM ACCESS TO THOSE PLACES TO
FOR ALL TWO THOUSAND STRUCTURES.
I MEAN I I GET THE HOMETOWN FIRE
STATION AND I GET THAT
CALIFORNIA'S XIN RIGHT OFF THE
FREEWAY AND ON URBAN INTERFACE
AREA BUT THERE ARE. TWO THOUSAND
STRUCTURES THAT OUR WAREHOUSES
SOMEPLACE IN STORAGE FACILITIES
IN AND BUNKHOUSES THAT ARE THERE
FOR THE PEOPLE IS THAT
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
I COULD JUST ASK THE QUESTION
AGAIN I DON'T WANT.
TO APPEAR INSENSITIVE BUT I JUST.
IT SEEMS LIKE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND STRUCTURES SOME OF THEM.
ARE NOT.
PUBLIC AS WE WOULD SAY THERE'S
NO PEOPLE HAVE NO BUSINESS GOING
INTO THOSE LIKE THEY HAVE NO
BUSINESS GOING INTO CHP FACILITY.
I MEAN JUST JUST SAYING.
THANK YOU SIR CAN ORDER POP UP
IN HERE MY NAME'S MIKE DUGGAN
MISSILE ENGINEER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND AS FAR AS OUR
ACCESSIBILITY --
REQUIREMENTS GENERALLY SPEAKING
EVEN WAREHOUSES DO NEED
ACCESSIBILITY TO THEM --
THE SOME AREAS THAT ARE QUITE
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T NEED TO
PROVIDE THAT WOULD BE LOOK OUTS
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ELEVATORS
IN THEM --
BUT AIR FIRE STATIONS THE
GENERAL MAJORITY OF OUR
LOCATIONS ARE PUBLIC FACILITIES
OR COULD BE USED IN A MERCY AS A
PUBLIC FACILITY.
SO -- YEAH
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE EIGHTY
BATHROOMS SENSIBILITY INTO THE
FACILITY --
A IF WE HAVE SOME MAJOR
ELEVATION DIFFERENCES UP --
TO THE MAIN ENTRANCE OF THE
FACILITY SO THE PUBLIC CAN MAKE
ACCESS AND APPLY FOR PERMITS OR
EVEN SCHOOL CHILDREN INTO THE
APPARATUS BAY.
OF THOSE HAVE TO COMPLY AS WELL
[inaudible]
THE MIND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM.
SO THIS SIX NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR WERE LOOKING
AT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUT
SUGGESTS THAT THE PROJECTED
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
SO WHY ARE YOU ONLY SEEKING.
THAT PORTION OF IT IN MAY BE
RELATED TO THAT QUESTION.
IS THE STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON INCLUDING
INTERESTING HOW YOU DEAL WITH
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
OVER TIME.
DURING THE SCOPE OF THE
STRATEGIC PLAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR EN EL AND I'LL
I'LL TOUCH THE THE PREFERS PART
OF THAT ARE THE SECOND PART OF
THAT FIRST --
THE STRATEGIC PLAN WILL BE
LOOKING AT ALL ASPECTS OF OF THE
NEEDS FOR OPERATIONALLY --
MEETING OUR MISSION SO YOU THE
ANSWER TO THAT PART OF THE
QUESTION IS YOU YES --
TO THE STRATEGIC PLAN IN A
MINUTE.
YOU'RE BACK --
TO MIKE DUGGAN.
SO -- THE
IDENTIFIED HUNDRED FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND BACKLOGS
DEFERRED SO THESE ARE THINGS
THAT --
WE'RE KICKING DOWN THE ROAD.
BASICALLY THE CHECK ENGINE
LIGHTS ON AND WE'RE STILL ABLE --
TO BUT WE'RE BUDGETING IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS SELF --%
BY WORKING IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'VE IDENTIFIED I THINK
OUR CAPABILITIES --
WITH STAFF --
THAT ARE PERMANENT AND CURRENTLY --
WERE ALSO OPERATING WITH ARTISTS
AND AND WHEN THE TERM STAFF AND
THAT'S THE WAY WE HAVE BEEN FOR
OVER A DECADE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO TACKLE --
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS --
ANYWAY POSSIBLE WITH MANY
DIFFERENT TOOLS --
WHAT WE SEE AS FAR AS ON THE NON
PERMANENT STAFF --
DUE -- TO
AND FIRE SOMEPLACE --
WE WERE NOT ABLE --
TO ACTUALLY GET THESE PEOPLE AND
WE STILL HAVE THE NEED THE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FACILITIES
STATEWIDE --
COVER FIRE STATIONS AIR ATTACK
BASES AND WE'RE JUST COMMAND
CENTERS LOOK OUT AS FAR AS COM --
AND OUR PLACE FULL JUST ON THE
REPAIRS WERE ALSO GIVEN AT JUST
LIKE YOU'D MENTIONED --
AS FAR AS THE FAR WATCH CAMERAS
THOSE ARE INSTALLED IN OUR
FACILITIES.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT REALLY
REQUIRED THAT WE HAVE TO DO THEM
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DON'T INTERFERE WITH
COMMUNICATIONS DEVICES.
AS FAR AS RADIO FREQUENCY --
THAT THEY'RE MOUNTED PROPERLY
THAT THE DAIRY TIE INTO OUR
MERCY COMMAND CENTERS AND
BECAUSE ANOTHER PROBLEM --
EVEN DURING EMERGENCIES --
AND FIRES AND INCIDENTS IN
EARTHQUAKES --
WERE CALLED UPON TO GO GET OUR
STANDARD AGAIN AND THE CAMP FIRE --
WE WERE WITHOUT POWER AND WATER --
SO WE HAD TO PROVIDE THAT --
WE ALSO HOPE OUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHILE WE'RE THERE SO
IF WE'RE ABLE --
TO A COMPLETE OUR MISSION
GETTING OUR STATIONS BACK ONLINE --
WILL WILL GO HELP WITH THE
COUNTY AND CITY AS FAR AS
INSPECTIONS ANYWAY THAT WE CAN'T.
AS LONG.
A PART OF IT IS CAPACITY HOW
MUCH YOU CAN.
THE VOTE A MORNING FLA OUR
FINANCE HAS A COMMENT ON THIS.
SURE IS SO WHEN YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THERE'S REALLY TWO PIECES
THERE'S I'M DEPARTMENTS.
PUTTING IN ENOUGH ONGOING
MAINTENANCE FUNDING AND SO THEN
IT GETS DEFERRED AND THEN YOU
END UP WITH A BIG BACKLOG IN SO
THAT I THINK HUNDRED FORTY TWO
MILLION THAT NUMBER YOU
REFERENCE.
WOULD BE --
CAL FIRES BACKLOG IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS HAVE HAVE LARGE
BACKLOGS AS WELL THERE'S TWO
WAYS OF ADDRESSING THAT ONE IS
WHAT'S IN THIS PROPOSAL HERE
WHICH IS.
INCREASE YOUR ON GOING
MAINTENANCE --
AT FINDING IT SO THAT AND
GROWING YOUR BACKLOG ON THE
OTHER WAY TO ADDRESS IT WOULD BE
BY PUTTING IN A ONE TIME FINDS
TO TO TAKE IT DOWN THAT BACKLOG.
THERE'S A SEPARATE PROPOSAL AND
I WANT TO SAY IT WAS HER LAST
WEEK BUT I'M NOT ENTIRELY
POSITIVE OR MAYBE YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR IT LATER ANYWAYS IT'S NOT
ON TODAY.
AND FOR AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING FOR ALL THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
CAL FIRE WOULD GET SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THAT SO THAT'S
GOING TO CHIP AWAY AT THAT
BACKLOG THAT'S ACCUMULATED.
THIS PROPOSAL --
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
REALLY PREVENT THE BACKLOG FROM.
I AM IN NO CONTINUING TO GROW IN
THE FUTURE I WOULD HIGHLIGHT I'M
ON THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL THAT ISN'T ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY BUT WE DO HAVE
A RECOMMENDATION THERE --
TO ENSURE THAT DEPARTMENTS ARE
REPORTING BACK ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE SIZE OF THEIR
BACKLOG AS WELL AS HOW THEY'RE
SPENDING THESE OF THE OTHER ONE
TIME FUNDS WHICH IS A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL.
AND AND IT JUST THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION WILL BE IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO EVALUATE NOT ONLY
THAT PROPOSAL BUT THESE SORTS OF
PROPOSALS WHERE.
ARE THEY REALLY MEETING THE
GOALS AT OF STOPPING THE
INCREASE IN THE GROWTH OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND
WHICH WOULD BE SORT OF THE GOAL
OF THIS TYPE OF A PROPOSAL.
THIS SORT OF THING IS SOMETHING
THAT OUR OFFICE HAS RECOMMENDED
THAT DEPARTMENTS DUE TO INCREASE
THEIR ON GOING FUNDING FOR IT
FOR FACILITIES MAINTENANCE SO
THAT.
YOU DON'T END UP WITH A BACKLOG
WHICH ENDS UP BEING MUCH MORE
COSTLY AND CAN LEAD. TO TURN THE
SCENE -- NO
IT'S NO LONGER MAINTENANCE NOW
YOU HAVE TO DO MARX AND X.
UNDERSTANDING AS A LOT OF THIS
WORK IS AND YET NOT NOT THAT IT
WOULD NECESSARILY EXCLUDE EIGHTY
EIGHT WORK BUT A LOT OF IT WOULD
BE AND YOU KNOW EACH BACK
REPAIRS AND ROOF REPAIRS AND AND
JUST.
GENERAL CONDITION OF THE
FACILITIES.
AND AND THAT THAT WOULD GO
BEYOND THAT AND THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF THOUGHT ACCUMULATED WORK.
SURE I I ONLY WENT OUT IS IS
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY AT
EVEN TO ADDRESS THE IN ANY
GROWTH IN THE IN THE BACKLOG IN
THE FUTURE SO IT'S PUTTING IN
THAT ONGOING MAINTENANCE FUNDING
SO THAT TELL FIRES IN A POSITION
TO DEAL WITH SORT OF THIS.
BEFORE THEY BECOME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE [inaudible]
THUNDERSTORMS.
THANK YOU.
FOLLOWING UP ON IN ORDER FOR
FIND LOOK AT EXACTLY WHAT THE
PROJECTS WOULD BE HERE I I SAW
H. BACK BUT ALSO.
MAKE SOME ELECTRICAL WORK IN --
ON THE ENERGY SIDE OF YOUR
SYSTEMS I KNOW.
YOUR NOT A IMMUNE FROM AG THE
GREAT ISSUES WE'VE BEEN HAVING
IN WE LOSE POWER PEOPLE GET HURT --
I I'M WONDERING HOW YOU'RE
APPROACHING.
THAT ISSUE THE RESILIENCY OF
YOUR FACILITIES --
IT IN TERMS OF HOW WHAT KIND OF
PROJECTS WE COULD SEE GOING
FORWARD.
IF I MIGHT ADD --
NEAR THE ABILITY.
FOR CAL FIRE AND FRANKLY ALL
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
THE STATE THAT HAVE CRUCIAL
PUBLIC SERVICE NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE OFF CREATED. FOR DAYS
ON END POTENTIALLY DURING THE
CYCLES.
THIS IS A MAJOR PRAYER.
WHAT'S THAT IS THAT MISSION A
PART OF HOW YOU ALL ARE GOING TO
BE UNDERTAKING THIS MAINTENANCE
SERVER UPGRADE EFFORT.
COMMENTS.
BOB I WOULD SAY WE TAKE.
TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SITUATION --
WHENEVER WE CAN AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE --
CHP WAS SURPLUS SING GENERATORS
THEY BOUGHT TWO FOR EACH OF
THEIR FACILITIES --
ONE WAS A SPARE --
THEY FOUND THAT THEY DIDN'T USE
THEM FOR FIVE OR SIX YEARS SO
THEY SURPLUS THEM SO WE WENT AND
AND GATHERS MANY AS WE COULD SO
WE CAN PUT HIM AT FIRE STATIONS
THE MAJORITY OF OUR FIRE
STATIONS ARE NOT.
GENERATOR SUPPORTED SO ALL THE
NEW CAPITAL PROJECTS ARE --
MOST OF OUR FACILITIES WERE BILL
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SIXTY SO --
WHAT HOW WE REMAIN OP NO POWER
TO THE SITE BUT THERE'S POWER TO
THE RADIOS AS FAR AS IN THE
ENGINES --
SO WE CAN STILL.
MAIN CONTACT ON THAT AND IN ANY
WAY POSSIBLE THEN WE'LL GO TO
TEMPORARILY SET UP A GENERATOR.
I AND WE DO THAT AT THE CAMPFIRE --
AS WELL AND WE ALSO IDENTIFIED
SUPPORT FUNDS --
FOR I BELIEVE TWO STATIONS TO
NOW HAVE GENERATORS UP IN
PARADISE --
I THE PARADISE AREA --
SO YES THAT WERE TRYING TO
NIBBLE AWAY AS BEST WE CAN
BECAUSE WE REALIZE WHAT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES.
I WOULD JUST ADD THOUGH MY
CONCERNS WE WENT THROUGH THIS
THIS GENERATOR GAME.
DOWN AND WE'LL SEE.
FEEL THE PAIN IT TOO YOU'VE GOT
TO STOCKPILE FUEL.
I'M WINNER WHEN WE GET PAST THIS
DIESEL GENERATOR CHASING THE
FUEL AND TRY TO GET THAN FUEL
PASSED FIRE LINES AND BLOCKAGES
WE WE WE LITERALLY HAD T HAVE.
ENTIRE FUEL CONVOYS TRY TO FEED
THEM THE GENERATOR BUT THE FIRES
GOING AND THEN THERE'S BLOCKADES
IN.
AND I WENT WHY AREN'T WE
REALIZING THE CLEAN ENERGY
POTENTIAL AT ALL THESE
FACILITIES IN TRYING TO GET
OURSELVES GRADE RESILIENT.
GOING TO BATTERY BACK UP LOOKING
AT MY GROUP GRADES YOU KNOW ON
SITE GENERATION THAT'S NOT GOING.
TO LIKE REQUIRE BUDGET DIESEL OR
PROPANE TO GET SHIPPED IN IS
THAT IS THAT SOME YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT --
DEFINITELY --
ACTUALLY DEPARTMENT WELL --
TRAINED AND THE WASTER --
THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT OUR REMOTE
LOCATIONS AS FAR AS CAMPS AND
AND I'D SAY TO A LESSER EXTENT
STATE FORCE.
FOR A DEVELOPING --
POWER OUT REMOTE AREAS TO TO
ASSIST US --
MOSTLY -- WE
HAVE ONE FIRE STATION TECHNICAL
SERVICES --
MY UNIT OUT OF READING --
PUT UP --
SOLAR AT AT THE FIRE STATION
JUST OUTSIDE READING.
WE'RE TRYING TO COMBAT THAT
BECAUSE WE DO REALIZE IT
SOMETIMES WERE WITHOUT POWER
RESOURCES WATER EVEN --
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
SO WE DO HAVE --
LARGE --
STORY FUEL --
THAT'S PRIMARILY FOR THE
APPARATUS BUT WE CAN ALSO USE
THAT FOR GENERATORS AND AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SOMETIMES WILL
NOT PERMIT THAT SO.
WE'VE LOOK AT PROPANE --
WE HAVE.
TO I'LL ACTUALLY HAVE TO FIRE
STATIONS --
OR ACTUALLY IT'S A COMBINATION
OF THREE AND THE THE CURRENT
BUDGET THAT ARE OFF GRID --
WILBUR SPRINGS HAMID ARE PERMITS
SPRINGS AND SKULL CREEK THAT ARE
COMBINATIONS.
WHICH THEY DO HAVE A SMALL
GENERATOR BUT ITS BATTERY BACKUP
INSULAR.
SO THE ONE THEY'RE JUST ASK IS
TO LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ALL AND
PARTNERING TO GET CREATIVE ABOUT
HOW TO MAKE THIS MONEY GO AS FAR
AS WE CAN.
BUT THERE IS IN A CREATIVE PPA
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE ABLE.
TO PULL PURCHASE CLEAN BACKUP
POWER EVEN MICRO GREENS FOR YOUR
SYSTEMS BUT ALSO YOU KNOW.
LOOKING FORWARD.
HOW HOW HOW VULNERABLE ARE IS
YOUR YSTEM GOING TO BE SO
GETTING A LITTLE BIT DATA BACK
ABOUT?
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE
BACK UP POWER IN PLACE AND WHERE
YOU DO AND HOW MUCH COVERAGE
WE'RE GONNA GET OUT OF IT.
I KNOW THEY'RE LIKE ENERGY
SERVICE CAUGHT --
BUT A CALM S. GOES ARE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF AGREEMENTS WE CAN SORT
OF FOR THE ENTIRE DEPARTMENT OR
THE BALL PURCHASED THIS STUFF TO
ESCO --
CONTRACTS TO THE DEPARTMENT
JOURNAL SERVICES IN THE PROBLEM
THAT WE'VE HAD IS --
EVEN ON OUR LARGEST FACILITIES --
THERE'S NOT --
I I SEE THE BIGGEST BANG FOR
YOUR BUCK SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A OF PRISON PERHAPS YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT'S LIKE ALMOST A
COMMUNITY YEARS SUPPLYING --
AID THE CONVERSION OF THAT IS IS --
BIG DOLLAR SAVINGS WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A FIRE STATION --
IT DOESN'T APPEAR.
TO GET THE INTEREST OF THE
DEPARTMENT SIR --
GENERAL SERVICES TO ALLOW US TO
EVEN BUNDLE OF FIRE STATIONS TO
DO THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
USUALLY SO REMOTE --
BASICALLY THE MAJORITY OF OUR
FIRE STATIONS ARE BASICALLY
RANCH STYLE HOUSES OUT IN THE
FAR REACHES OF THE STATE.
BURGER FRIES COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE I'D HAVE TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SPECIFIC
FACILITIES FRIEND AND HOW WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT POWER
[inaudible]
ANYTHING.
WE CAN DO HERE.
I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE AN H. ISSUE
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY.
IT'S IT'S BIG PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE AROUND THE STATE'S ARE
JUST CURIOUS YEAH I ENTER
SHARPER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE DEFINITELY SHARE YOUR
SAME INTEREST MORE LOOKING AT
THE OUR ENTIRE CAPITAL PORTFOLIO.
AND I THINK THE REAL ISSUE IS IS
BEING FOR THE BACK IS THIS THE
BEST PLACE TO EVEN PUT AN ESCROW
TYPE DOLLARS AND ALSO SOME OF
OUR OTHER AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
UTILITY COMPANIES AND OTHER
PARTIES THAT WILL COME IN AND
THEN.
THEY'LL PUT A BIG SOLAR FIELDS
AND THEN THEY GET TO A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE BACK WHATEVER WE
DON'T USE.
SO THESE PROJECTS ARE SMALL
ENOUGH THAT THE BANG FOR THE
BUCK REALLY ISN'T THERE SO IT'S
IN THE BETTER INTEREST OF THE
STATE JUST TO CASH FIND OUT OUR
OWN SOLAR PANELS AND NOT DO
THOSE TYPE OF PROGRAMS.
WHICH WE ARE DEFINITELY DOING
AND LOOKING AT THE WE LOOK IT'S
STRATEGIES IS THAT'S GO THE BEST
ROUTE IT MEANS THAT MAY BE AN
INAPPROPRIATE CONTRACTING
MECHANISM I'M SURE TO GET AT THE
UNDERLYING RESILIENCY AND SAY
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO SUCK
ABOUT MUCH --
THESE ARE THE GENERATORS AND TRY
TO STOCKPILE FUEL SITUACIóN
SAID THE THE THE PRODUCT ITSELF
SEEMS LIKE.
I DON'T REAL ISSUE YEAH YEAH AND
ME AGREE AND SOME OF THEIR MINOR
PROJECTS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
LOOKING I HAVE BEEN PUTTING
SOLAR PANELS ON FACILITIES IN
THE MORE WE CAN DO THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT THE CURRENT
WE SHARE THE SAME INTEREST ALL
LEAVE.
A JUST LEAVE YOU WITH.
BATTERIES IS LEAVE YOU WITH THAT
AND AND IN THE GENERATIONS ONE
PIECE BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES WERE
LOOKING AT A CRITICAL WATER
PUMPING STATIONS THIS IS AN
ISSUE AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE WANT TO BE SAFE.
SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT EVEN IF IT'S
ABOUT WORKING WITH UTILITIES
TIME IS THERE A LITTLE RESIDENT
RETICENT ON BEHIND THE METER --
GENERATION AND I CAN GET
COMPLICATED SIZING INPUT SOME OF
THE LEAD TO HELP YOUR WORK THANK
YOU FOR THE AND WHAT THAT WILL
MOVE TO FIREWORKS.
AND LOCAL THAT MATTER OPEN --
WE'RE GOING TO THE MANAGEMENT
AND DISPOSAL.
AFTER PRESENTATION HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
FIREWORKS MANAGEMENT DISPOSAL --
I'M I'M ACTUALLY ARE YOU GOOD
WITH THIS.
TAKING OVER ON THE SIDE.
THANK YOU --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CALLS FOR
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE MANAGEMENT AND DISPOSAL
OF ILLEGAL FIREWORKS.
THIS PROBLEM --
I'M SURE IN IN YOUR DISTRICTS
YOU YOU ARE AWARE OF THIS ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY IT SEEMS TO BE
INCREASING EVERY YEAR.
NOW WE HAVE THIS INFLUX OF
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS THAT COMES AND
FROM OUT OF STATE IT COMES IN U.
P. S..
BUT WE HAVE MANUFACTURING OF
FIREWORKS THAT IT'S OCCURRING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IT'S
OVERWHELMING THE RESOURCES OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE IN FACT
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT
EVEN IN FORCING ANYMORE.
IN PRIMARILY BECAUSE THERE
HASN'T BEEN A PLACE OR THERE
HASN'T BEEN CONSISTENT FUNDING
FOR THE DISPOSAL OF SEIZE
FIREWORKS.
SO THEY GO IN AND LOCAL SCHOOL
AND SEES THE FIREWORKS AND THEN --
TO COME AND PICK THEM UP AND
TAKE THEM TO A AN OUT OF STATE
LOCATION --
THROUGH A CONTRACT AND IS AN
ISSUE BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
FUNDING SO --
WE'VE TRIED MANY MANY ATTEMPTS A
MINI CREATED THE TEMPS --
AND HERE WE ARE.
REQUESTING GENERAL FUND.
LET ME THROW ANOTHER CREATIVE --
ATTEMPT WOULD BE AS A EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY WE WE
HAVE THIS MODELS THAT SAYS IF
YOU PRODUCE THE ITEMS YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROPOSAL.
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE WE HAVE SOME
YOU KNOW WE'RE CALIFORNIA IF
THERE ARE SOME.
LEGAL FIREWORKS ELSEWHERE IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
ILLEGAL HERE AND WE AND I USED
TO CHAIR.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY SO I'M.
FULLY AWARE OF MASTERS HAS HIS
WAYS BUT IF WE WERE ABLE TO
REQUIRE THE PRODUCERS IF WE HAD
A POLICY THAT WE HAD OF THE
PRODUCERS.
THIS IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
DISPOSE OF THIS LIKE WE WOULD WE
WOULD DO IN PLASTIC SIR CARPET
OR WHERE WHATEVER.
THAT IS A MODEL THAT WE HAVEN'T
TRIED THEM JUST.
THROWING IT OUT THERE BECAUSE WE
GO THROUGH THESE THINGS SAVE
CERTAINLY SPARK IDEAS SO RATHER
THAN.
PAYING THREE POINT SIX MILLION
TO DISPOSE OF THEM WE HAVE THE
PRODUCERS COMING GET THEIR STUFF
AND TAKE IT OUT OF THEY PAY TAKE
IT OUT THEY'VE GOT AN INCENTIVE.
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THEY CAN
RESELL THESE THINGS RIGHT.
I MEAN THESE ARE DID OR NOT
THEY'RE NOT DISPOSING OF PICKING
UP THE OTHER STUFF HAVE WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH THE STAFF REPORT
DIDN'T SEE THAT IDEA.
HAS THAT EVER BEEN DOES YES YEAH
YEAH WE YES WE'VE TRIED THAT SIR.
IN FACT THE LAST TWO BUDGET
CYCLES WE TRIED TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY AND LOCAL FIRE AND LOW
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ON A
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM.
AND WE COULD NEVER --
WE COULD NEVER GET IT OFF THE
GROUND SO TO SPEAK --
WHETHER IT WAS INDUSTRY THAT WAS
BALKING AT IT BECAUSE THEY SELL
SAFE AND SANE FIREWORKS IN THE
STATE AND THEY WERE GOING TO BE
ASKED TO SUBSIDIZE ALL OF THE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY THAT WAS
OCCURRING --
AND THEIR CONCERNS WERE THE
PRODUCTS THAT WERE BEING SEASON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'D BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO RESELL THEM.
IN ANOTHER LOCATION AND RECOUP
THEIR COST OR OR ABSORB SOME
LIABILITY BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO WE WORKED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR TWO YEARS TO BUDGET
CYCLES TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER A
MODEL AND WE JUST COULD NEVER
GET IT THROUGH.
THE LEGISLATURE AS I RECALL IT
ALSO EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN
ABOUT RE PURPOSING OF OF THE
FIREWORKS AND IN SOME OF OUR
MEETING SO --
WE WE HAVE WE HAVE MADE AN
ATTEMPT.
ALEJO BEFORE GET TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
WE WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS --
PROPOSAL I IT SEEMS REASONABLE
AND WE JUST KNOW THAT IT DOESN'T.
FOR CLOSE THE OPTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AT A FUTURE TIME IF
YOU DO COME UP WITH A DIFFERENT
FUNDING MECHANISM MORE OR WAY OF
HANDLING THIS SO YOU COULD
ALWAYS MAKE THAT CHANGE BUT THIS
WOULD AT LEAST ADDRESS THE I'M
EXISTING [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANKS I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
THE CHIEF I A I WAS READY TO
MOVE THAT LEGISLATION LAST YEAR
ACTUALLY I WOULD JUST.
URGE YOU TO NOT BE DETERRED BY
WHATEVER --
CONSIDER SMALL CONCERNS YOU
MIGHT HAVE HEARD THROUGH THE
PROCESS LAST YEAR.
I THINK WE CAN SOLVE THE WASTE
DISPOSAL ISSUE IN ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THREAT OF THE
HAZARDOUS NATURE TOXICS ISSUES I
THINK THAT SOLVABLE.
I'D.
THE SENSE I GOT FROM INDUSTRIES
THAT THEY REALIZE IT'S A BIG
PROBLEM AND IN FACT IT'S A YOU
KNOW THERE'S A BLACK MARKET.
THE TRAIN IS STATE RIGHT NOW
THAT'S HURTING PEOPLE AND THEIR
CRIME RINGS GOING ON AT A STATE
BACON MILLION DOLLARS SHIPPING
THAT AT A STATE.
AND THEN BLOWN UP IN OUR
BACKYARDS DURING FIRE SEASON I
MEAN --
DURING FIREWORKS AND FOURTH OF
JULY I MEAN PEOPLE GET HURT
PEOPLE GET KILLED SO --
I I I I PROBLEM.
BUT I STILL THINK THERE'S HOPE
FOR SOLVING THAT SO --
TO EXTEND YOU ARE STILL
INTERESTED AYE AYE I THINK IT'S
WORTH TAKING ANOTHER BITE AT IT
AND YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE CHAIR
YOU YOU BRING THAT UP JUST
BECAUSE IT'S A REDDING GOING
OUTSIDE OF THIS SORT OF UNIVERSE
IN POLAND ON GENERAL FUND.
THERE IS A WAY TO HAVE A SORT OF
SELF CONTAINED ECOSYSTEM I THINK
HERE THAT THAT GETS EVERYONE
WHAT THEY NEED SO.
ANYHOW I WOULD JUST ASK DON'T
GIVE UP HOPE IN IF WE CAN TAKE A
SHOT AT THIS THING AGAIN.
THANK YOU --
ON THE WORKING ON THIS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS.
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC OKAY GOOD
GOOD I WILL HOLD THAT MATTER
OPEN AND WILL ADDRESS IT WILL.
LATER LET'S GO TO PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS PROGRAM CONTINUATION
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING A TO MAKE
PERMANENT ITS PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS PROGRAM --
THAT'S BEEN --
WITH US --
FOR IT WAS ENACTED AFTER THE THE
BUDGET ACTIVE OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE REQUEST IS FOR FOURMILLION DOLLARS AND FOURTEEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS THAT WE
CURRENTLY.
HAVE FILLED --
TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM INTO THE
FUTURE --
THE THE PROGRAM IS --
CONTINUING.
TO MOVE THROUGH THE ELEMENTS
THAT IT WAS CHARGED WITH.
AND IS --
TRULY MOVING INTO THE TRAINING.
OF EMPLOYEES ON PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT --
AND PROVIDING A COMPREHENSIVE OF
OF SUPERVISORY AND MANAGEMENT
TRAINING.
GUIDELINES TO PROMOTE --
THE APPLICATION OF CONSISTENT
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT --
IS SO THAT WE ARE TREATING --
LIKE --
INFRACTIONS OF OUR POLICIES AND
RULES -- THE
SAME -- FROM
ONE END OF THE STATE TO THE
OTHER -- AND
TO MAINTAIN THAT CONSISTENCY AS
WE MOVE THROUGH ANY DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS THAT MIGHT FOLLOW
[inaudible]
COMMENT.
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT IN A WE'RE
WE HAVE TO BE VERY STINGY
HEARING GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL IN THE A. B..
THIRTY TWO OUR ARENA I KNOW THAT
WE PASSED SOME EXTENSIONS BUT
THAT BEGINS WITH THE OPTIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THERE'S A
VERY CLOSE NEXUS THAT HAS TO BE
SHOWN.
ON THE REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE
GASES FOR FUNDS TO TREAT MONEY
CENTER USE FROM THE FUND AND
THAT'S WELL THE TRAININGS FINE
AND THERE'S OTHER.
THERE'S OTHER JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
THAT ARE IN THERE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT OUR OUR DUTY HERE IS
TO AS WE SEE FROM THE AUCTION
PROCEEDS SO.
THIS SHE'S IT'S IT'S IN THERE
FOR AT A HUNDRED NOT VERY MUCH.
AND FINANCE MAY HAVE A COMMENT
ON THAT.
SURE SIT IN THE AMOUNT THAT'S
INCLUDED IS REFLECTIVE OF SORT
OF TWO THINGS ONE IS THAT THE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS PROGRAM
SUPPORTS THE FIRE PREVENTION
PERSONNEL THAT I CAL FIRE.
WITHIN SORT OF CAL FIRES RANKS
AND SO IT MAKES SENSE THAT AS A
PART OF SUPPORTING THAT STAFF
THERE WOULD BE A PORTION OF THAT
PROGRAM THAT THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
THE OVERALL FUNDING MODEL AND
THEN.
JUST TO THE NEXUS BECAUSE OF
WHAT WE MAY TRAIN PEOPLE TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES THE
CLEANING DOESN'T REDUCE THEM AT
I MEAN I KNOW PEOPLE WHEN THEY
GET THERE.
BUT WE'RE STINGY HERE AS FAR AS
SAYING ONCE THEIR TRAIN I GET
THAT THEIR THEIR PARTNER THERE.
HEY YOU KNOW STAFFING WILL
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES.
ALL I CAN SAY TO THAT IS IS THAT
THIS IS A PROGRAM WITHIN CAL
FIRE THAT SUPPORTS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAMS AND SO
FROM THAT SENSE.
AND THEN THE OTHER COMPONENT OF
THIS IS THE FACT THAT WE WE DO
HAVE AND SORT OF THE THE NATURE
OF THE BACK STILL OF THE SEA
RESPONSIBILITY AREA FIRE
PREVENTION FUND SAID THIS.
G. G. R. AFFECT NOW ARE YOU
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION BY NOW
FORMS A PART OF CAL FIRES BE
SLAIN BUDGET AND SAY THIS
AMOUNTS OR OR SORT OF STAY
RESOURCES THAT ARE PROPOSED HERE
CONSISTENT WITH CAL FIRE
SPACEPLANE FUNDING MODEL.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE BACK
FILLING IT WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED THROUGH THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA FIRE
PREVENTION FUNDS WITH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
YOU MAKE MY ARGUMENT FOR THE S.
R. A QUESTIONS ON THIS.
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS PROGRAM
WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN.
I'LL LET'S MOVE TO ITEM FOURTEEN
WHICH IS VERY VERY IS CAPITAL
OUTLAYS PROGRAMS CENTER MINING
DC THE ITEMS WERE WERE WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WERE ACTUALLY.
PROPOSING TO REMOVE THESE
OUTDATED OUR MOVE BEYOND THESE
UPDATED --
SELL THESE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT LEAD IN CHAIR --
SO THE REQUEST IS --
FOR FORTY JUST OVER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR FIFTEEN CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS INCLUDING ACQUISITION.
PRELIMINARY PLANS A WORKING
DRAWINGS --
CONSTRUCTION AND MINOR PRICE.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN IN CAL
FIRES FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE --
PLAN -- FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS IN SOME CASES --
SOME OF THEM --
OVER THE YEARS HAVE FALLEN OFF
OF THE PLAN --
EVEN AFTER HAVING BEEN TO GO
THROUGH THEIR PRELIMINARY
FINDING A FOUR I MEAN FOR
FUNDING FOR PRELIMINARY PLANS.
AND SOME OF THE STUDY. FOR THE
THOSE --
FACILITIES --
DUE TO THE GENERAL FUND --
REDUCTIONS DURING THE RECESSION --
THAT THAT WAS MOST RECENTLY --
MEAL AT TEN TWELVE YEARS AGO
BEHIND US NOW.
BUT WHAT I I WANT TO REFLECT IS
WHILE THEY ARE SHOWN AS NEW
FUNDING.
THEY ARE OLD TO THE PLAN.
MOST OF THESE PAST AND NOW
THEY'RE SHOWING UP AGAIN --
BEFORE YOU.
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S FACILITIES WERE
CONSTRUCTED PRE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY HAND THE
OPERATIONAL LIFE CYCLE OF OF OUR
FACILITIES IS IS ABOUT FIFTY
YEARS.
SO -- WE ARE
AT A POINT WHERE WE'RE REALLY
WORKING TO REPLACE --
WHAT WE CAN WHEN WE CAN --
THE OLDER FACILITIES.
ARE -- AN
ISSUE FOR US --
IN MANY CASES THEY DON'T FIT THE
APPARATUS THE FIRE ENGINES AND
EQUIPMENT THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
USING -- AND
THEN THEY ALSO WERE NOT BUILT.
TO A BUILDING CODES THAT WOULD
BE EXCEPT OF FURTHER --
THEY ARE NOT REFLECTIVE OF
TODAY'S MODERN WORKFORCE --
THEY ARE --
VERY MUCH AND IN MANY CASES JUST
OPENED BERWICK STYLE --
SLEEPING QUARTERS --
WITH SINGLE SEX BATHROOMS AND
AND THE SAME FOR THOSE SLEEPING
QUARTERS SO THIS WOULD ALLOW US
TO MOVE THESE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS --
IT FORWARD AND CORRECT SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS.
AND TO MOVE SOME OF THESE
OBSOLETE FACILITIES TO BECOME
STORAGE AYE WHEN I WAS GOING
THROUGH IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE
THESE.
PODS OF THIS OVER SIMPLIFICATION
OF FIVE BUILDINGS AND SOME FROM
OR STORED SOME FROM OUR BARRACKS
OVER OUR PARKING FACILITIES.
FOR THE VEHICLES --
CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME FLAVOR OF
WHAT ARE THE ONES THAT ARE JUST
HOST AND THEY JUST THEY'RE DONE
AND IN SOME OF THEM THAT THEY'RE
BEING.
ARRESTED PER ORDERS REPURPOSED
FOR MOVING FROM A FACILITY --
OF SLEEPING FACILITY OR AGAIN I
HAVE BROUGHT UP --
MIKE DUGGAN TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
I'D SAY WE DEFINITELY LOOK TO
REPURPOSE ANYTHING THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE CAPITAL OUTLAY CYCLE --
IS AT A MINIMUM --
FIVE YEARS.
TYPICALLY --
SO IF WE CAN REALIZE A STRUCTURE
FOR STORAGE --
WE DEFINITELY WILL HAVE YOU
CHANGED THE OCCUPANCY OF THE
BUILDING THEN YOU HAVE TO BRING
IT UP TO CURRENT CODE.
AND IN SOME CASES THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO QUICKLY SWAP
SOMETHING OUT BECAUSE IT WOULD
POSSIBLY REQUIRE RE DOING ALL
THE ELECTRICAL OR BRINGING IN.
FIRE SPRINKLERS --
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE --
ANY WATER TANKS ARE FIRE WATER
FLOW.
HOW ABOUT THE CCC BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BERRICS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE APPROPRIATED FOR
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS BUT
FIRST?
HIGH SCHOOL --
YOUNG ADULTS THAT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE ON AN INTERIM BASIS
AND I'M THINKING ABOUT SOME.
FACILITY THAT THEY'RE LOOKING TO
INCREASE. TWELVE INVENTOR --
THE WEEK CONFERRED THE
CONSERVATION CAMP TO A FREE
PERSON FACILITY WHICH CAUSED
MANY PROBLEMS IN THE SENSE OF
THE THE I GUESS THE THEORY.
BEHIND THE TWO IS DIFFERENT IN
OTHER WORDS WHEN YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO CONFINE PEOPLE AND IN THE
FREE PERSON SAYS YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO THEY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT THROUGH
WINDOWS.
THROUGH DOORS --
CORRIDORS WE HAD THAT WE WE'VE
LOOKED --
MANY WAYS TO UTILIZE WHATEVER WE
CAN AND IN IN SOME CASES LOOKED
OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO UTILIZE
THEIR FACILITIES AND AND
REPURPOSE THOSE --
THE SEAS I WOULD SAY ARE JUST AS
CAN POSSIBLY UTILIZE THINGS I
KNOW WHEN --
THE CAMERI --
FACILITY WHICH IS RIGHT NEXT
DOOR TO THE VENTURA CAMP --
WERE WORKING WITH THEM IN ORDER
TO ACCOMMODATE US AND REQUIRE
MEMBERS.
MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT COMES
WITH THE HAVE FREE HEFTY PRICE
TAG THERE.
CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN US ON I WAS
SURPRISED TO TO LEARN HOW MANY
OF THE FACILITIES ARE RENTED.
AND THAT THERE'S THAT THE
RELEASE THAT THE LEASES ARE
COMING UP AND THEY'RE OBSOLETE
AND NOW THE LANDLORD WHEN SICK.
CHECK OUT THE BILL THE CHUCKY
CHEESE WHATEVER'S WHATEVER'S
GOING ON WHAT.
WHAT IS THE WHAT'S THE GAME PLAN
GOING FORWARD --
WE ACQUIRING SITES ARE WE
LEASING OTHER SITES AND BUILDING
UP PEOPLE PEOPLES --
OF REMOTE PROPERTIES.
I WOULD SAY ON A THE LARGEST.
SCALE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
WE REALIZE THE TIME AND FISCAL
IMPACT ON THE STATE TO PRODUCE
THESE FACILITIES.
AND PROVIDING THEM ON A SHORT
TERM LEASE OF MAYBE TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS --
WHERE ONCE WE COME TO THE TABLE
AGAIN --
THEY HAVE US OVER A BARREL --
SO WE ARE LOOKING TO ACQUIRE
WHAT WE CAN IN PLACES AND
THERE'S SOME FACILITIES AND SOME
OF THIS CAPITAL PLAN THAT WE
HAVE TO LEASE THE FACILITY.
ARE WE LEAST LEAST THE GROUND
LIKE AT THE AIRPORTS WE CAN'T ON
THE PHYSICAL GROUND --
BUT THOSE ARE LONG TERM LEASES
PREFERABLY --
THE OTHER LEASES THAT WE DO HAVE
OR WITH OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND WE TRY TO GET THE
LONGEST TERM POSSIBLE. FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE US FOREST
SERVICE AND CONSERVATION CAMPS
AND OTHER FIRE STATIONS.
AN MY FINAL QUESTION WHAT IS A
FIVE AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR
KITCHEN AND TO HIM A COUNTY LOOK
LIKE.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE EACH EACH
E. IN CAMP REPLACEMENT KITCHEN I
SAID. TO HIM A COUNTY FIVE AND A
HALF MILLION BUCKS FOR KITCHEN.
WELL --
ACTUALLY HE WE TRIED --
VERY CREATIVE METHOD
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
AND IN IN THAT PROJECT WE HAD A
FIRE THAT TOTALED THE KITCHEN AT
THE CAMP.
AND IT JUST SO HAPPENS THAT WE
KNEW AT THE FACILITY IN
SUSANVILLE CDC ARE HAD JUST
PRODUCED THE PLANS. FOR A A
KITCHEN THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT ARE NEED WOULD BE --
WE HAD TO MODIFY IT A LITTLE BIT --
JUST AS FAR AS THE COMPONENTS
INSIDE BUT PRIMARILY WE WERE
TAKING IT AS IS SO WE HAD A
RATHER AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO
UTILIZE THAT PLAN AND SITE
LOCATED.
AT TAMA COUNTY --
A A CAMP KITCHEN IT'S DEFINITELY
HAVE A LOT OF CODE --
SITUATIONS WITH THAT --
BEING THAT IT'S AN INSTITUTION
SO IT HAS TO MEET --
CORRECTIONAL STANDARDS NOT
REGULAR COMMERCIAL STANDARDS --
IN.
EDUCATE ME MORE ON YOUR MIND.
I HAVE I'VE WE'RE LOOKING AT
FACILITIES STATIONS --
AND A LOT OF MONEY THAT GOES
INTO THE PRELIMINARY PLANS IN
THE WORKING DRAWINGS AND IT IT
IT.
IT SEEMS I DON'T WANNA TO DUMB
DOWN THE FACILITIES BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE WE SHOULD HAVE LIKE ONE
MODEL.
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE WHAT
THE CAL FIRE STATION WHO.
LOOKS LIKE AND FEELS LIKE IT'S
SORT OF THAT SOME ARCHITECTS
WOULD SAY HISTORICALLY WHEN YOU
WALKED INTO A POST OFFICE YOU
HAD THAT FEELING LIKE THIS WAS
THE POST OFFICE BUT DIDN'T
REDESIGN EVERY POST OFFICE THAT
YOU HAD.
SO I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF I'LL
GO TO ONE OF THESE.
FIRE STATIONS IN A REMOTE AREA
BUT IT SHOULD BE THE DORMITORY
SHOULD BE.
PRETTY.
SIMILAR AT LEAST NINETEEN
VERSION OF IT AND I JUST AS I GO
THROUGH AND I LOOK AT THIS IS
ANOTHER'S DRAWING FOR THIS IS
ANOTHER DRIVER THIS IS WORKING
DRAWING.
I'M READING A BOOK RIGHT NOW BUT
AS A MURDER MYSTERY ABOUT
DRAWINGS ARCHITECTURAL DRAWINGS
SOME VERY.
A TO PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION THAT.
WANT.
HELP ME OUT AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE BIGGER PICTURE HERE.
I THINK YOU'RE GENERALLY SAYING
HOW COME WE CAN'T COOKIE CUTTER
THESE AND GET THEM OUT FASTER.
THAT WOULD BE YET THAT WOULD BE --
YEAH WE DEFINITELY LOOK INTO
THAT -- AS
FAR AS LIKE TO MACULA WHICH IS A
PREVIOUS --
PREVIOUS BUDGET AND ELSINORE --
THOSE SHOULD BE --
VERY SIMILAR IF NOT EXACT AS FAR
AS THE STAFFING LEVEL THE
CLIMATE LOCATION SO AND
STRUCTURALLY AS FAR AS SEISMIC
ZONE SO WE WERE LOOKING TO TRY
AND UTILIZE THAT AND GET THAT.
PROJECT OUT ONE OF THE I WOULD
SAY GOALS OR PRODDING SAID WE'VE --
RECEIVED FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES EXECUTION WE NEED TO
EXECUTE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
NOT --
SPECIAL DESIGN.
EACH INDIVIDUAL PROJECT SO --
I BELIEVE IN THE C. --
ONE THIRTY PROPOSAL OUR ISSUE --
WE'RE LOOKING AT BUILDING THE
SAME BARRACKS IN ALL LOCATIONS.
SO WE PULLED OUR MOST CURRENT
PLAN WHICH IS THE CAR YOU
BECAUSE FIRE STATION THAT AS
JUST GOING THROUGH PLAN CHECK.
IT'S IN A BED BARRACKS WE'RE
LOOKING TO UTILIZE THAT INSIGHT
ADAPTED TO EACH OF THESE
LOCATIONS WHICH IS SHOULD BE.
OF QUITE SIMPLE BECAUSE AIRPORTS
IS OBVIOUSLY VERY FLAT SO WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF SITE WORK
THAT WE ASSUME.
THE OTHER --
THE ONLY CHANGE THAT WE COULD
FOR SEE IS --
HVAC BECAUSE THE CLIMATE BEING --
FAIRLY MINOR SORRY FROM BEING.
THAT'S I GET THE CONSTRUCTION
BUDGET AND AND AND THOSE THAT
PARK BUT THE CULINARY PLANS AND
IF IF IT'S AN ACQUISITION I GET
THAT THIS DIFFERENT LAN AND
DIFFERENT SITES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE SO I HAVE TO PAY WHAT.
BUT THE MARKET RATE AS ELLIE --
DO YOU HAVE A ANYTHING TO ADD.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH AS PACIFIC I'M CAPITAL A
PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN THE BUDGET
BUT JUST WANT TO NOTE FOR YOU.
I'M SO OUT OF THE FORTY MILLION
FOR CAPITAL A PROJECTS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
A LITTLE OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION OF THAT IS TO INITIATE
NINE NEW PROJECTS --
AND THAT INCLUDES THREE OF THE
BARRACKS PROJECTS RELATED TO THE
ISSUE WHEN THIRTY AIR TANKER
PROGRAM.
SO THOSE IN NINE NEW PROJECTS
I'M JUST FOR YOUR OUT YOUR
BUDGET PLANNING PURPOSES ARE
GONNA HAVE --
TOTAL COSTS OF ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT NOT INCLUDED
IN THIS BUDGET WOULD BE AND AN%
ADDITIONAL CLOSE TO ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL BERWICK'S PROJECTS
RELATED TO THE C. --
ONE THIRTY PROGRAM AM AND THE
ADDITION AROUND.
YOU KNOW SO THE THREE THAT ARE
IN THE BUDGET ARE RAMONA PASS A
RUTHLESS AND FRESNO AND THEN THE
ADDITIONAL.
ONE CHICO.
AND THAT'S NOT IN THIS BUDGET
BUT WE CAN IN THE FUTURE YEARS
ARE JUST IN TERMS OF THINKING
ABOUT YOUR OUT YOUR COSTS FOR
WHAT YOU'RE EXCEPT.
ANYTHING TO ADD.
NOTHING THAT CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHARGES I'M LOOKING THROUGH THE
BRIEFING DOCUMENT I'D.
I'M NOT SEEN.
THE CONTRACT COUNTIES PIECE OF
IT IS THAT BECAUSE IT'S IN A
SEPARATE.
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE.
I'M SORRY HOURS ARE MY COMMENTS.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS MATTER
OPEN AND MOVED --
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN AND OUR
LAST ISSUE THE CONTRACT COUNTY
CAPITAL OUTLAY OF THREE POINT
THREE MILLION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SO THIS
IS THE COUNTER CONTRACT BUT
COUNTY PIECE --
AND SO CAL FIRES AT IS
REQUESTING THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO GENERAL FUND.
TO RESTORE THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT --
PROPORTIONAL FUNDING FOR THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES OF LA ORANGE --
SANTA BARBARA VENTURE --
KERN AND MARIN COUNTY'S.
THE REQUESTED ASKED.
FOR THESE FUNDS --
AND OF THE WE'VE USED --
TRADITIONALLY TO BE REINSTATED
THIS IS A A NEGOTIATED RATE THAT --
WE'VE COME TO WITH THE A
CONTRACT COUNTIES --
IN AGREEMENT WITH AND THAT IS --
APPROXIMATELY IN 19%.
OF CALIFORNIA --
IS --
PREVIOUS FISCAL YEAR LIKE FOR
LIKE DOLLARS SO IT'S 19% OF WHAT
WE SPENT LAST YEAR ON ON ON OUR
OUR OUR FISCAL I MEAN ON OUR
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
AND THAT IT WOULD BE EXTENDED.
TO THE CONTRACT COUNTIES --
TO A TO DO THE SAME TYPE OF WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE.
IN THE ENSUING YEAR --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROPORTIONAL
FUNDING METHOD AND FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
IS IS.
THE WAY TO GO AND IT ALLOWS --
FOR THE FLUCTUATION IN OUR OUR
BUDGET AND OUR OUR CYCLE --
TO ME OR WHAT THE CONTRACT
CONTRACT COUNTIES --
WOULD GET OUT OF THAT SAME --
FUNDING MECHANISM --
AND NOT END UP WITH IN SOME
YEARS AND MUCH LESS IN OTHER
YEARS.
I GUESS THE STAFF REPORT THIS IS
THE SORT OF A GUESSTIMATE ON
RATHER THAN THE ACTUAL
REIMBURSEMENT THAT THEY'RE
GETTING GETTING LA --
DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT
YEAH SO AND JUST.
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE HISTORY AND
THAT THAT THE STATE USED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING A CONTRACT
COUNTIES FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
HAS NOT PROVIDED THAT FUNDING.
SENSE --
TWELVE THIRTEEN WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY PROVIDING.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN I'M AND SO IT
YOU KNOW AS YOU'RE WINNING YOUR
OVERALL GENERAL FROM PRIORITIES
AND MEET YOU KNOW.
REINSTATING THIS FUNDING IS
REASONABLE CONTRACT COUNTIES ARE
PROVIDING A SERVICE TO THE STATE
AND CAL FIRE AND THEY OBVIOUSLY
NEED.
FACILITIES AND FIRE STATIONS TO
DO THAT AS TO THE OVERALL
CONCEPT IS REASONABLE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH JUST
REINSTATE THE I AM PRIOR FORMULA
ON THE FORMULA THEY USE TO FIND
THE SUPPORT.
AND THAT THAT'S ONE WAY TO DO IT --
WHEN WE'VE LOOKED AT IT THE THE
FORMULA THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY SIDE AND NOT
COMMENTING ON HOW THE SAME
FORMULA IS USED ON THEY JUST
GENERAL SUPPORT FOR THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES BUT ON THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY SIDE?
IT'S NOT BASED ON WHAT THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY NEEDS ARE.
AND AND SO EASY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
REALLY TIED TO THE NEEDS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO USE THAT FORMULA
IF YOU DECIDE THAT YOU WANT TO
RINSTATE THE FUNDING TEAM YOU
MIGHT CHOOSE TO DO THAT --
FOR CONSISTENCY'S SAKE WITH THE
WAY WE HOW MUCH MONEY WANT TO
GIVING GIVING THEM THAT AMOUNT
EVERY YEAR --
WE AND TOOK A LOOK BACK IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PROVIDED
US THIS INFORMATION IF THAT
FORMULA HAD BEEN IN PLACE OVER
THE LAST ROUGHLY A DECADE OR SO.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WOULD
BE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE LOWEST
YEAR AND NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TOTAL TO BE SPLIT
AMONGST THE SIX CONTRACT COUNTY
SO.
KIND OF BASICALLY NOTHING WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THAT
BUYS YOU IN TERMS OF CAPITAL
OUTLAY. TO NINE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE HIGHEST
YEAR.
I'M SO IN --
IF YOU ARE COMFORTABLE HAVING
THAT TYPE OF FLUCTUATION BUT
AGAIN THERE'S NO WE NEED TO TO
ACTUALLY USE THIS FORMULA
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BASED ON WHAT
THEIR ACTUAL NEEDS ARE.
WE WE KIND OF RECOGNIZE THE BE
PROBABLY DIFFICULT TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE YOU SAY WHAT THOSE
NEEDS ARE IT COULD BE VERY
EXPENSIVE --
AND IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED
QUESTION TO ANSWER AND TO
CONTINUALLY UPDATE THE DATA AND
SO WE THINK MAYBE JUST PICKING
THEM OUT IS IS A SIMPLER
APPROACH FOR YOU YOU COULD PICK
THE AMOUNT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR AT THE THREE POINT THREE
MILLION THE AVERAGE OF WHAT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS TO BE ABOUT TWO POINT
TWO MILLION.
THAT WE COULD PICK SOME OTHER
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THEN YOU CAN EVEN SET UP A
PROCESS TO REVISIT THE AMOUNT
OVER TIME.
SURE I UNDERSTAND WHAT WERE
INCLUDING IN THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
OR BUT WE'RE NOT INCLUDING AND
WE'RE NOT INCLUDING HELICOPTERS
RIGHT WE'RE NOT INCLUDING.
THE C. ONE THIRTIES RIGHT WERE
OVER WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
PHYSICAL WE'RE NOT INCLUDING THE
FIRE TRUCKS. TWO I AM TAKING
THIS A FUNDING SPECIFICALLY AS
RELATED TO THE SORT OF THAT
CAPITAL OUTLAY EXPENDITURES AND
REALLY WHAT THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT IS IS THAT WE FIND
THE STATE FIND IN --
SORT OF A PROPORTIONAL AMOUNT --
TO BASED ON SORT OF WHAT THE
CONTRACT COUNTIES NEEDS ARE TO
PROVIDE EQUIVALENT FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND SAID THAT --
THAT COMES DOWN TO THE NAY UPSET
OF CAL FIRES TOTAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY EXPENDITURES IN THE PRIOR
FISCAL YEAR.
AND AND IS REALLY TAKING THE
CALCULATION ON LIKE FOR LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE TYPE OF
FACILITIES THAT THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES --
ARE OPERATING --
WHERE IS THERE MAY BE SOME TYPES
OF FACILITIES --
THAT ARE IT SORT OF LIKE FOR
LIKE WHERE THEY'RE CAL FIRE
OPERATED FACILITIES THEY THAT
DIRECTOR CAN PROBABLY EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN MYSELF.
BUT IF I UNDERSTAND THIS MARIN
COUNTY LET'S PICK ON MARIN
BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY HERE FROM.
FIRE CHIEF IS HERE LET'S PICK
LET'S PICK ON MY LIST BECOME RAN
LET'S SAY THEY COME THERE'S
SPORTY SUPERVISORS DECIDE THAT
THEY WANT TO UPDATE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THAT THEIR FACILITIES ARE.
AND THEY WANT TO UPDATE ALL
THEIR FIRE FACILITIES.
WE WOULD.
DO WE WOULD.
THE CALIFORNIA TO HAVE TO
ACTIVATE THE CITY TAKE THE
ACTION WE WOULD PAY FOR THE
PORTION OF THE FACILITY COSTS
THAT WOULD --
THAT THEY WE USE FOR KALIFORNIA
ASSISTANCE IN THE AREA.
NO NOT NOT STRUCTURED NOT BASED
ON HOW THE METHODOLOGY
METHODOLOGY IS STRUCTURED SO IN
YOUR IN THE CASE OF YOUR EXAMPLE
MARIN COUNTY WOULD TAKE THE
ACTIONS TO UPDATE THEIR
FACILITIES AND THEN A FEW YEARS
OUT FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE
PURSUANT TO THE METHODOLOGY
BASED ON WHAT TELL FIRE.
SPENDS ON ITS CAPITAL PROGRAM.
HI.
I THINK AS THE ELLIE --
IS HAS RECOGNIZED SORT OF THE
NEEDS AT THE LCAL LEVEL ARE ARE
FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL BEYOND JUST
THE FACILITIES THAT SORT OF SIR
PROVIDE THAT CONTRACT COUNTY
SERVICE. TO WEAR BUT BUT IN
ORDER TO DO SO AGAIN WE'RE
TRYING TO MEET THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT WHICH IS AND AND SO
THIS IS THE WAY THAT'S BEEN.
UTILIZED OVER TIME THE
METHODOLOGY THAT'S BEEN PUT
FORWARD AND WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
ANY CONCERNS --
BY THE CONTRACT COUNTIES WITH
THIS METHODOLOGY I WOULD ALSO
NOTE YOU KNOW THERE'S VERY
ABILITY IN OUR STATE CAPITOL
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF WHAT WE FIND
FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY ON A YEAR TO
YEAR BASIS AND THIS METHODOLOGY
IS CAN IS CONSISTENT --
YOU KNOW WITH THAT METHODOLOGY
OUR TRACKS WITH THAT METHODOLOGY.
WITH OR THAT VERY ABILITY RATHER
I'M GONNA OPEN THE PUBLIC FINAL
THOUGHTS YEAH I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT I AM.
WHAT WHILE WHAT'S PROPOSED HERE
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
METHODOLOGY METHODOLOGY THAT'S
BEEN USED AND THERE IS A STATUTE
AND THERE IS A?
GENERAL OPINION ABOUT.
I'M BASING IT ON HOW MUCH THE
STATE SPENDS I'M THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT NECESSARILY
BOUND TO TO THAT BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN PROVIDING THIS
FUNDING.
SO IF YOU WERE BOUND TO THAT
THEN WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING THE SPENDING AT THAT
THE SAME FORMULA OUT OVER ALL
THESE YEARS AND THIS WOULD NOT
BE A QUESTION FOR YOU TODAY --
AND SO YOU KNOW WE DO THINK THAT
YOU HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY IS
CERTAINLY REINSTATING THE OLD
FORMULA IS ONE WAY TO DO IT BUT
IT'S BEEN ALMOST TEN YEARS SINCE
YOU PROVIDED THIS FUNDING AND IT
COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK --
AND IN YOUR EXAMPLE WHERE THAT
FIRE STATION IN MARIN AND THAT
WOULD BE BASED ON THE ACTUAL
NEEDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THIS IS
BASED ON WHAT CAL FIRE SPENDING
ON ITS FACILITIES AND SAYING
WILL BECAUSE WE BILL YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THOSE NINE NEWS STATIONS OR
WHATEVER.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO TRANSLATE
INTO THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY AND SO
IT'S REALLY NOT TIED TO THE
MEANS AND SELL EITHER WE THINK
YOU JUST HAVE OPTIONS IT'S SORT
OF A GOOD NEIGHBOR.
APPROACH TO THESE FOLKS THAT ARE
PROVIDING THESE THAT THE
SERVICES AND IN THIS AREA.
OKAY -- IF
MY COLLEAGUES OR HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
NO GO AHEAD ASK AS YOUR QUESTION --
CENTER STERN.
THINK.
OF
SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN FOR THE
QUESTION --
SO WITH THE CONTRACT COUNTIES
ACTUALLY HAVE STE THE FACILITIES
THAT -- IN
MANY CASES WAR STATE FACILITIES
BEFORE THEY BECAME A CONTRACT
COUNTY.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE SAME
FACILITIES WERE TALKING ABOUT WE
HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S CALLED THE
GREAT BOOK WE TRACK ALL OF THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE --
THAT RE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS TYPE
OF FUNDING AND ALL OF THE
ENGINES AND AND OTHER EQUIPMENT
AND PERSONNEL.
UNDER A GREAT BOOK SO THE
GREYBULL THESE ARE THE ONES THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. FOR FOR USE
OF THIS MONEY --
HOWEVER.
THAT IS NOT HOW WE'RE WE'RE
ASSESSING THEIR NEEDS THE THAN
THAT NEEDS ARE NOT PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION AS MUCH AS IT'S A
PROPORTIONAL --
AMOUNT OF WHAT CAL FIRE IS
GETTING TO TO MAINTAIN THE
STRUCTURES AND THE FACILITIES
THAT ARE LIKE FOR LIKE IN THOSE
GRAY BOOK OR THOSE CONTRACT
COUNTY LOCATIONS SO.
IF I HAVE A FIRE STATION A
CALIFORNIA FIRE STATION AND I'M
GONNA.
I'M GONNA REBUILD IT THAT A
PORTION OF THAT FUNDING WE'RE
ANTICIPATING THE CURRENT
CONTRACT COUNTIES ALSO NEED TO
DO. TO MAINTAIN THE BUILDINGS
THAT WE LEFT THEM WITH.
WHAT IS THIS GUY?
IS THERE A AT THE BAR THEY ASK
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF
NEED OUT THERE HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM.
ANY OF THESE COUNTIES ABOUT SORT
OF WHAT THE OVERALL SENSES --
THE OVERALL SCOPE I MEAN I'M A
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT
IT WHAT WHAT WE LOOKING AND
FOURTEEN IT'S THREE POINT THREE
MILLION HERE BUT FOR THE THE
VARIOUS CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
FOR WORD FORTY MILLION OBVIOUS
IT NEEDS IN A BE FAR GREATER AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CAPACITY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL --
THERE TOO BUT JUST GIVE A SENSE
OF WHAT SIMILARLY THESE THESE
FACILITIES ARE IN SIMILAR --
AGE CATEGORIES --
AS THEY ARE ACROSS THE STATE IN
IN GREAT BOOK VERSUS OUR BLUE
BOOK -- AND
THE THOSE ARE THE LIKE FOR LIKE --
STATIONS.
AND FACILITIES --
SO THEY ARE VERY MUCH IN THE
SAME STATE --
IT DAILY IN SOME CASES COUNTIES
HAVE SUBSIDIZED THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON STATIONS AND
BROUGHT STATIONS --
UP TO A CODE OR THE NEEDS OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY THAT HAS GROWN
UP AROUND THEM.
AND SO -- IN
SOME CASES THIS THIS MONEY --
WOULD LIKELY BE BACK FILL FOR
SOME OF THOSE THINGS THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY DONE TO
SOME OF THE THE GREAT BOOKS
STATIONS.
I WOULD JUST REITERATE THE POINT
I MADE EARLIER AND TO THE EXTENT.
WHEN WE HAVE?
THESE FACILITIES GO DOWN DURING
AN INCIDENT BECAUSE OF LACK OF
ABILITY MAINTAIN HAVE AN
ADEQUATE ELECTRICAL BACKUP POWER
RESILIENT SYSTEMS OR WHATEVER
ELSE GOING TO SPENDING IS
CAPITAL --
ON YET WE WANT TO HELP YOU
BECAUSE IT'S WHEN WHEN RESIDENCY.
THEIR ACTUAL FIRE STATION SHUT.
YEAH THIS HAPPENED A NUMBER
TIMES DURING THESE PAST FEW
INCIDENTS AND IT'S IT'S
DISTURBING AND IT'S SOMETHING I
THINK IT'S SOLVABLE BUT I YEAH
WE'LL WE'LL WAIT TILL HE IF WE
HEAR FROM ANY COUNTIES BUT I'M
HAPPY.
TO HELP YOU GUYS WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THAT BECAUSE YET WHEN
YOU JOIN YOUR FEET WHEN.
THINGS HIT THE FAN.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THERE YOU ARE NOW I'D LIKE TO
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
PORTION OF THIS MATTER ARE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION THIS WILL BE.
ISSUES.
WE GET IT RIGHT.
NOT 891-112-1314 AND FIFTEEN
MISTER REED THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EARN READ
REPRESENTING A CALIFORNICA
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING DRESSED LIKE
THIS I WHEN SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
TERRY MCHALE WAS BUT HE'S A NEW
GRANDPA AS A FEW HOURS AGO HIS
DAUGHTER HAD A GRANDSON.
HIS SECOND GRAND CHILD SO HE'S
AT THE HOSPITAL WHERE HE SHOULD
BE -- SO
APOLOGIZE FOR MY CASUAL DRESS --
I FIRST WANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IN DEPTH HEARING TODAY I AM
AWARE OF THE HOUR YOU'LL HAVE
LONG DISTANCES TO GO BACK TO
YOUR DISTRICTS ALL BE VERY QUICK --
CENTER MCGUIRE WILL AGREE WITH
YOU 1000%.
ALL YOUR POINT ABOUT WE CAN'T DO
ENOUGH THIRTEEN ENGINES IS NOT
ENOUGH THIRTY ONES NOT ENOUGH
OKAY.
I GO BACK FORTY NINE YEARS I
STARTED YEARS AGO BUT I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS SORT OF WORK SINCE
REAGAN'S FIRST TERM AS GOVERNOR
SO IT'S BEEN AWHILE.
OF CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS LACKED
THE RESOURCES TO DO THE JOB
ADEQUATELY THEY HAD.
OLD EQUIPMENT OLD AIRPLANES I'M
A LIFELONG PILOT I WOULDN'T FLY
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT THEY HAD
TO FLY.
IT WAS MARGINALLY AIRWORTHY.
SO YOU MAKE GREAT STRIDES THANK
YOU FOR THE HELICOPTERS THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT IN THE PAST
AND I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR LEANING IN THIS TIME.
IN THE THIRTEEN ENGINES IS A
GOOD START WE DO WANT TO SAY IT
SHOULD BE THIRTY ONE FORGET THE
EIGHT ORANGE COUNTY HAD EVEN
WITHOUT THAT I MEAN WE NEED.
REALLY --
FOUR HUNDRED THEY'RE GONNA DO IS
PRETTY G. PLAN I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM ON THAT.
A AS YOU KNOW BETTER THAN I DO.
WHEN IT DEPARTMENT DOES A PLAN
LIKE THAT IT HAS TO GO THROUGH
THEIR AGENCY IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH FINANCE IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR?
SO THAT PLAN MIGHT NOT LOOK.
EXACTLY LIKE IT WAS IN THE VERY
BEGINNING BECAUSE IT GETS
CHOPPED DOWN THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
I'VE SEEN IT.
HUNDREDS OF TIMES OVER FORTY
NINE YEARS SO --
BUT I HOPE THAT THE PLAN BUT WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE AT LEAST THE
THIRTY ONE ENGINES IN THE
STAFFING THAT GOES WITH IT.
THE FIRE SEASON IS NOW TWO AND A
HALF MONTHS LONGER.
THAN IT WAS IN IN MANY MANY
CASES AROUND THE STATE FIRE
SEASON IS YEAR ROUND.
THAT'S JUST SIMPLY THE CASE
WE'VE HAD FIRES THE THOMAS FIRE
BURNED WELL INTO.
DECEMBER --
YOU KNOW IS THERE A IN THE I
DON'T HAVE TO TALK ABOUT.
THE FIRE CONDITIONS IT'S
TERRIBLE AUTHOR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DEAD AND DYING
TREES -- IS
GONNA TAKE HIS DECADES TO DIG
OUT OF ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW ONE ENGINE FOR
NINETY THOUSAND ACRES. ONE
ENGINE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH WE'RE WAY SHORT
SO TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THAT I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR FOR THE
MONEY ON MENTAL ON THE HEALTH
CARE.
OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS IT'S A
REALLY TOUGH JOB I'VE BEEN ON US
I CAN'T EVEN COUNT HOW MANY
FIRES AT BEEN ON IN I'VE HAD THE
BE JESUS SCARED OUT OF CREDIBLE.
WALLS OF FLAME YOU CAN IMAGINE
AND THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN OUT
RUN THESE FIRES IT THEY MAKE
THEIR OWN WHETHER.
IT'S A VERY VERY TOUGH JOB --
YOU KNOW THAT THE URBAN
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE TO INTO OUT
RULE THAT BREATHING APPARATUS
WITH.
IN THE WILD LAND.
IT IS STILL THE WILD WEST.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR HEARING
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THAT --
WE DID HAVE A LEYVA BILL LAST
YEAR THEY WENT TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL MONEY ON ON
DEEPER RESEARCH ON ON SOME OF
THE HEALTH ISSUES THAT ARE
FIREFIGHTERS FACE --
THE RECOMMENDED JERRY BROWN VETO
THE BILL SAID DO IT IN THE
BUDGET --
WILL GIVE YOU A WRITTEN PROPOSAL
ON THAT IS NOT ON YOUR AGENDA
TODAY -- SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ITEM FOR ANOTHER
DAY.
BUT AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR FREE TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATOR CORY CELLS --
HERE ON BEHALF OF DEALINGS.
THANK YOU FOR THE TENSION YOU
PROVIDED IN THIS HEARING AND THE
OUTSIDE OF THIS HEARING --
DEALINGS IS PLEASED TO WORK WITH --
THE ENTITIES HERE TODAY --
THE ALERT WILD FOR PROJECT THE
PLACING OF CAMERAS OF THIS IS
SPECIFIC TO ISSUE A AND NOT ONLY
CAMERAS AS A FOCUS BUT ALSO
BUILDING A FIX --
WIRELESS INTERNET CONNECTIVITY
THAT NOT ONLY KEEPS THE CAMERAS
LINKED UP --
HELPS PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
TO THE FIREFIGHTERS IN THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO NEED THAT
INFORMATION BUT WHO CAN ALSO
PROVIDE THE DATA.
ABOUT --
WHETHER MONITORING AS YOU
POINTED OUT MISTER CHAIR
POLLUTION SENSING THAT SORT OF
THING ALL OF THESE THINGS CAN BE
BILL TOGETHER AND IT'S REALLY
THIS FOUNDATIONAL BROAD NETWORK
THAT UPPORTS THE CAMERAS ON
THESE OTHER TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT HELP WITH THE EFFORT SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TODAY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL LOOK FOR TO BEING A
RESOURCE TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
AN MARIN COUNTY.
SHARE WITH CASKEY CENTERS THANK
YOU JASON WEBER MARIN COUNTY
FIRE CHIEF REPRESENTING --
ASSOCIATION A CONTRACT COUNTIES --
YOU KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT PIECES HERE IS THAT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
REESTABLISHING THE THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDING BUT ALSO SHOULD
WE HAVE IS SO IMPORTANT WITH CAL
FIRE AND IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
RELATIONSHIPS STUDY WAS DONE.
REALLY HIGHLIGHTED THE MUTUAL
BENEFITS HERE IN THAT THE STATE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BEAR ALL OF
THOSE COSTS THAT WERE ABLE TO
SHARE THAT IN THOSE THOSE
COUNTIES.
AND IT'S MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL AND
I THINK THAT THIS REQUEST AND
FUNNY TODAY AT 19% ALSO PROVIDES
MUTUAL BENEFIT IN MOVING FORWARD
WE SHARE.
UNFORTUNATELY SAME CHALLENGES OF
FACILITIES AND AND FIRE
PROTECTION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR SEVEN YEARS TO RE ESTABLISH
THIS FUNDING --
YOU KNOW WE WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE 19% FORMULA MOVING
FOR WE DON'T FEEL IT'S ARBITRARY
AT ALL AND IS ACTUALLY TIED.
TO THE NUMBER OF ENGINES AND
PERCENTAGE TO TO WHAT CAL FIRE
HOUSE AND ALL THOSE ENGINES OF
COURSE HAVE FACILITIES THAT THEY
NEED TO BE HOUSE THAT --
ADDITIONALLY WE FEEL AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL POSITION WAS
PRETTY CLEAR THAT --
THE FUNDING IS IS DUE TO THE
COUNTY SO AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THE WORKING RELATIONSHIP OF
STATE I THINK IT'S MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S TIME HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
MYSTERY YOU WANTED AT THE SECOND
BY THE APPLE.
IN MY CASE I'VE I I WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU TO IS A SENATOR
STERN.
HE BROUGHT UP AN ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN NOT DISCUSS PUBLICLY FOR A
LONG LONG TIME I'VE BEEN AWARE
OF IT --
SUICIDE RATES VERY HIGH.
WE JUST DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT
SORT OF THING THE STRESS IS VERY
HIGH THANK YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THAT ISSUE.
HE HAS LEGISLATION ON THE
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY CAN PARTICIPATE TODAY
WE ARE TURN [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT GOING